AND I THANK EVERYONE FOR BEING
HERE FOR OUR APRIL THIRD LABOR
AND EMPLOYMENT MEETING.
WE DO NOT HAVE QUORUM YET BUT
OUT OF RESPECT FOR EVERYONE'S
TIME BILL START AS A SUB
COMMITTEE WITH THE MEMBERS THAT
ARE PRESENT -- AND I JUST WANT
TO LET.
THE PARTIES IT WILL BE COMING
BEFORE US FOR THE VARIOUS BILLS
KNOWN OUR MIND -- AUTHORS AS A
AS A SHOW UP.
THAT ON THE BILL BEFORE US TODAY
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT AS WELL AS
TESTIMONY OPPOSITION WILL BE
LIMITED TO UP TO SIX MINUTES PER
SIDE ALL SIX MINUTES DON'T HAVE
TO BE USED BUT ALL ALLOW THE
AUTHORS DECIDE HOW THEY WANT TO
DIVVY UP.
THAT SIX MINUTES AMONGST THEIR
WITNESSES.
SO.
NOW WITH OUR VICE CHAIR ACTUALLY
BEGIN -- HAVE A MADAM SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL IN AND ESTABLISH
KERR BEFORE YOU BEGIN
[inaudible]
KALRA [inaudible]
FLORA [inaudible]
CARILLO [inaudible]
THE GONZALEZ.
JONES SAWYER THREE OF US.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WHILE WE
HAVE A QUORUM ESTABLISHED CAN I
HAVE A MOTION -- FOR AB EIGHTEEN
OH FOUR WHICH IS THE SOLE ITEM
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SAID AS A COMMITTEE ITEM.
SO WE HAVE A MOTION FROM SUMMIT
IS AWESOME SECOND VICE.
OUR VICE CHAIR FLORA ME PLEASE --
MATTERS I RECALL ROLE MOTION IS
D. PASSED CONSENT TO
APPROPRIATIONS KALRA AYE KALRA
AYE FLORA.
FLORA I'D CARILLO DEEP.
THE I GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I JONES SAWYER THREE OF
US [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AND SO THE MORE MOVE ON TO THE
FIRST BILL WILL BE HEARING TODAY
WHICH IS AB THREE SEVENTY EIGHT
SOME OF THEM ARE -- LIMON SO
SOME OF THE MALL PLEASE -- GET
YOURSELF SITUATED IN BEGIN
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS AYE
AB THREE SEVENTY EIGHT SEEKS TO
CREATE A SUSTAINABLE CAREER
PATHWAY AND SUPPORT THOSE WHO
EDUCATE.
AND CARE FOR OUR EARLIEST
LEARNERS CALIFORNIA'S EARLY CARE
AND EDUCATION WORKFORCE IS
COMPRISED PRIMARILY OF WOMEN AND
PREDOMINANTLY OF WOMEN OF COLOR.
THIS IS THE WORK FORCE THAT
OFTEN DOES NOT EARN A LIVABLE
WAGE AND QUALIFIES FOR THE SAME
SUBSIDIES.
THE FAMILIES THEY SERVE USE.
AS THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY.
WORKFORCE ISSUES FOR OUR CURRENT
WORK FIRST AND FUTURE WORK FIRST
MUST REMAIN AT THE FOREFRONT OF
OUR THINKING.
THE STABILITY IS BROUGHT TO THE
EARLY CHILD CARE EDUCATION WORK
FORCE WHEN A SOLID FOUNDATION IN
QUALITY.
AND REIMBURSEMENT IS IN PLACE
AND WE KNOW WHEN FAMILIES HAVE
ACCESS TO HIGH QUALITY CARE
PARENTS ARE MORE PRODUCTIVE IN
THE WORK FORCE AND CHILDREN ARE
SET UP.
SET UP TO SUCCEED LEADER IN
EDUCATION AND IN LIFE.
THE ASSEMBLY BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSION ON CHILD CARE WORKED
TIRELESSLY OVER THE LAST TWO
YEARS TO DEVELOP A COMPREHENSIVE
SET OF RECOMMENDATIONS.
IN ADDRESSING THE ISSUES WITH
THE CURRENT EASY WORK FORCE ONE
OF THEIR RECOMMENDATION IS TO
SUPPORT COLLECT COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING RIGHTS FOR FAMILY
CHILD.
CARE HOME PROVIDERS BOTH LICENSE
AND FAMILY FRIENDLY AND OR
NEIGHBOR.
CALIFORNIA RUNS A TWENTY FOUR
HOUR A DAY WORKFORCE BUT OUR
CHILD CARE OPTIONS FOR WORKING
FAMILIES DO NOT MEET THAT NEED
NOR DO THEY SUPPORT THOSE WHO
PROVIDE CHILD CARE.
THIS BILL PROFESSIONAL EYES AND
CREATES A STABILITY FOR FAMILY
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS BY MAKING
QUALITY TRAINING AVAILABLE TO
ALL PROVIDERS THROUGH COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING.
AB THREE SEVENTY PROVIDES A
HOLISTIC FRAMEWORK TO ADDRESS
BOTH PROVIDER PAY INEQUITY AND
THE LACK OF ACCESSIBLE CHILD
CARE.
JOINING ME TODAY WE HAVE
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS.
RACINE AT RECESS AND LEVY APPLE
D. GUESS OF MERRY GO WITH THE
ADDRESS FROM S. YEAH YOU IS HERE
TO ASSIST WITH THE TRANSLATION.
AND DâN ERIN -- IS HERE
REPRESENTING SCA YOU AND ASKS ME
AND CAN ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS THAT MAY COME UP THANK
YOU [inaudible]
HELLO.
MY NAME IS RUTH SCENERIES AND
FOR THE PAST NINETEEN YEARS I
HAVE BEEN A FAMILY CHILDCARE
PROVIDER IN SAN BERNADINO COUNTY.
I ALSO RUN A NONPROFIT CALLED
WOMEN OF NOBLE CHARACTER.
I CURRENTLY CARE FOR TWENTY
CHILDREN SIXTEEN OF WHICH ARE ON
A STATE SUBSIDY AND I HAVE FOUR
CHILDREN OF MY OWN.
I AM ALSO A PROUD MEMBER OF
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS UNITED A
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN YOU D. W.
ASKED ME AN STI YOU LOCALS
NINETY NINE AND FIVE TWENTY ONE
I LIKE THOUSANDS OF FAMILY CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
SPEND COUNTLESS HOURS NURTURING
AND EDUCATING INFANTS TODDLERS
AND SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN.
IN MANY CASES WE OFF AROUND THE
CLOCK CARE SEVEN DAYS A WEEK SO
THAT PARENTS WORKING
NONTRADITIONAL WORK HOURS HAVE A
SAFE PLACE TO LEAVE THEIR
CHILDREN.
I AM PASSIONATE ABOUT MY WORK
AND I'M GRATEFUL THAT I GET TO
LIVE MY CALLING.
BUT THERE'S A VERY DARK SIDE TO
CHILDCARE THE GOES BEYOND DIRTY
DIAPERS AND TEMPER TANTRUMS.
WELL I SUPPORT PARENTS SO THEY
CAN MOVE THEMSELVES OUT OF
POVERTY BY CARING FOR THEIR MOST
VALUABLE TREASURES THEIR
CHILDREN.
I STAND THERE ALONG WITH THEM ON
THE BRINK OF HAVING NOTHING. ONE
DECISION MAKERS SAY THAT I DO
VALUABLE WORK THE LAW SAYS
SOMETHING ELSE THE LAW SAYS THAT
I AM DISPOSABLE BECAUSE
PROVIDERS LIKE ME ARE NOT EVEN
SEEN WORTHY ENOUGH. TO BE
COVERED BY BASIC WORKER
PROTECTIONS LIKE A MINIMUM WAGE
WORKERS COMPENSATION OR EVEN
HEALTHCARE.
I AM LITERALLY AN ILLNESS AWAY
FROM LOSING IT ALL.
I AM AN EARLY EDUCATOR IN A
STATE WITH THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD AND YET I
DO NOT EARN A LIVING WAGE.
INSTEAD I QUALIFY FOR THE SAME
SUBSIDY I PROVIDE.
CIRCUMSTANCES LIKE THESE HAVE
CONSEQUENCES AND THEY DID FOR ME.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT UNABLE
TO MAKE MY MORTGAGE I LOST MY
HOME WELL LOSING ONE'S HOME IS
TRAGIC ENOUGH FOR A FAMILY
CHILDCARE PROVIDER.
THE EXPERIENCE IS EVEN MORE
DRAMATIC BECAUSE WHEN WE LOSE
OUR HOME WE LOSE OUR ABILITY TO
EARN A LIVING.
MY STORY IS ONE OF MANY AND A
GLARING EXAMPLE OF THE DEEP
CRACKS IN CALIFORNIA'S CHILD
CARE SYSTEM THAT NOT ONLY IMPACT
FAMILY CHILD CARE PROVIDERS LIKE
ME.
BUT OUR CHILDREN AND PARENTS WHO
RELY ON US.
THAT'S WHY I LIKE MY CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS SISTERS STANDING
BEHIND ME HAVE BEEN FIGHTING FOR
FIFTEEN YEARS FOR THE RIGHT TO
FORMER UNION AND COLLECTIVELY
BARGAINED WITH THE STATE.
WE WANT TO JOIN PROVIDERS AND
ELEVEN AND ELEVEN OTHER STATES
WHO HAVE NOT ONLY SING
IMPROVEMENTS TO THEIR LIVES BUT
ALSO TO THOSE OF THE CHILDREN
AND PARENTS THEY SERVE.
AS WELL AS TO THEIR PROFESSION
ONCE THEY BECOME REAL PARTNERS
WITH THE STATE.
WE SHOULDN'T HAVE TO CHOOSE
BETWEEN THE CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES WE LOVE CARING FOR
EVERY DAY AND PUTTING FOOD ON
THE TABLE FOR OUR OWN CHILDREN.
THEREFORE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE FOR EIGHTY THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
NUMBER THREE THAT ARE THE
BIGGEST EITHER ON THE LIST OF
THE MOST IS HE SAID DANIEL
SAFETY THE PROBIOTIC WITHOUT
INVENTED. FOR ME LET IN WHAT
SOME MADE MY NAME IS LYDIA
PROPERTY GUESTS ON FOR THE PAST
SEVENTEEN YEARS I'VE BEEN A
FAMILY CHILDCARE PROVIDER IN
WATSONVILLE.
I THOUGHT IT MEANT THAT WE LOOK
AT THOSE TO NINOS SIT THERE
THERE YOUR SPELLING BECOME BUT I
IN SWEET CBO.
THAT MEANS A MOTHER THAT BUT
THREE HOLES YEAH WELL EITHER.
ONE I CARE FOR FOURTEEN CHILDREN
SEVEN OF WHOM ARE ON SUBSIDY I
AM ALSO THE MOTHER OF FOUR
CHILDREN THE GRANDMOTHER OF ONE
OTHER MONTHLY MEMBER WE ALSO
MEANT THAT PROVIDE THE WHAT
EXACTLY THAT IN FRONT.
OF ME THIS. ONE PROJECT -- AND
TODAY.
WILL THERE THE LITTLE THE LITTLE
GUY LAST MOMENT I KNOW I HAVE A
SINGLE INTO AND I'M ALSO PROUD
MEMBER OF CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
UNITED A PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN YOU
W. AND S. YEAH YOU LOCALS NINETY
NINE AND FIVE TWO ONE MAKE THEM
THEM AT THAT LEVEL FROM ABROAD
WITHOUT.
I THINK WITHOUT IN FRONT THE
FRONT MEDIA BUT GETS SAY.
GIVE ME THAT I'M A LICENSE IN
YELLOW NINOS LED BY YOURSELF
THAT LET ME INVEST.
CAN ASSIST THE THUMB BUT A
COMMON SIDE CAN THAT.
REBELS I LOVE MY JOB AS A FAMILY
CHILDCARE PROVIDER BECAUSE I
KNOW THAT MY WORK IS HELPING
CHILDREN WITH THE VALUABLE TOOLS
THEY NEED TO START SCHOOL
KINDERGARTEN READY.
IT WAS IMPORTANT THEY MEET THAT
ALLOW YOU LEVELS BY THE DECIDED
THAT THAT ARE HOT.
BUT I GET WHEN I MONTH IN AND
ASSIST BY MEDIA.
AND JUST AS IMPORTANTLY MY WORK
HELPS PARENTS GO TO WORK SO THEY
CAN PROVIDE FOR THEIR OWN
FAMILIES.
AT THE MOMENT THEY WE DON'T KNOW
NINO THAT BY THE DAY SKILL LEVEL
AND I'M COMMITTED ABOUT HOW THIS
ARTICLE LAST.
A LITTLE BIT OF A HASSLE MUST I
THINK WITHOUT INVENTIVE WELL I
AM PASSIONATE ABOUT THE WORK
THAT I DO I OFTEN WISH THE STATE
WAS MORE PASSIONATE ABOUT ME AS
A FAMILY CHILDCARE PROVIDER.
AT THIS SAID THE CAMEL MEAT THAT
I'VE UP ON A BUS ON THE YEAH CAN
I STILL LOOK CHANDLER YES THAT I
FOUND THAT.
THE MALONIC DECADE I'M NOT BUT
I'M AND THEN AT ME FROM MEDIA
[inaudible]
IT'S GONNA.
LOU CHECK ON SUNDAY BY THAT LOVE
THAT SO THEY ME FROM MEDIA ON
SATELLITE IS MENTAL.
THERE'S A LOT TO ME ANYMORE WELL
I LOVE MY JOB THERE'S NOT A DAY
THAT GOES BY WHERE I'M NOT
STRUGGLING OR STRESSED OUT.
AS THE SOLE BREADWINNER FOR MY
FAMILY MAKING ENDS MEET ON LESS
THAN MINIMUM WAGE IS A CONSTANT
STRUGGLE.
ESOS IN MEN'S YOU'RE NOT GET
YOUR COST YOU ANYTHING GET ONE
AT ALL.
IF UP A LITTLE THEY LET HIM
STAND.
WILL LOOK AT THAT -- Là WHOLE
SIGNIFICANT BESIDE A SEMI
NOTHING BY WILL.
COME ON NOW WELL THE THE NOT TO
MENTION THAT THERE ARE TIMES
WHEN AN ERRANT PAPERWORK BY THE
AGENCY A CONTRACT MEANS THAT I
WILL GO WEEKS WITHOUT PAY AS
THIS HAS HAPPENED TO ME BEFORE.
NOBLE THAT A MEDAL FOR THAT THEN
IT IS STILL SEVERAL DAYS.
FEDERAL COURT IF HE GOT OUT OF A
SMITH SAID GOAL MUST YOU MUST UP
A LITTLE I CAN'T AFFORD THESE
ERRORS BUT THEY HAPPEN AND WITH
EACH ONE I COME CLOSER AND
CLOSER TO LOSING EVERYTHING.
IT BUT I MEANT THAT NANCY OF
THAT I MAY KNOW THEM AT THE
LOCAL BACK IN MAY OF I YEAH I
LOST THE MATCH I LOOK OKAY DON'T
MEAN YOU.
KNOW FOR THAT MONTH AND THEN
I'VE YET STUCK WITH OTHER
COUNTRIES TO ADD TO MY ANXIETY
OFTEN WORRY THAT I'M GOING TO
GET HURT PICKING UP A CHILD AND
WILL BE ABLE TO KEEP MY CHILD
CARE OPEN.
WHAT I WHAT I SAW SOMETHING OF
THE BUS UNITS THAT ARE MADE
BASED ON DATA NORTE?
FEDERAL SOMEBODY ALICE MINNESOTA
NEXT SYSTEM BUT CANNOT BUT I
KNOW THAT BUT I WOULD ASK. FOR
NOW THEY'RE JUST WORRIES THAT
WAY ON ME EVERY NIGHT BUT THEY
ARE REAL MY SAVINGS ARE NON
EXISTENT BECAUSE THERE'S NOTHING
LEFT OVER TO SAVE. NINE NINGUNA
NEW ONE MAKE A NEEDS MORE BUT I
ME SEE THING GOING NOT THESE
POLITICAL SURVEYED FIVE WILL
GONNA HANDS YEAH.
IN THIS THE STYLUS PROVIDE A LOT
OF NOISE STOMACH BUT THAT HE
THAT. FOR LACK OF A SYSTEM THAT
THEY HAVE A HAVE A LOTUS AS HE
CAN NOT THE NAY MONNING WILL NOT
LET THIS IT WOULD BE THAT
THERE'S NO REAL APPEAL PROCESS
FOR ME IF I HAVE A PAY DISNEY
WITH THE AGENCY.
AND PROVIDERS IN THE STATE ARE
NOT COVERED BY WORKERS
COMPENSATION SO WE HAVE NO
SAFETY NET.
THE MEMO SAID THAT THAT'LL
SCHOOL OVER THAT THAT ASSOCIATES
[inaudible]
YES YES.
THAT'S WHY I AM HERE TODAY WITH
MY PROVIDER SISTERS BECAUSE
AFTER FIFTEEN YEARS OF FIGHTING
FOR THE RIGHT TO FORM A UNION
AND NEGOTIATE WITH THE STATE.
WE KNOW THAT IF WE'RE GOING TO
CHANGE THE INEQUITY AROUND US
AND THE CHILDREN WE CARE FOR WE
NEED TO BE TREATED AS REAL
PARTNERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND JUST READ WAS
INFORMATION I DON'T HOLD THE
TIME. TO TRANSLATE AGAINST THE
SIX MINUTES SO I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTARY THANK YOU --
OKAY AND THE SO -- THERE IS
THERE ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL AND I'M GONNA ASK THIS IS
THE GOING TO BE THE RULES WE
HAVE A LOT OF PUBLIC COMMENT I'M
SURE TODAY -- JUST YOUR NAME
YOU'RE REALLY ASIANOR TITLE AND
YOUR STUPID JUST SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION LET ME GET OPPOSITION.
SO JUST NAME -- TITLE
AFFILIATION AND YOUR POSITION ON
THIS PARTICULAR BILL THANK YOU.
WE IN THE CHURCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS WHEN ALL THE SANDERS
ACT I HAVE BEEN A QUALITY%
CHILDCARE PROVIDER IN THE
WONDERFUL CITY OF COMPTON FOR
OVER THIRTY YEARS.
AND I SUPPORT AB THREE SEVENTY
EIGHT I HOPE THAT I PRAY THAT
YOU GIVE US ABOUT THIS GIVE A
STEP OUT THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS VANESSA RODRIGUEZ AND
I HAVE BEEN A FAMILY CHILDCARE
PROVIDER IN THE WONDERFUL CITY
OF FRESNO. FOR NINE YEARS --
ALSO A MEMBER OF SEIU LOCAL FIVE
TWO ONE AND I STAND HERE IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE SEVEN NAY
AND I ASK FOR YOUR EIGHT VOTE.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS CELESTE GLENNA AND
I HAVE BEEN A DAY CARE PROVIDER
IN THE CITY OF TULARE. FOR
TWENTY FOUR YEARS AND I HAVE
MADE A BIG DIFFERENCE IN THE
QUALITY THAT THESE CHILDREN GET.
IN THEIR LEARNING I'M ALSO A
MEMBER OF THE S. YEAH YOU FIVE
TO ONE I STAND HERE IN SUPPORT
OF AB.
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT AND ASK FOR
YOU. TO VOTE YES ON EIGHTY THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT THANK YOU GO TO
LARRY.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU MY NAME
IS ROSE ANNA PEREZ AND I'M HERE
WITH UNITED DOMESTIC WORKERS OPS
MEAN AND I AM HERE STANDING IN
SUPPORT OF AB.
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT WE NUMBER
ADDRESS HONESTLY A KEY BE THE
AND ALSO UP FOR YOU -- BUT IT
WOULD BE ALMOST APPLE YANDLE
ABIT THIS YET THEY'VE ORCHARD
THANK YOU.
CLASSES.
NUMBER RESTS ON A MASSIVE MAKE
UP FOR YET AT I'LL READ THE AVE
THAT IS IF THEY WERE.
TO ASSESS.
THE NUMBER IS MONEY A MISS
HAVING WHAT FOR YET I LIED AVE.
THEY SEE IT THEY WERE JOKING S.
CLASSES.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JOYCE
HALL I'VE BEEN DOING I HAVE BEEN
A CHILD CARE PROVIDER IN THE
CITY OF OUT TO DINA CALIFORNIA
FOR THIRTY YEARS.
I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF S. C. I.
YOU NOT LOCAL NINETY NINE AND I
STAND HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB
THREE SEVEN EIGHT AND ASK FOR
YOUR A FULL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS SAID TO BE AGILE FUN --
PROVIDED FOR FIFTEEN YEARS AND
I'M HERE TOOL FOR THE CHILDREN'S
OF AMERICA AND THE MORE THEIR
SELF AMERICA WHAT IN THE SAYS
SPUR ME.
THAT IS WHY AREA I AM.
FOR THE AB THREE SEVENTY EIGHT
THANK YOU AND I NEED YOUR
SUPPORT.
TO THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS LAUREL IS WILL HAVE
BEING FAMILY SHOW CARE.
PROVIDING FOR A SOUTH GATE FOR
FORTY YEARS I AM ALSO A MEMBER
OF LOCAL NINETY NINE AND
STANDING HERE TO SUPPORT OF A B..
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT AND ASK YOU
FOR YOUR BOTTOM THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SO
THAT THOMAS I AM A PROVIDING
SIGNAL HILL I BEING A PROVIDER
FOR NINE YEARS I AM A MEMBER OF
AC YOU LOCAL.
NINETY NINE I GUESS THEN HERE AS
THE VOICE OF OUR CHILDREN -- I
SUPPORT THE B. L. A. B. THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT AND I ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JULIE UP ONE DAY I'M
A PROVIDER IN DOWNEY.
AMBIEN PROVIDER FOR OUR CHILD
CARE FOR SIXTEEN YEARS NINE HERE
TO SUPPORT THE AV THREE SEVEN
EIGHT I ASKING FOR YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO LADIES AND GENTLEMAN NAMED
CHARLOTTE NAIL IN A CHLD CARE
PROVIDER AND IT'S YOU KNOW
SACRAMENTO I'VE BEEN IN BUSINESS
FOR SEVENTEEN YEARS AND I'M ALSO
A MEMBER OF C. C. P. U..
A PARTNERSHIP OF ASKED ME U. D.
W. AND S. C. I. YOU LOCALS FIVE
TWENTY ONE NINETY NINE AND I
STAY HERE SUPPORT UP. THRE
SEVEN EIGHT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND COMMITMENT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS LUCY WILL
RUN IN I WAS SOBBING CHILD CARE
FOR FIFTEEN YEARS AND RANCHO
SANTA MIGHT GET IT THAT'S HOW
CALIFORNIA.
IN ON THE LOAN SO THEY DO THAT
WE YOU AND I WORKING THEY HAVE.
A NICE TO BUY YES TO FOR YOU
WHAT'S SUPPORT US THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS AMY DAY I'M AN
ORGANIZER WITH UNITED DOMESTIC
WORKERS -- ASKED ME LOCAL THIRTY
NINE THIRTY AND I'M HERE IN
SUPPORT OF I EIGHTY THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS SABRINA STREET
I AM WITH UNITED DOMESTIC
WORKERS APPS ME -- I AM FROM
BUTTE COUNTY AND I'M IN SUPPORT
OF AB THREE SEVENTY EIGHT THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS MARIA I'M HERE
WITH -- UNITED DOMESTIC WORKER
SOMEONE OF THE ORGANIZERS -- I'M
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL THAT
I EIGHT AB T. SEVENTY EIGHT
SEVENTY NINE AND I HOPE THAT.
YOU CAN -- SUPPORT THAT THE LESS
WELL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS KISHA HANEY I AM
FROM BUTTE COUNTY -- YOU W.
LOCAL THIRTY NINE THIRTY AND I
AM HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE
SEVEN EIGHT AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT.
AB THREE SEVEN EIGHT THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS MY REPAIR WORK
FOR SCA USE THEY COUNSEL AND I'M
ALSO IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE
SEVEN EIGHT AND I THINK IN
ADVANCE FOR SUPPORT IN CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS UNITED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS NATALIA VEGA AND WITH
LOCAL SCO YOU FIVE TO ONE AND I
WOULD LIKE TO USE THIS FOR AB
THREE SEVEN EIGHT THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS TANYA MCMILLAN AND
I HAVE BEEN A CHILD CARE
PROVIDER IN THE CITY OF
BELLFLOWER FOR TWENTY FOUR YEARS.
I AM A THE CULTURE OF RAISING
CALIFORNIA TOGETHER COALITION
AND A COMMISSIONER ON THE BLUE
RIBBON COMMISSION AND I HUMBLY
ASK YOUR SUPPORT AND I VOTE FOR
AB.
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
NATASHA FOR MISTER AND I HAVE
BEEN A FULL TIME CHILDCARE
PROVIDER IN THE CITY OF
HAWTHORNE FOR TWENTY FOUR YEARS.
I AM ALSO A MEMBER OF LOCAL
NINETY NINE AS SEE I YOU AND I
STAND HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT AND I'M
HOPING THAT YOU ALSO SUPPORT AS
WITH THIS EFFORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS ANNA FAR FAN I
SUPPORT AB THREE SEVEN A AND I'M
HERE TO ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
ALSO.
THINKING.
HELLO MY NAME IS MICHAEL COLE
ALSO COME HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
SORRY.
HI MY NAME IS SHARON TO CHELSEA
I'M WITH A U. D. W. HOME CARE
PROVIDER.
OF I SUPPORT AB THREE SEVENTY
EIGHT THANK YOU BRING TALK.
HI MY NAME IS LISA SCOTT I'M
FROM AROUND COUNTY ON MY HOME
CARE WORKER FOR SEVENTEEN YEARS
AND I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS NANETTE RING GOING
SEATTLE I AM THE EXTERNAL
ORGANIZING DIRECTOR AT SEIU
LOCAL NINETY NINE I AM HERE IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE SEVENTY
EIGHT AND ASKING FOR YOUR A VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH HI MY NAME
IS ON MY SENSE IS AND I'M FROM
VICTORVILLE NAMA IN HOME
CHILDCARE PROVIDER IN AMERICA.
IS SUPPORT AND ASK YOU FOR
SUPPORT FOR THREE AB THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
HELLO I AM STILL YET TO REVEAL
AN ORGANIZER WITH SEIU LOCAL
NINETY NINE AND I'M HERE TO US
FOR YOUR SUPPORT IN OUR BILL AB.
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT LET'S INVEST
IN OUR MOST PRIEST PREACHES
RESTARTS WHICH IS OUR CHILDREN
IF YOU KNOW ALL A MOTHER OR A
CHILD THAT YOU LOVE PLEASE
SUPPORT OUR BILL THANK YOU.
YOU KNOW GOOD MONEY ENOUGH I
DON'T.
BEFORE THE SANTA CRUZ.
REPRESENT THE LEFT FOR A LOT OF
IF THEY WILL BE SURGERY INSTEAD
OF A FINAL ON THE SCREEN.
EVEN WATER PERCENT DONE THE AVE
THE SIMPLE MMHM.
THE DEADLINE.
CLASSES.
HI MY NAME IS THE RETIREES ARE
YOU THAN WHAT SOME BILLS.
I CARE I I CAN TELL YOU PROVIDE
FOR TWENTY THREE YEARS I AM FOR
MEMBERS. FOUR ZERO FIVE TWO FIVE
TWO ONE I THINK HERE I SUPPORT
AB THREE SEVEN EIGHT AN AXE YOU.
FOR YOUR VOTE THANK YOU THANK
YOU -- Là.
MEAN NUMBER IS MOTOR HE MENACE
BENGAL THE WHAT SOME BILLS THANK
YOU SANDERS WITHIN THE MEALS IS
TOM PSYCHE.
WHEN THE LAST PRODUCT GATE WAS
SEVEN OF PLAN UP FOR YEAH GOOD I
pHELLO -- MY NAME IS HIGH MAN --
FROM SANTA CRUZ -- AND THE
REASON I'M HERE TODAY IS BECAUSE
I'M SUPPORTING MY WIFE WHO HAS
BEEN AYE CHILDCARE PROVIDER FOR
EIGHTEEN YEARS.
AND PLEASE -- I'M ASKING YOU TO
SUPPORT THE AB THREE SEVEN EIGHT
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS A
MEASURE GRIFFIN I AM FROM APPLE
VALLEY CALIFORNIA I HAVE BEEN A
FAMILY CHILDCARE PROVIDER FOR
OVER SIXTEEN YEARS.
I AM A MEMBER OF S. CI YOU AND
LOCAL NINETY NINE AND I SUPPORT
AB THREE SEVENTY EIGHT AND I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR A VOTE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS PATTY
TIVO AND I'M A CHILD CARE
PROVIDER IN THE CITY A FULSOME
I'VE BEEN OPEN FOR THIRTY YEARS.
AND I'M HERE.
AS A MEMBER ALSO OF A C. C. P.
U. A PARTNERSHIP OF AFC.
AFSCME AND THE U. D. W. AND
LOCALS FIVE TWENTY ONE OF NINETY
NINE AND I STAND HER SUPPORT OF
AB. THREE SEVEN EIGHT AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU HEARING US
TODAY THANK YOU FOR TAKING.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS
MARICA YOSHIHARU WITH THE
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
CAN REALLY RESURRECT A SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION ON
BEHALF OF ALL SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND MEMBERS WE'RE REALLY
EXCITED TO SPONSOR THIS
LEGISLATION AND RECOGNIZE SOME
OF THE HARDEST WORKING
INDIVIDUALS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
LIBBY SANCHEZ ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS MUCH THANK YOU.
AFTER NAME IS CHAIR BEVERLY YOU
ON BEHALF EW ASKED ME LOCAL
THREE NINE THIRTY A STRONG
SUPPORTER EXCITED CO SPONSOR
THIS BUS WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HI JACKIE GALLIANO FROM SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA A U. D. W. THIRTY
NINE THIRTY C. C. P. U..
I'M ASKING FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON
THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
A GOOD MORNING A NOT SO CAR THAN
US I'M HERE WITH YOU D. W. AND
S. YEAH YOU AND I'M HERE IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE SEVEN EIGHT
THANK YOU.
HI JESSICA STANDER ON BEHALF OF
EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES AND THE
STRONGER CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES
NETWORK IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
CAITLYN VEGA FOR THECALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION WE ARE HERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THESE CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS HAVE WAITED LONG
ENOUGH IT NOW IS THE TIME THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANDRE RIVERA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LOOK HERE YOU WILLIAMS FROM
SACRAMENTO BUT I AM A CHILD CARE
PROVIDER IN APPLE VALLEY -- I'M
WITH -- SEIU LOCAL NINETY NINE
AND BEYOND ASKING FOR SUPPORT I
JUST REALLY ASK THAT YOU
CONSIDER THAT THIS IS NOT ABOUT
LABOR UNIONS JUST ABOUT MAKING
SURE THAT.
EVERYONE CONTINUES TO WORK.
INCLUDING THOSE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO DO ANYTHING IF YOU'D LIKE TO
DO BECAUSE YOUR BABY TAKEN CARE
OF THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON JACKI ALONG WITH
GRAYSON AND TELL PARTY IN
CALIFORNIA CAMPAIGN IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY ASIA COLE AND
I AM INTERNET THE CHILD CARE
LAWCENTER AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WHEN YOU WERE ALSO FROM CHILD
CARE LAWCENTER AND WE ARE PROUD
CO SPONSOR [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
JAZZY GIRL UCW WESTERN STATES
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT THANKS THANK
YOU.
I JUST PARK LOW WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN.
WELL ROSES WILL PAUSE FOR
WESTERN CENTER.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
IF NOT ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY.
I WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR ANY COMMENT OR
MOTION.
I'M OF THE BILL.
I AM I SO EXCITED AS THAT THIS
BILL IS COMING BACK I HONESTLY
CAN'T THINK OF NO MORE IMPORTANT
BILL THAT WE'RE GOING TO VOTE ON
THIS YEAR -- IT'S A PRIORITY OF
WE ARE GOING TO GET YELLED AT SO
IT'S A PART OF THE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS IT'S A PRIORITY LET YOU
KNOW CAUCUS -- WE KNOW AS FAR AS
JOBS GO THESE JOBS ARE GOING TO
EXIST THEY CAN'T BE OUTSOURCED
THEY CAN'T BE.
AUTOMATED -- AND LIKE OUR AYE AT
CHESS AS WORKERS -- WE WE HAVE
POPULATIONS THAT ARE YOUNG AND
OLD AND ARE GONNA NEED CARE AND
SO TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO TO
HAVE CHILD CARE PROVIDERS BE
PROFESSIONAL LIES. TO EVENTUALLY
HAVE THE RIGHT TO COLLECTIVELY
BARGAIN AND AND TO MAKE THESE
THE GOOD PAYING CAREERS THEY
SHOULD BE -- IF WE CARE ABOUT
OUR CHILDREN IF WE CARE ABOUT
OUR WORKERS -- WILL PASS THIS
EVERY TIME SO -- THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING FOR THE THE BILL --
MUSLIM ON AND AND I'M SO PROUD
AT TO BE PART OF IT AND
EVENTUALLY I THINK IT MIGHT GO
SOMEWHERE BEFORE I CAN BECOME A
CO AUTHOR BUT EVENTUALLY I WOULD
LIKE TO BE.
THANK YOU IT IS IN OUR AREA.
THREE MEDIC IT'LL OF THE DEATH
IS THAT THE LESS MAHOOD IS
COMPANY LACKEY AND THAT THIS THE
MONEY SO BUT IMPORTANT THAT
GIVES THAT IS BEING HONEST LOOK
UP AT THE LITTLE.
BUT A OF A GOD BUT I LESS LESLIE
IF THIS ON IMPORTANCE BUT IN THE
FISCAL MONEY THAT IS YOU KNOW
SPECIFY MEDIA.
ME MAMA WITHOUT ANY NEWS CUANDO
YOU IT ANYA IN THE END UP
PICKING AT THEM IN.
E. L. WHAT I YES MA'AM BUT THEM
IN THIS YEAH YOU.
HAVE BEEN THINKING SAY.
E. L. DRIVE I HOPE YOU SAID THIS
ASSN IS IMPORTANT.
IS THIS A SIDE DEAL THE TO SOME
OF THE NORM WHEN ALLOWED A CAN
AND CAPITAL -- BUT AS A LOCAL
CITY WILL BUT A MISTRESS THAT'LL
SS [inaudible]
HI.
THERE'S NO OTHER CALM NOT SPEAK
ABOUT.
A COMMENT THAT -- YOU KNOW THIS
IS BEEN A JOURNEY THAT'S BEEN
GOING ON FOR WELL OVER A DECADE
IN THE MAKING -- THAT TO I KNOW
MANY OF THE WORKERS INCLUDING
I'M SURE MANY WHO SPOKE HERE
TODAY.
HAVE BEEN FIGHTING THIS FIGHT
FOR VERY VERY LONG TIME AND I
WANT TO GIVE CREDIT TO THOSE
THAT HAVE BEEN THIS STRUGGLE
INCLUDING MANY.
PREVIOUS AUTHORS THAT HAVE TRIED.
AND GOTTEN BILLS VETOED AND SO
ON AND SO ON AND SO ON AND I
REALLY WANT TO THANK OUR AUTHOR
TODAY SERVER LIMON BECAUSE THIS
IS NOT AN EASY ENDEAVOR TO TAKE
ON WE'VE SEEN.
OTHER STRUGGLES WITH IN THE PAST
BUT I THINK THAT WE HAVE THE
RIGHT AUTHOR I THINK WE HAVE THE
RIGHT MOVEMENT.
I THINK THAT -- THAT WE WE HAVE
A LEGISLATURE THAT UNDERSTANDS
THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS -- AND
YOU KNOW I I THINK WE HAVE A
RECOGNITION.
AS IT APPLIES -- TO CHILDCARE
WORKERS THAT THEY'RE NOT
BABYSITTERS -- THERE QUITE OFTEN
A CHILD'S FIRST EDUCATOR FIRST
TEACHER.
ALONG WITH THEIR PARENTS AND I
THINK THAT -- AS HAS BEEN STATED.
BY THE WITNESSES QUITE
ELOQUENTLY THAT IF WE CARE ABOUT
OUR CHILDREN HOW CAN WE NOT CARE
ABOUT THOSE THAT CARE FOR
CHILDREN.
YEAH AND SO -- I OFTEN I I
USUALLY REFRAIN FROM CO
AUTHORING BILLS THAT COME ARE
GOING TO COME BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE THIS IS AN EXCEPTION
WELL I'M VERY PROUD TO BE A
PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR OF THIS BILL.
BECAUSE IS THAT IMPORTANT. FOR
THE FUTURE OF OUR STATE LET
ALONE.
THE CHILD CARE WORKERS AND SO --
WITH THAT WE DO HAVE AN AYE
RECOMMENDATION I DO PASSED TO
JUDGE JUDICIARY -- WITH THE
MOTION FROM AS A MEMBER GONZALEZ
A SECOND BY A SIMILAR CARILLO --
AND WITH THE OTHER CUT THERE'S
NO THE COMMENT ALLOW OUR AUTHORS
TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS THAT
I THINK THAT WHAT HAS BEEN
SHARED WITH ALL OF US TODAY IS
THAT CHILD CARE WORKERS.
KEEP THE CALIFORNIA WORKING WE
DO NOT HAVE JOBS WE CANNOT HAVE
AFFECTED BUSINESSES WITHOUT
CHILD CARE WORKERS AT THE TABLE
AND NO WAY NO HOW IS IT OKAY FOR
CHILD CARE WORKERS TO BE
RECEIVING THE SAME SUBSIDIES.
BUT THE FAMILIES THEY SERVE OUR
RECEIVING WE HAVE GOT TO BRING
THEM TO THE TABLE WE HAVE GOT TO
GET THEM TO THE PLACE WHERE
THEIR WAGES.
ALLOW THEM TO KEEP CALIFORNIA
THRIVING WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
A AND MASSACRED CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE.
DO PASSED TO JUDICIARY KALRA AYE
KALRA AYE FLORA.
FLORA I AGREE YOU.
CARILLO I DEEP.
DEEP NOT VOTING GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I JONES SAWYER THREE OF
US.
WHAT'S THE BILL'S OUT AND WILL
BE ABLE TO OPEN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
I I APPRECIATE THE EXUBERANCE OF
A BUT IF -- IF FOLKS CAN MAKE
THE WAY OUT OF THE COMMITTEE
ROOM PLEASE WE DO HAVE A LOT.
MORE WORK TO DO.
ALAS THE IF WE CAN TAKE THE
EXUBERANCE OUTSIDE.
SO WE CONTINUE OUR WORK QUIETLY
PLEASE THANK YOU ALL SO MUCH.
SO -- A NEXT A BRUSH GONNA HEAR
FROM AS A MEMBER GRAY WHO'S
WALKING INTO THE DOOR ANY MOMENT
NOW BECAUSE HE'S RIGHT ACROSS
ALL.
ON AB.
TWELVE TWENTY FOUR AND LET'S
GIVE A MOMENT.
FOR OUR AUDIENCE TO MAKE THEIR
WAY OUT AND IF THERE'S ANYBODY
ELSE OUTSIDE JUST LOOKING FOR A
SEAT TO MAKE THEIR WAY IN
.
SO -- AS THE CROWD MAKE THIS WE
ARE WE'RE GONNA HEAR FROM SOME
OF OUR GREAT AND THEN A SUMMER
GRAYSON IF.
AS IMMIGRATION DOESN'T MIND
SUMMER GRAY'S CHAIRING A
COMMITTEE RIGHT ACROSS THE HALL
HE'S MAKING HIS WAY OVER HERE
RIGHT NOW.
AND SO AS LONG AS HE'S HERE
WITHIN THE NEXT NINETY SECONDS.
IF THAT'S OKAY THANKS
.
ALL RIGHT -- MISTER GRAYSON --
WHAT WE GO AHEAD AND GET AN
INTEREST OF TIME HERE YOUR BILL
QUICKEN?
IT'S A AB.
SEVEN TWENTY ONE AND IT DOES
ENJOY AND I DO PASSED HUMAN
SERVICES RECOMMENDATION.
IT'S IT'S UP TO YOU MISTER
GRAYSON IF YOU IF YOU WANT TO
FOR A WERE HAPPY HUMAN SO I DO
HAVE A MOVE THE BILL AND YES A
SECOND.
YOU HAVE A MOVE IN A SACK IT'S
ALREADY BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
ALL YOUR HARD WORK AND ATTENTION
ON THIS BILL.
AND I DO HAVE A WITNESS WITH ME
HERE TODAY SO I WILL REFER TO MY
WITNESS MISTER CONNELLY CAUGHT --
COLORS CO CHAIR OF THE LIFTING
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES OUT OF
POVERTY THAT TASK FORCE.
THANK YOU THANKS.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS THE OF
LEGISLATIVE CHARGE FROM THIS
BODY TO THE CHILD POVERTY TASK
FORCE.
WAS TO DEVELOP A COMPREHENSIVE
EVIDENCE AND DATABASE PLAN. TO
SUBSTANTIALLY REDUCE
CALIFORNIA'S HIGHEST IN THE
LEVEL HIGHEST IN THE NATION
LEVEL OF CHILD POVERTY.
THE PLAN THAT WE PRODUCED.
WHICH SPECIFICALLY PRIORITIZES
ASSEMBLYMAN GRAYSON.
SEVEN TWO ONE WILL ELIMINATE
CHILD POVERTY IN THE STATE.
IN FOUR YEARS AND SUBSTANTIALLY
REDUCE IT BY AT LEAST 50% OVER
TEND -- TO TWENTY YEARS IN THE
WORKFORCE SUBCOMMITTEE OF THE
TASK FORCE WAS CHAIRED BY --
DâN ROUNDS THE POLICY DIRECTOR
FOR THE CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD ON BEHALF OF
THE DEVELOPMENT BOARD.
AND THE STATE LABOR DEPARTMENT.
CHAIR ROUNDS IN THE SUB
COMMITTEE.
RECOMMENDED THIS BILL.
AS THE SINGLE MOST.
IMPORTANT PRIORITY IN THE WORK
FORCE TRAINING AREA BOTTOM LINE
PRETTY SIMPLE. FOR LOW INCOME
PEOPLE TO PARTICIPATE IN JOB
TRAINING PROGRAMS THEY NEED TO
BE ABLE TO GET TO AND FROM WORK.
THEY NEED CHILDCARE THEY NEED
STABILITY AND BASIC SERVICES
LIKE HOUSING AND IF WE PROVIDE
THAT THEY WILL BE ABLE TO LIFT
THEMSELVES UP THE ECONOMIC
LADDER.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT WE WE
ASK FOR A TO PASS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
THE PICKING UP THE MICROPHONE
SET UP FOR THAT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN RECESS OR THE
OTHER BEHALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL WERE OFTEN PARTNERS WITH
THE WORKFORCE OF ON THE BOARDS.
ON WORKFORCE PREPARATION FOR
PARTNERSHIP BELIEVE THIS BILL
ASSIST A LOT OF OUR OUR PEOPLE
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO TARGET
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
SB ABOUT COMMITTEE WE HAVE A
MOTION.
I JUST WANNA BE CLEAR I'M A
LITTLE I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THE
VAGUENESS OF THE BILL AND THERE
ARE NOT ALL WORKFORCE READINESS
PROGRAMS IF YOU WILL ARE CREATED
EQUAL -- SO WHEN MY CONCERNS OF
BY THE TRADES WERE UP HERE BUT
WHEN MY CONCERNS ARE FOR EXAMPLE
WE CAN TAKE THE BUILDING TRADES
IS A GREAT EXAMPLE RIGHT YOU
COULD YOU COULD BE A PART OF A
JOINT LABOR MANAGEMENT
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM.
IN WHICH CASE THE WORKER IS NOT
PAYING -- FOR FOR CLASSES THERE
ARE AYE ON A ROAD TO BEING PAID
THEY'RE ON THE ROAD TO
GRADUATION THERE ARE OTHER
PEOPLE WHO ALSO OPERATE
CONSTRUCTION WORK FORCE COURSES.
WHO CHARGE THE STUDENT WHO DON'T
GRADUATE THEIR STUDENTS WHO --
DON'T PROVIDE KIND BASIC
SERVICES I WANT TO MAKE SURE IF
WE'RE PUTTING MONEY AND WE'RE
PUTTING IT MONEY IN A
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH THAT IS
ACTUALLY IN LIFT PEOPLE OUT OF
POVERTY AND NOT FAKE WORKFORCE
PROGRAM SO.
I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THIS WAS
FOR THAT WE HAVE -- THOSE KINDS
OF SPECIFICS IN IT WE SHOULD
SUPPLEMENT -- PROGRAMS THAT WORK
IN PROGRAMS THAT TRULY LIFT
PEOPLE OUT OF POVERTY AND GIVE
THEM CAREER OPPORTUNITIES NOT
JUST ABOUT JOB.
THANK YOU FOR THE FUTURE
REFERENCE BEFORE IT SOMEHOW MAY
MAKE IT TO ANOTHER COMMITTEE I
ON THANK YOU THANK YOU -- AND SO
WE DO HAVE A MOTION NO FURTHER
COMMENT.
WE HAVE A MOTION AS SOMEONE TO
MEMBERS WELL ACTUALLY IT'S GOING
TO A CLOSING COMMENTS.
FROM AS IMMIGRATION.
I THANK THE MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE -- MY COLLEAGUES --
FOR COMMENTS AND WILL TAKE THEM
TO HEART AND MAKE SURE THAT WE
FOLLOW THAT TRACK AS WE MOVE
THIS BILL FORWARD.
THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY ASK
WHEN I THANK YOU THE DOESN'T
REALLY DO PASSIVE TO HUMAN
SERVICE RECOMMENDATION THERE'S A
MOTION TO THAT EFFECT WAS A
MEMBER GONZALEZ.
SECONDED BY SUMMER CREEL.
PLEASE TAKE WILL.
DO PASSED TO YOU HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE KALRA AYE KALRA AYE
FLORA CREEL.
CREEL I DEEP.
THE FIVE AND SALAS.
GONZALEZ I JONES SAWYER THREE OF
US ALRIGHT SO THAT BILLS OUT OF
CONTROL OPEN FRAT ON SICK THANK
YOU.
ALL RIGHT UP NEXT WE HAVE.
AB TWELVE TWENTY FOUR SOMETHING
MEMBER GRAY THANKS FOR HUSTLING
OVER HERE FOR ****.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
THAT PLEASE.
AB TWELVE TWENTY FOUR CREATES AN
OPPORTUNITY MEMBERS FOR PART
TIME EMPLOYEES. TO RECEIVE
TWELVE WEEKS OF JOB PROTECTED
LEAVE.
THE BILL ALSO PERMITS ADDITIONAL
SIX WEEKS OF PAID FAMILY LEAVE
FOR EMPLOYEES WHO EXPERIENCE A
SECOND.
QUALIFYING EVENT WITHIN A TWELVE
MONTH PERIOD.
MEMBERS I INTRODUCED THIS BILL
BECAUSE IN MY CAPACITY AS AN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER -- CURRENT LAW
FAILED MY OWN STAFF.
MY FORMER CHIEF OF STAFF NOW
WORKS FOR ME IN A PART TIME
BASIS AND FOUND SHE WAS
INELIGIBLE FOR JOB PROTECTED
LEAVE FROM THE ASSEMBLY.
BECAUSE HER PART TIME STATUS
RESULT IN HER FAILING FALLING
RATHER HUNDREDS OF OUR SHORT OF
THE CURRENT TWELVE HUNDRED FIFTY
OUR THRESHOLD.
THERE'S NO REASON -- IN HER CASE
THAT JOB SHOULDN'T BE PROTECTED
AFTER HER SERVICE TO THE TWENTY
FIRST ASSEMBLY DISTRICT THERE'S
NO REASON THE LAW SHOULD
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST THE WOMEN
AND MEN WHO WORK ONE OR MORE
PART TIME JOBS.
AB TWELVE TWENTY FOUR CREATES AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THOSE WHO WORK
AT SEVENTEEN AND A HALF HOURS
PER WEEK OR MORE.
BUT WHO DO NOT QUALIFY FOR THE
CURRENT CALIFORNIA FAMILY RIGHTS
AFTER THE FAMILY MEDICAL LEAVE
ACT TO TAKE TWELVE WEEKS OF JOB
PROTECTIVELY.
THE CURRENT LANGUAGE IN THE BILL
REFLECTION ATTEMPT TO ADDRESS
THE CONCERNS RAISED BY THE
OPPOSITION WHICH ALLOWS THE
VARIOUS TYPES OF LEAVE PERMITTED.
BY CURRENT LAW TO BE STACKED
TOGETHER POTENTIALLY PROVIDING
SIGNIFICANTLY LONGER
OPPORTUNITIES FOR LEAVE THAT
ORIGINALLY INTENTION.
THERE ARE OTHER OPPORTUNITY TO
EXPLORE WHETHER LONGER FORMS OF
LEAVE APPROPRIATE OR NOT BUT MY
INTENTION WITH THIS BILL IS
SPECIFIC TO PROVIDING TWELVE
WEEKS OF LEAVE. FOR PART TIME
EMPLOYEES WITHOUT CREATING NEW
STACKING OPPORTUNITIES.
I HAVE COMMITTED MY WILL
REITERATE TODAY THAT IS MY
INTENTION IMPROVE THE LANGUAGE
CURRENTLY IN THE BILL TO ADDRESS
THE STACKING ISSUE.
BUT I'M CURRENTLY IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO DO JUST THAT.
WALL WE ARE IN AGREEMENT -- TO
ADDRESS THE UNINTENTIONAL ISSUE
I THINK I CAN FAIRLY SAY THAT WE
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE ON THE
FUNDAMENTAL PREMISE OF THE BILL.
WELL WE HAVE MADE SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS ON THIS ISSUE IN
CALIFORNIA OVER THE LAST TWENTY
YEARS WE CONTINUE TO IMPOSE
CONDITIONS ON WOMEN IN ORDER TO
QUALIFY FOR PREGNANCY AND
BONDING LEAF.
DATA FROM THE US BUREAU OF LABOR
STATISTICS SHOWS THAT WOMEN
TEENAGERS AND SENIORS ARE THE
MOST LIKELY DEMOGRAPHICS TO WORK
PART TIME.
PART TIME EMPLOYEES ARE MORE
LIKELY TO HAVE LOWER MEDIAN
FAMILY INCOMES.
IN A HIGHER INCIDENCE OF POVERTY
THAN OTHERS MAKING -- THIS CLASS
OF WORKERS MORE VULNERABLE TO
JOB LOTS OF HOMELESSNESS.
US DEPARTMENT OF LABOR'S ALSO
FOUND THAT WORKERS WITH LATIN
AMERICAN HERITAGE
DISPROPORTIONATELY LOCKED AND
INVOLUNTARY PART TIME EMPLOYMENT
EVEN AS OTHER MINORITY GROUPS OF
EXPERIENCE REDUCTION IN
INVOLUNTARY PART TIME EMPLOYMENT
SINCE THE GREAT RECESSION.
AS THE STATE WITH THE LARGEST
WHICH IN OUR POPULATIONS
CRITICAL ISSUE IN CALIFORNIA ONE
THAT IMPACTS CONSTITUENTS IN
EVERYONE OF OUR DISTRICTS.
OUR BIOLOGY DOES NOT CARE IF WE
WORK FULL TIME OR PART TIME IN
THESE WORK.
THESE WORKERS DESERVE THE SAME
RIGHT TO JOB PROTECTED LEAVE AS
EVERYONE ELSE.
AB TWELVE TWENTY FOUR ALSO
CREATES ADDITIONAL OPPORTUNITY
FOR SIX WEEKS OF PAID FAMILY
LEAVE FOR AN EMPLOYEE WHO
EXPERIENCES A SECOND.
QUALIFYING EVENT WITHIN A TWELVE
MONTH PERIOD.
THIS PART OF THE BILL WAS ALSO
INSPIRED BY SITUATION WHICH
IMPACTED A DIFFERENT ONE OF MY
OWN STAFF.
I MIGHT BE STATING THE OBVIOUS
HERE BUT IT IS IN FACT POSSIBLE
MEMBERS TO GIVE BIRTH TWICE
WITHIN A TWELVE MONTH PERIOD.
SO OFTEN NEW MOTHER TAKE SIX
WEEKS OF PAID FAMILY LEAVE IN
JANUARY.
AND THEN GIVES BIRTH TO A SECOND
CHILD NOVEMBER SHE IS INELIGIBLE
FOR PAID FAMILY LEAVE FOR THE
SECOND CHILD.
THE CURRENT LAW DEFIES.
LOGIC IN THIS TIME TO A LINE
THIS PROGRAM WITHOUT PREGNANCY
ACTUALLY WORKS.
I DO NOT BELIEVE THIS IS
CONTROVERSIAL COMPOSED THE BILL
BUT IT IS AN INCREDIBLY
COMMONSENSE CHANGE THAT IS LONG
OVERDUE.
I WOULD RESPECTFULLY.
REQUEST YOUR RIVAL TODAY MEMBERS
AND BE HAPPY TO ENTERTAIN ANY
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS.
THANK YOU AS A MEMBER OF MANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MR CHEN MEMBERS CAITLIN VEGA FOR
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
WE ARE HERE IN SUPPORT WE ARE
INCREASINGLY SEEING AN ECONOMY
WHERE WORKERS ARE OFTEN
COMBINING MULTIPLE PART TIME
JOBS.
AND AND EVERY WORKER SHOULD HAVE
THE ABILITY TO STAY HOME WITH
THE NEW BABY WE ALL ARE ALSO
PEOPLE NOT JUST WORKERS WE HAVE
LIVES WE HAVE FAMILIES WE HAVE
OBLIGATIONS.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE THAT
AND TO MAKE SURE THAT AS WE GO
THROUGH LIFE WE'RE ABLE TO KEEP
OUR JOB.
A PROTECT OUR FAMILY AND BE ABLE
TO DO BOTH SO WE'RE HERE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SHERMAN RECESS ARE THE OTHER
HALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL FOR
THE REASONS ALREADY STATED ALSO
JUST A REAR ITERATE THAT.
CONSTRUCTION IN AND OF ITSELF
AND MANY TIMES YOUR MULTI
EMPLOYER MULTI PROJECTS SETTING
VERY TEMPORARY SO THIS WILL BE A
VERY STRONG PROTECTION FOR A LOT
OF MEMBERS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CHEN DOESN'T ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
AND SO ANY OTHER ME TO
SUPPORTERS.
ANYONE ELSE'S SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
OKAY -- OPPOSITION.
AND FOR FOR REFERENCE FOR THE
FOR AUTHORS THAT -- THAT --
WE'RE HERE IN THE BEGINNING I
GIVE UP TO SIX MINUTES AND OFTEN
TAKE ALL THE SIX MINUTES UP TO
SIX MINUTES FOR EACH SIDE YOU
CAN TO BEAT UP ANYWAY YOU WANT
WITH WITNESSES.
SO PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
TODAY MY NAME IS FOR CURTIS AND
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WE GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S WILLINGNESS TO WORK
WITH US ON THIS BILL.
NOR OBVIOUSLY VERY SYMPATHETIC
TO THE ISSUE OUR CONCERN IS IS
THAT THIS LEAVE IS SEPARATE AND
DISTINCT FROM THE COUNTY
CALIFORNIA FAMILY RIGHTS ACT SO
IT APPLIES TO ANY EMPLOYEE WHO
REACHES NINE HUNDRED HOURS.
OR ABOVE SO WHAT IT DOES IS IN
ADDITION TO SEE FOR A OR FMLA
LEAVE AT THE FEDERAL EQUIVALENT
TO CALIFORNIA FAMILY RIGHTS ACT.
IT ALLOWS FOR AN ADDITIONAL
TWELVE WEEKS OF LEAVE SO WE'RE
LOOKING AT ANY EMPLOYEE THAT'S
FULL TIME COULD BE TAKING UP TO
TWENTY FOUR WEEKS OF LEAVE
WITHIN A ONE YEAR PERIOD.
ADDITIONALLY IF A PART TIME
EMPLOYEE WORKS NINE HUNDRED
HOURS RETURNS TO WORK AND THEN
WORKS THE ADDITIONAL THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY HOURS.
THERE THAN ADDITIONALLY -- I
FEEL THAT THEY ARE THE
ADDITIONAL TWELVE WEEKS ARE ALSO
AVAILABLE TO THEM THE OTHER
CLARIFICATION THAT I'D LIKE TO
MAKE IS THAT THIS IS NOT JUST
FOR PREGNANCY DISABILITY LEAVE
IT'S NOT JUST FOR FAMILY LEAVE
FOR BABY BONDING.
IT'S FOR ALL MEDICAL THE FOR A
FAMILY MEMBER OR YOURSELF SO IT
EXPANDS THAT TO AN EVEN BROADER
GROUP OF PEOPLE AND AND THAT'S
OUR CONCERN IS THAT EMPLOYERS
DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO
DETERMINE WHEN A PERSON CAN OR
CANNOT TAKE OFF WORK. FOR THESE
REASONS AND SO THEY CAN'T TELL
EMPLOYEES SO AND SO'S OUT
HOWEVER WE CAN LET YOU TAKE
LEAVE IN SIX WEEKS OR SO AND SO
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE MULTIPLE
EMPLOYEES THAT COULD POTENTIALLY
BE ON LEAVE AT THE SAME TIME.
SO WE'RE LOOKING AT NOT ONLY THE
COST OF ALLOWING THOSE EMPLOYEES
TO TAKE LEAVE -- BUT ALSO THE
COST OF BACK FILLING THAT
POSITION AND WHILE THIS IS WE
UNDERSTAND IT'S AN UNPAID LEAVE
THERE'S STILL A LOT OF THOSE
ISSUES THAT AN EMPLOYER HAS --
TO ACQUIRE -- HAS TO AND MAKE AN
ACCOMMODATION FOR SO OVERALL
THOSE ARE CONCERNS IS THE ADDED
BURDEN THAT THIS WILL PLACE ON
EMPLOYERS NOTABLY THIS APPLIES
TO ALL EMPLOYERS WHO HAVE FIFTY
OR MORE EMPLOYEES.
AND THAT IS AND YOU KNOW FOR A
LOT OF EM BUT SMALL BUSINESSES
THAT MAY NOT SEEM LIKE US.
A SMALL BUSINESS BUT FIFTY
EMPLOYEES ADDS UP REALLY QUICKLY
SO THAT'S JUST SOMEONE THAT OWNS
A LARGE RESTAURANT OR A COUPLE
RESTAURANTS CAN -- FIT THAT HIT
THAT FIFTY EMPLOYEES -- MARK
FAIRLY QUICKLY.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE ARE
OPPOSED AND WE THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME TODAY.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION NAME
TITLE AFFILIATION AND POSITION
PLEASE.
HELLO KATY HANSEN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION WERE OPPOSED FOR THE
REASONS STATED THANK YOU.
HI IN THE NAME ONLY NUMBER AFTER
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION A
JOINT POWERS AUTHORITIES.
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON BRIAN LITTLE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION OPPOSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
OKAY SO LET'S BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE BE -- ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS YES SOME OF
HIS OFFICE I DO HAVE QUESTIONS
AND I'M SORRY I AM.
I USUALLY THINK OF A PRETTY GOOD
HANDLE ON YES LAWS AND WHO THEY
AFFECT.
IN PLAIN IN THE SPACE FOR AWHILE.
THIS IS SIX WEEKS OF PAID LEAVE
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
AND THEN AN ADDITIONAL.
POSSIBILITY OF TWELVE WEEKS OF
UNPAID IN MY READING THIS
CORRECTLY.
THERE WERE SPECIFIC EXACTLY TO
PROTECTED LEAVE ALL JOB
PROTECTED PROTECTED PROTECTIVELY
BUT THE FIRST SIX WEEKS WOULD BE
PAID FAMILY LEAVE.
UNDER CURRENT LAW.
UNDER YOUR BELT.
THEY'RE THEY'RE JUST THIS BILL
EXPANDS GOT TWELVE YEARS TWELVE
WEEKS PROTECT TWELVE YEARS SHE'S.
PROBABLY SERVER TARGET TIME
WORKERS.
SO.
A PART TIME WORKER.
WOULD IT TAKES SIX WEEKS OF PAID
LEAVE.
WOULD BE INCOME REPLACEMENT AT
SIXTY OR 70%.
THERE WOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR TO
TAP THE FUNDFOR THE STE SIX
WEEKS OF PAID MEN HAVE PROTECTED
UNDER THE WHOLE.
RIGHT SO WOULD BE 70% OF THEIR
PART TIME.
PAY.
THE THE INTENTION THE BILL IS TO
VERY NARROWLY -- OR AT LEAST
VERY FOCUSED -- AFFORD.
OUR PART TIME EMPLOYEES THE SAME --
BENEFITS FOR DRAWFUL TEMPLARS
RIGHT AND I'M IDEA TO MAKE
FURTHER REVISIONS BEYOND THAT
BUT JUST TO CREATE THE EQUITY.
WHAT?
I THINK THAT'S INTERESTING I
APPLIED WHAT YOU'RE DOING I I
WILL ALWAYS VOTE -- TO EXPAND
FAMILY LEAVE AND AND PAID FAMILY
LEAVE AND JOB PROTECTION.
JOB PROTECTED LEAVE -- BUT I
THINK THAT WE HAVE.
TO ENSURE THAT WE UNDERSTAND
THAT PEOPLE WHO WORK -- FOR
SMALLER EMPLOYERS PART TIME OR
FULL TIME STILL DON'T HAVE JOB
PROTECTED LEAVE.
THAT WE STILL I MEAN SO WE STILL
HAVE.
CLASSES OF EMPLOYEES WHO ARE
ABLE TO TAKE LEAVE.
REALLY BASED ON WHO THEY WORK
FOR HOW THEY WORK UNDER WHAT
CONDITIONS THEY WORK -- WE HAVE
OF COURSE TEACHERS WHO DON'T
QUALIFY FOR PAID FAMILY LEAVE SO
WE HAVE A LOT OF ISSUES --
BEYOND THIS THAT I HOPE.
AS AS YOU VIEW OTHER BILLS
COMING FORWARD WILL RECOGNIZE --
KIND OF WHAT WHAT'S GOOD FOR THE
GOOSE IS GOOD FOR THE GANDER --
I I JUST I'M I'M CONCERNED --
THAT WERE WERE SOLVING A VERY
SMALL PROBLEM WHICH IS IMPORTANT --
BUT NOT A LARGER ONE I WOULD
ALSO WONDER IF -- INCOME
REPLACEMENT ON A PART TIME JOB
THAT IS 60% OR 70%.
OF THEIR INCOME -- IS REALLY FOR
FILLING RIGHT I MEAN IT'S BETTER
THAN NOTHING YES -- BUT A LOT OF
PART TIME WORKERS WOULD NOT BE
ABLE TO TAKE THE LEAVE IF THEY
ONLY RECEIVE 70% OF THEIR INCOME
BECAUSE OFTEN A PART TIME --
ESPECIALLY WITH PARENTS PART
TIME WORK ON BY MOTHER MIGHT BE
IN THEY HAVE TO WORK IN ORDER --
TO MAKE THE FAMILY INCOME AND
AND THEY'RE JUGGLING -- CHILD
CARE DUTIES AT HOME AS WELL SO
I'M JUST CONCERNED OR OTHER
BILLS COMING THROUGH I KNOW THEY
DEAL WITH ALL THE INCOME
REPLACEMENT.
AS WELL AS JOB PROTECTED LEAVE
FOR FOR WORKERS WHO WORK AND AND
SMALLER COMPANIES AND I THINK I
AM I I HOPE WE CAN CONTINUE THIS
DISCUSSION AND AND HOPEFULLY
MAYBE EVEN SOME POINT.
WRAP ALL THESE IN TOGETHER TO
MAKE SURE THAT.
WHAT WE REALLY SHOULD HAVE IS A
LEAVE POLICY THAT COVERS EVERY
WORKER IN CALIFORNIA AND LEE
POLICY THAT ENSURES THAT YOU CAN
ACTUALLY TAKE SIX WEEKS OF PAID
LEAVE BECAUSE?
YOU ARE YOUR INCOME IS REPLACED
AT A LEVEL THAT THAT FINANCIALLY
THAT'S EVEN FEASIBLE AND THAT
YOUR JOB WILL BE THERE WHEN YOU
RETURN SO I I THINK WE'RE AT THE
SAME WE'RE LOOKING FOR THE SAME
THINGS.
BUT WE'RE PIECE MEALING AND
MAKES ME A LITTLE NERVOUS.
I I WOULD AGREE I THINK OUR
INTERESTS ARE ALIGNED -- THAT
OUR PHILOSOPHIES -- TO SOME
DEGREE ALLIED AND YOU AND I AS
YOU WELL KNOW ON MANY ISSUES
DON'T ALIGN OUR PHILOSOPHY IS
EXACTLY THE SAME AND I CERTAINLY
BELIEVE IN INCREMENTAL PROGRESS --
WHETHER IT'S THE PERFECT -- OR
NOT AND I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
ROOM IN THE SPACE MEASURE THE
THE CURRENT MINISTRATION THE
CURRENT GOVERNOR HAS HIS OWN
IDEAS.
ON THIS SUBJECT THERE'S SEVERAL
OTHER PIECE LEGISLATION -- I
WALKED THROUGH THE DEBATE THE
MERITS OF THOSE IN THIS --
COMMITTEE AT THIS TIME -- BUT I
DO THINK -- THIS IS A KIND OF
COMMON SENSE REFORM IN THIS BILL
AND AN INCREMENTAL PROGRESS ON
THE ISSUE OF MANY OF THOSE
POPULATIONS YOU'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT DOESN'T BY ANY MEANS --
NEGATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO DEBATE --
YOU KNOW MORE DRAMATIC OR OR
MORE AMBITIOUS -- UNDERTAKINGS.
AS WELL BUT I DO THINK THAT THAT
SPEAKS TO THE ISSUE WE'RE TRYING
TO SOLVE HERE IS IT CRAZY A
LITTLE BIT BETTER EQUITY WITH.
PART TIME PLACE AND CONCERNED
THAT THERE ARE A LOT OF FOLKS
OUT THERE IN THE WORKFORCE TODAY
THE REMOTE WORKING MULTIPLE PART
TIME JOBS. TO MAKE ENDS MEET AND
THEN CERTAINLY AS IDENTIFIED IN
MY OPENING COMMENTS THIS NOTION
OF NOT RECOGNIZING THAT YOU CAN
HAVE TWO CHILDREN WITH A TWELVE
MONTH PERIOD -- AND
DISCRIMINATING FRANKLY AGAINST
INDIVIDUALS A FINDING THAT
CIRCUMSTANCE MAKES NO SENSE AT
AND FINALLY IT JUST A
CLARIFICATION BECAUSE I HEARD
SOMEBODY SAY EMPLOYERS WITH
UNDER FIFTY PEOPLE SO THIS --
THIS ALLOWS PART TIME WORKERS
TEMP JOB PROTECTED LEAVE IF
THEY'RE IT LINES UP WITH FEDERAL
THE FEDERAL STANDARD NOT THE
STATE STANDARD.
BECAUSE IN IN THE STATE IF YOU
WORK FOR A COMPANY WITH TWENTY
OR LESS.
YOU DON'T HAVE JOB PROTECTIVELY
BUT TWENTY TO FIFTY IS
PROTECTING CALIFORNIA BUT NOT IN
THE FEDERAL LAW.
SO I I'M I'M JUST THE LANGUAGE
THE BILL IS AT FIFTY TO THE CAN
LOOK AT ALIGNING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STANDARD -- BUT I I
BELIEVE YOU'RE CORRECT IT'S
FIFTEEN ABOUT.
IT IS THAT -- YOUR VIEW OF
INCREMENTAL OR SO SO.
I I AND I DON'T MEAN THAT IN A
MEAN WAY AS I SAID MY OPENING
COMMENTS -- WERE WORKING AND
MASSAGE IN THE LANGUAGE OKAY IS
THERE SOME THAT'S WHAT I MEANT
WHAT I DID WE'RE NOT QUITE OKAY
THE LANGUAGE DOESN'T REFLECT
WHERE WE'RE AT IN OUR
DISCUSSIONS AND WITH THE OKAY GO
I TRIED OUTLINED THAT YOUR
COMMENTS -- I CAN CERTAINLY KEEP
YOU POSTED AS WE BRING THE NEXT
ROUND A LANGUAGE CHEN BUT I
WOULD WE ARE LINED IN OUR
INTEREST.
THE INCREMENTAL STEP FORWARD NOT.
BITING OFF EVERYTHING.
YOUR TO DO AND I I UNDERSTAND
THAT I JUST THINK -- FOR FOR
EVEN WHAT I HEARD YOU SAY YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO SO IF I IT WAS A
PART TIME EMPLOYEE.
AT A COMPANY WITH THIRTY PEOPLE
MY CO WORKER THEN WAS A FULL
TIME PLAY WOULD WOULD HAVE THE
JOB PROTECTED LEAVE.
I'M TRYING TO UNDERSTAND WHAT I
THEN AND I THINK WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING IS MAYBE YOU'RE STILL
WORKING THROUGH WHETHER THAT'S
THE FIFTY STANDARD OF THE TWENTY
SKINNER MAYBE I JUST WANT TO PUT
THAT OUT THERE FOR YOUR STAFF SO
WE CAN THINK ABOUT IT AS
HOPEFULLY THIS COMES
APPROPRIATIONS.
THESE ARE THE KIND OF QUESTION
INTENT WOULD BE TO CONSISTENT BE
CONSISTENT WITH CURRENT LAW
WE'RE NOT GOING TO LIE TO CHANGE.
THAT WITH.
CALIFORNIA WHAT IS LONG AS WAS
DONE CALIFORNIA THINK WE ARE.
YES THEY HAVE A DIFFERENT
STANDARD.
THAT'S OKAY AS WELL.
IT'S GOOD IT'S GOOD IT'S BECAUSE
WE DO NOT INCREMENTAL CHANGE
THANK YOU I'M OF THE BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU -- ANY OTHER COMMENT.
IF NOT I'LL JUST SAY THAT YOU
KNOW I I DO BELIEVE THAT THIS IS
AN IMPORTANT BUILDING BLOCK TO
GOALS THAT THAT APPARENTLY SEEM
SHARED.
INTERESTS PROTECTING ALL WORKERS --
AND I DO APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
EFFORTS -- TO RELEASE SOME OF
THE CONCERNS OPPOSITION.
AND THE NEED FOR MASSAGING -- I
THINK EVEN IN THE COMMITTEE
COMMENTS -- THE THE NEED FOR
GREATER CLARITY MORE SPECIFICITY
AND IT DOES IT THIS DOESN'T JOIN
I DO PASSED TO INSURANCE
COMMITTEE RECOMMENDATION FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE AUTHOR TO
CONTINUE. TO DO THAT AND I THINK
THAT THE RECOGNITION FROM SOME
OF OUR GREAT THAT IS THAT THAT
THAT THAT HE'S THE MORE WORK IS
NEEDED IS APPRECIATED AS WELL.
EIGHT OF HER IF I MIGHT CLARIFY
MISTER YOU KNOW -- ON THE TWELVE
WEEKS OF LEAVE -- ISSUE WE WERE
TAP WE TEMPTED TO NULLIFY THE
STACKING AND WE DISCUSSES WITH
COMMITTEE STAFF -- BUT COUNCIL
DIDN'T. ZERO IN ALL THAT THE WAY
I THINK -- OUR INTENTIONS WERE
HEADED SO THE NEXT SET OF
AMENDMENTS IS GOING TO ADDRESS
THAT WE DISCUSS THAT WITH ME
STAFF AND WE'LL KEEP YOU POSTED --
AS WE GET THAT -- DRAFTING AIR --
SHORT OUT YEAH AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR WORK IN YOUR YOUR STAFF'S
WORK WORKING WITH OUR COMMITTEE
STAFF AND I'M CONFIDENT THAT.
A LOT OF THAT CLEARLY CAN BE
DONE BEFORE HITTING THE NEXT
COMMITTEE AS WELL.
SO -- WITH THAT WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AND WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE --
AFTER I VOTE THANK YOU -- WE
MOTIONS SUMMER GONZALES SECOND
BY SUMMER CARILLO DO PASSED TO
INSURANCE MA'AM SECTOR TO ROLL
PLEASE [inaudible]
KALRA.
I FLORA CREEL [inaudible]
CARILLO I DEEP NO GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I DON'T SWEAR THREE OF
US THAT BILLS ON CALL.
THE BILL REMAINS ON CALL ME ONE
MORE VOTE THANK CHAIRMAN TAKE
MEMBERS THANK YOU SUMMER CARILLO.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO BE HEARD ON
THE FOR THOSE.
OKAY SO I'M AGO WITH MY ONE
ORDER.
AB [inaudible]
SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
AND AGAIN JUST LIKE THE OTHER
BILLS UP TO UP TO SIX MINUTES --
ASIDE.
FOR WITNESS TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU FOR CHAIR WHICH ONE
DID YOU SAY FIRST. SEVENTY EIGHT
ITEM [inaudible]
EIGHT PLEASE ENTER [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
BUT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I AM HERE PRESENTING A.
B..
SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT A FEW DAYS
AFTER TRANSIT.
TRANSGENDER DAVID VISIBILITY A.
B. SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT OF THE BILL
THAT ADDRESSES UNLAWFUL
WORKPLACE PAY DIFFERENCES.
OF EMPLOYEES OF ALL GENDERS.
OUR CURRENT EQUAL PAY ACT
ENSURES THAT EMPLOYEES OF
DIFFERENT GENDER RACE AND
ETHNICITY THROUGH PERFORM.
THE THING ABILITY SIMILAR WORK
ARE PAIRED ARE PAID FAIRLY.
THIS LAW ALSO DISCOURAGES PAY
SECRECY BY PROHIBITING
RETALIATION OR DISCRIMINATION
AGAINST EMPLOYEES WHO DISCUSS
THEIR INCOME OR ASK COWORKERS
ABOUT THEIR WAGES.
AB SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT STRAINS
CALIFORNIA FAIR PAY ACT BY
REMOVING THE GENDER BINARY
TERMINOLOGY EXPLICITLY
INCORPORATING NON BINARY PEOPLE
INTO FOUR EQUAL PAY PROTECTIONS.
AND CLARIFYING THE TRANSGENDER
PEOPLE WHO HAVE ALWAYS BEEN AND
WILL CONTINUE TO BE PROTECTED.
THIS BILL ALSO SPECIFIES THAT
ONE A SINGLE CONFERENCE -- IS
SUFFICIENT TO BRING AN EQUAL PAY
ACT CLAIM TO WORKERS HAVE WON
YOUR FILING DEADLINE FOR
ADMINISTRATIVE RETALIATION
CLAIMS JUST AS THEY DO FOR
FILING CIVIL RETALIATION CLAIMS.
WHILE GENDER NON CONFORMING AND
TRANSGENDER INDIVIDUALS HAVE
ALWAYS OCCUPIED OUR WORKPLACES
THEY HAVE NOT ALWAYS BEEN
LEGALLY RECOGNIZED.
PRO TEM ATKINS GENDER
RECOGNITION ACT OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN PROVIDED FOR A THIRD
NON BINARY GENDER MARKER OPTION
ON CALIFORNIA'S IDENTIFICATION
DOCUMENTS.
WITH THE PASSAGE OF THE GENDER
RECOGNITION ACT WE HAVE A DUTY
TO UPDATE BINARY THOUGHT AS
LANGUAGE AND EXPLICITLY
INCORPORATE PEOPLE OF ALL
GENDERS AND TO EQUAL PAY.
PROTECTIONS.
TRANSCEND NON BINARY PEOPLE
OFTEN FACE UNDUE SOCIAL ECONOMIC
BARRIERS AND DISCRIMINATION.
THIS IS THE PARENT AND THE
TRANSGENDER LAWCENTER SUPPORT
THE DESPITE RELATIVELY HIGH
EDUCATION RATES TRANSCEND GENDER
NON CONFORMING PEOPLE.
ARE UNABLE TO FULLY PROFIT FROM
THEIR ABILITIES DUE TO WORKPLACE
DISCRIMINATION.
TODAY WITH ME ARE TAMMY MARTIN
LEGISLATIVE MANAGER OF EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA.
CAROL HENDON CLIENT OF EQUAL
RIGHTS ADVOCATES TO TESTIFY ON
BEHALF OF THE BILL JESSICA
THUNDER.
PLUS SENIOR STAFF ATORNEY OF
EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES WILL BE
INTRODUCING HER KLEIN OF
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL TECHNICAL
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AND THERE WAS A
MOTIONS MISS AMERICANS ALSO
SECOND THAT MOTION SO WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
TAMMY MARTIN HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE QUALITY CALIFORNIA THE STATE
WIDE OGT Q. CIVIL RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION AND PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF AB SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT
WHICH REFLECTS CALIFORNIA'S
RESPECT FOR ITS DIVERSE
POPULATION.
AND UPDATE OUTDATED LANGUAGE IN
THE STATE'S EQUAL PAY ACT. FOR
TWENTY YEARS EQUALITY CALIFORNIA
HAS LED THE GOLDEN STATE'S FIGHT
FOR FULL LGBT Q. EQUALITY.
AND IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WE
SPONSORED THE GENDER RECOGNITION
ACT AUTHORED BY SENATOR ATKINS
AND SENATOR WIENER.
WHICH ENABLED MORE PEOPLE TO
OBTAIN ACCURATE STATE ISSUED
IDENTITY DOCUMENTS BY CREATING A
THIRD.
NON BINARY GENDER MARKER.
THE CURRENT LANGUAGE OF
CALIFORNIA'S EQUAL PAY ACT
PROHIBITS EMPLOYERS FROM PAYING
AN EMPLOYEE LESS THAN AN
EMPLOYEE OF QUOTE THE OPPOSITE
SEX. FOR SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR
WORK.
THIS BILL WILL UPDATE THE
OUTDATED BINARY LANGUAGE AND
ENSURE THAT EMPLOYEES OF ALL
GENDERS AND GENDER EXPRESSIONS
ARE PAID EQUITABLY.
WE KNOW THAT LGBT Q. PEOPLE AND
TRANS GENDER AND NON BINARY
PEOPLE IN PARTICULAR HAVE
HISTORICALLY FACED HIGH LEVELS
OF SOCIETAL STIGMA AND
DISCRIMINATION.
A RECENT SURVEY REVEALED
PATTERNS OF DISCRIMINATION
AGAINST TRANSGENDER AND NON
BINARY PEOPLE IN A VARIETY OF
SETTINGS INCLUDING IN WORKPLACES.
ONE OUT OF EVERY THREE
RESPONDENTS REPORTED BEING FIRED
DENIED A PROMOTION OR OTHERWISE
BEING MISTREATED AT WORK BECAUSE
OF THEIR GENDER IDENTITY OR
EXPRESSION.
THIS PERPETUATES THE CYCLE OF
ECONOMIC INSTABILITY FOR
TRANSGENDER AND NINE NON BINARY
CALIFORNIANS ONE THIRD OF WHOM
LIVE IN POVERTY.
AB SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT IS A
THOUGHTFUL AND NECESSARY UPDATE
TO EQUAL PAY LAWS AND WE THINK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO FOR
ADVANCING THIS CRITICAL
LEGISLATION.
AND WE URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
SUPPORT AS WELL THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE -- IS JESSICA
STANDARD -- FROM AT EQUAL RIGHTS
ADVOCATES WERE PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR THIS BILL -- AS ASSEMBLY
WITH WOMAN CARDIO MENTIONED
WE'RE HERE TO PROVIDE ANY
TECHNICAL SUPPORT OF QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE -- AND I'M HERE TO
INTRODUCE MY CLIENTS -- CORAL
HAND IN WHO'S GONNA TALK ABOUT
THE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL
WORKERS HAVE THE SAME SUCH
LIMITATIONS FOR FILING
RETALIATION CLAIMS UNDER THE
EQUAL PAY ACT REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER IT'S IN.
THE ADMINISTRATIVE CONTACTS WITH
LABOR COMMISSIONER OR IN A CIVIL
CLAIM IN COURT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB.
SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT WHICH WILL
PROVIDE AN IMPORTANT UPDATES AND
CLARIFICATIONS TO OUR STATE WILL
PAY LAW.
I WORK FOR A MAJOR GOLF RESORT.
FOR ABOUT A YEAR AND A HALF AS A
ROTATIONAL MANAGER.
AND IN THAT POSITION I WORKED
SEVERAL DIFFERENT RESTAURANTS AT
THE RESORT ON A ROTATIONAL BASIS.
DURING THAT TIME I WORKED THERE
I WORKED VERY HARD I DID MY JOB
VERY WELL.
AND I RECEIVED POSITIVE FEEDBACK
AND EVALUATIONS FROM MY
SUPERVISOR'S.
AFTER A LITTLE OVER A YEAR OF
WORKING THERE.
I CAME ACROSS A DOCUMENT ON A
SHARED SERVER THAT LIST OF THE
SALARIES OF ALL THE MANAGERS.
AND REFLECTED DISPARITIES
BETWEEN MALE AND FEMALE MANAGERS.
WITH THE MEN RECEIVING HIGHER
WAGES.
I IMMEDIATELY REFORM TO MY
SUPERVISOR THAT I COME ACROSS
THE DOCUMENT IN THE OFFICES
DIGITAL FILES.
AND GIVEN THAT IT HAD SENSITIVE
WAGE INFORMATION I THOUGHT IT
PROBABLY SHOULD BE PASSWORD
PROTECTED.
I ALSO RAISE A GENDER WAGE
DISPARITY THAT WERE REFLECTED IN
THE DOCUMENT WITH MAJOR
DEPARTMENT.
AS FAR AS I KNOW NO CHANGES IN
PAY WERE MADE AFTER I REPORTED
THE WAGE DISPARITIES.
A FEW MONTHS LATER I DECIDED TO
TAKE ANOTHER JOB BECAUSE IT PAID
MORE.
DURING MY EXIT INTERVIEW THE H.
R..
REPRESENTATIVE ASKED WHY I WAS
LEAVING AND I TOLD HER THAT I
WAS LEAVING EVEN THOUGH I LOVE
MY JOB.
AS I WOULD BE BEING PAID TOO
LITTLE.
AND BECAUSE OF THE PAY
DISPARITIES I'D SEEN BETWEEN MEN
AND WOMEN IN THE DOCUMENT.
THE H. R. REPRESENTATIVE THEN
TOLD ME THAT MY SUPERVISOR WAS
VERY UPSET. FOR ME HAVING RAISE
THE ISSUE OF PAY ESPECIALLY
HAVING TAKEN A TO HR.
I EXPLAINED THAT IT ACTED NOT
WITH ANY MALICE I'D SIMPLY
REPORTED THE ISSUE TO HR BECAUSE
I FELT IT WAS THE RIGHT THING TO
DO.
THE NEW JOB DIDN'T WORK OUT AS
I'D HOPED SO AFTER A FEW MONTHS
I'VE APPLIED FOR SEVERAL OPEN
POSITIONS WITH MY FORMER
EMPLOYER.
I WAS ALREADY TRAINED AND HAD
EXPERIENCE IN ALL OF THE
POSITIONS.
HOWEVER AFTER MONTHS OF APPLYING
AND CONTACTING MY FORMER
EMPLOYER.
NOTHING WAS DONE I NEVER HEARD
BACK.
I WAS CONFUSED AND UPSET BECAUSE
I HAD A GREAT.
HAD BEEN A GREAT EMPLOYEE AND I
FELT THAT I'D HANDLE THE
SITUATION PROFESSIONALLY.
BY REPORTING THE PAY PROBLEM
THAT I HAD DISCOVERED.
IT WAS CLEAR TO ME THAT THEY
WERE NOT CONTACT ME ABOUT THE
OPEN POSITIONS BECAUSE I HAD
RAISE THE ISSUE OF EQUAL PAY.
APPROXIMATELY FIVE MONTHS AFTER
I RE APPLIED TO WORK AGAIN AT
THE COMPANY.
I FILED A WAGE CLAIM AND A
RETALIATION CLAIM UNDER THE
EQUAL PAY ACT.
WITH THE LABOR COMMISSIONER.
INVESTIGATOR CONTACTED ME ABOUT
THE EQUAL PAY CLAIM BUT I WAS
NOT CONTACTED ABOUT THE
RETALIATION CLAIM DESPITE MAKING
REPEATED INQUIRIES.
I FINALLY LEARNED.
THAT THE LABOR COMMISSIONER HAD
DISMISSED MY RETALIATION CLAIM.
ON THE GROUNDS THAT WAS FILED
MORE THAN SIX MONTHS AFTER THE
END OF MY EMPLOYMENT.
I FILED AN APPEAL ON THE GROUNDS
THAT THE DEADLINE FOR THE FILING
OF THE RETALIATION CLAIM WAS ONE
YEAR.
AS STATED IN THE STATUTE.
I DID NOT RECEIVE ANY RESPONSE
FROM THE LABOR COMMISSIONER
ABOUT MY APPEAL OF THE
RETALIATION DISMISSAL.
DESPITE REACHING OUT MULTIPLE
TIMES.
FINALLY THE INVESTIGATOR WHO IS
INVESTIGATING MY EQUAL PAY WAGE
CLAIM TOLD ME THAT THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER WAS UNABLE TO RE
OPEN THE CLAIM.
AND THEN IF I WANTED TO I COULD
REACH OUT TO THE RETALIATION
PUBLIC LINE FOR MORE INFORMATION.
I HAVE SENT MULTIPLE REQUESTS
THE RETALIATION PUBLICATION
PUBLIC LINE BUT I HAVE NOT HEARD
ANYTHING BACK.
I FILED MY PEOPLE PAY.
AND RETALIATION CLAIMS WITH THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER BECAUSE I
COULDN'T FIND A LAWYER AND WOULD
NOT HAVE BEEN ABLE TO FILE A
LAWSUIT ON MY OWN.
I THINK WORKERS SHOULD HAVE THE
SAME AMOUNT OF TIME TO FILE A
RETALIATION CLAIM WITH THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER.
AS THEY HAD TO FILE IN COURT.
WORKERS ABILITY TO FIND A LAWYER
AND A FILE A LAWSUIT SHOULD NOT
DICTATE THE AMOUNT OF TIME SHE
HAS TO SEEK THAT.
JUSTICE FOR THE RICH BEING
RETALIATED AGAINST.
AB SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT WOULD
CLARIFY THAT THE FILING DEADLINE
FOR THESE CLAIMS IS THE SAME
REGARDLESS OF THE FORUM AND I
URGE YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR SHARING YOUR STORY --
ANYONE IN SUPPORT NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION.
SHANNON SMITH RALLY REPRESENTING
THE AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF
UNIVERSITY FOR WOMEN IN
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
VERY CLEAR SHE HARLEM THE
CALIFORNIA PLUMMET LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
THE GUITAR KALRA MEMBERS MITCH
SNIDER WITH CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
KATIE WHICH IT WITH LEGAL AID AT
WORK IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
RENEE BAYARDO SEIU CALIFORNIA
ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY BRING THAT TOO MANY WE DO
HAVE A MOTION [inaudible]
WE ALL ALL ALL ALL ALL YOU TO
SECOND.
OKAY I I'M SECOND BEFORE ABOUT
FOR NOT TO THIS YEAR TO SECOND I
CAN HELP IT SO WE'LL HAVE --
SOMEBODY AT THE SECOND.
AS A WE DO HAVE A MOTION ANY
OTHER COMMENT.
ALL RIGHT WE GO BACK CLOSING
COMMENTS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AB SEVEN FIVE FIFTY
SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT THE BILL THE
REFLECTS AND PROTECTS THE
DIVERSITY OF OUR WORKPLACE AND
WHAT THE FUTURE LOOKS LIKE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO WE DO
HAVE A MOTION FOR SOME NUMBER
GONZALEZ SECONDED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DO YEP I DO PASS AS
AMENDED IT -- TO THE JUDICIARY
[inaudible]
KALRA PLEASE.
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE KALRA AYE KALRA AYE
FLORA.
CREEL.
HI.
I GAVE.
THE I AND SALAS HI THEMSELVES I
JONES SAWYER THREE OF US THAT'S
WHY THE BILL IS OUT.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK [inaudible]
MY
JEFF.
THANK YOU I WILL BE DOING AB
ELEVEN FIFTY EIGHT AND THEN
AFTER THAT WE'LL DO SOME ACROSS
FINAL BILL AND THEN WE'LL DO.
SOME OF HIS OFFICE IS.
EIGHTY FIVE ALL RIGHT A OF AB.
ELEVEN FIFTY EIGHT SUMMER GRIP.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
HELLO [inaudible]
OKAY.
MY AFTERNOON ALL THE BILLS.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT ELEVEN FIFTY
EIGHT TO WHICH SEEKS TO PROTECT
HER WORKER SAFETY BY ALLOWING
FOR THE TEMPORARY SUSPENSION OF
A PERMIT.
TO CONSTRUCT AN ELEVATOR IF AN
INSPECTION DETERMINES THAT THE
WORK DOES NOT COMPLY WITH THE
OPTICAL BUILDING STANDARDS.
THE DIVISION OF OCCUPATIONAL
SAFETY SAFETY AND HEALTH ALSO
KNOWS THE CAL OSHA IF TAX WITH
THE PARTS THE PROTECTING AND
IMPROVING THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
OF WORKERS BY SETTING AND
ENFORCING.
STANDARDS PROVIDING OUT RE TO
EDUCATION AND ALSO ISSUING
PERMIT LICENSE CERTIFICATES AND
APPROVALS STATE LAW REQUIRES THE
NO ELEVATOR OR ESCALATOR BE
OPERATED WITHOUT A VALID AND
CURRENT PERMIT ISSUED BY THE
ELEVATOR UNIT WITHIN THE CAL
WITHIN CAL OSHA.
AND OUTLINES THE CIRCUMSTANCES
IN WHICH A BUILDING PERMIT MAY
BE SUSPENDED.
HOWEVER CERTAIN ELEVATOR CONCERN
ELEVATOR COMPANIES WHO HAVE
BEGUN INCORPORATING INNOVATIVE
TECHNOLOGIES AND CONVEYANCES
HAVE KNOWINGLY INSTALLED
ELEVATORS THAT FAIL TO COMPLY.
WITH CAL OSHA STANDARDS. FOR
INSTANCE SOME OF THESE ELEVATOR
COMPANIES HAVE INSTALLED
ELEVATOR PULLING MECHANISMS
WHICH IS TYPICALLY LOCATED BUT
ABOVE THE ELEVATOR CAR ON THE
SIDE OF AN ELEVATOR INSTEAD
ALTHOUGH THIS IS DONE IN AN
EFFORT TO INTEGRATE NEW
TECHNOLOGIES MODIFICATIONS AS
SUCH EXPOSE WORKERS. TO GRAVE
DANGERS WHEN THEY OPERATE THESE
MACHINES AB ELEVEN FIFTY EIGHT
PROVIDES THAT APERMIT. TO BUILD
OR WORK ON A CONVEYANCE MAY BE
TEMPORARILY SUSPENDED PENDING
NOTICE OF AND IT'S AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTEST OF
SUSPENSION.
IF THE WORK PERFORMANCE THE TERM
AND TO VIOLATE BUILDING CODE OR
OCCUPATIONAL STANDARDS TODAY WE
HAVE SCOTT WEDGE HERE TO TESTIFY
WITH THE AND INTERNAL UNIT OF
ELEVATOR CONSTRUCTIONS LOCAL
EIGHT AND EIGHTEEN AS WELL AS
MISTER CAESAR D. AS FROM THE
BUILDING TRADES.
AND WE HAVE ONE MOMENT PLEASE
GIVE THEM WE HAVE A MOTION FOR
SUMMER BECAUSE ALL THIS IS OUR
SECOND.
OKAY AS WITH A MOTION AND A
SECOND I DON'T BELIEVE THERE'S
ANY FORM OPPOSITION AND I
RECOMMENDATION.
SO MUCH PLEASE GERM BE VERY
BRIEF ON BEHALF OF THE ELEVATOR
CONSTRUCTORS UNION.
IN SHORT THE WHAT HAPPENS IS --
YOU IF AN ELEVATOR IS INSTALLED
THAT VIOLATES EITHER OSHA
STANDARDS OR BUILDING STANDARDS
THERE IS A PROCESS FOR THE OWNER
OF THE BUILDING TO FILE AND ASK
FOR A VARIANCE.
THE PROBLEM IS WHAT THEY'RE
DOING IS THEY'RE WAITING UNTIL
AFTER THE SYSTEMS ARE INSTALLED.
AND THEN IS THE OLD I'D RATHER
BEG FOR FORGIVENESS THAN ASK FOR
PERMISSION.
AND SO WHAT HAPPENS IS THEY GO
WHEN WE WERE THE VARIANCES
REQUESTED EVEN OTHER SERIOUS
HEALTH AND SAFETY CONCERNS.
THE THE OPTION IS IS THAT A
PUBLIC AGENCY LIKE A SCHOOL OR
UNIVERSITY IS FACED WITH
REMOVING. EIGHT ELEVATOR THAT
COST SEVERAL MILLION DOLLARS
THIS IS GREAT PRESSURE TO GRANT
A VARIANCE AND SO WE'RE TRYING
TO GET AHEAD OF THAT SO WE WOULD
ORIGIN I VOTE THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
SURE MEMBERS AS ARE THE OTHER
BEHALF THE STATE BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL ALSO
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
NAME AFFILIATION IMPOSITION.
WHICH DUGGAR CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ALSO IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ANYONE OPPOSITION.
OKAY -- OF WILL BRING A BACK WE
DO HAVE A MOTION FOR SUMMARY
GONZALEZ SECONDED BY SOME IN A
REVERSE IT THERE'S NO FURTHER
COMMENT YOU MAKE CLOTHES NUMBER
CARILLO.
THANK YOU AB ELEVEN FIFTY EIGHT
THIS COMMON SENSE LEGISLATION
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MADAM SECTOR OF CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE.
DO PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
KALRA AYE KALRA AYE FLORA CREEL.
I CREEL I DEEP [inaudible]
I GONZALEZ.
SALAS I JONES SAWYER THREE OF US
[inaudible]
THREE OF US.
RIGHT THE BILL IS OUT.
AND THEN THE THE FINAL BILL FROM
A SUMMER CREEL AS A. B..
FOURTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS A. B. E. R. FOURTEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT WILL ENSURE THE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SURVIVORS HAVE.
THE DESERVE OPTION OF A STRAIGHT
FORWARD AND EXPEDITIOUS LEGAL
PATHWAY TO JUSTICE IN THE CASE
OF THEIR EMPLOYERS WRONGDOING.
AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT IS
NEEDED BECAUSE THE METHOD
VIOLENCE SURVIVORS TO SERVE A
CLEAR AND DIRECTLY EAGLE AVENUE
TO ADDRESS DISCRIMINATION OR
RETALIATION BY THEIR EMPLOYER.
EMPLOYERS PLAY A CRITICAL ROLE
IN SUPPORTING A DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SURVIVOR WHO IS IN THE
PROCESS OF BREAKING FREE.
FROM AN ABUSIVE RELATIONSHIP AND
RECOVERING FROM TRAUMA.
A RECENT STUDY FOUND THAT 38% OF
SURVIVORS OF OF SURVIVORS REPORT
EITHER HAVING BEEN FIRED OR
FEARING TERMINATION BECAUSE OF
THE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SITUATION.
AND 34% REPORT HAVING TO QUIT A
JOB DUE TO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
I IT AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT
WILL PROMOTE ECONOMIC THE
STABILITY FOR SURVIVORS BY
EMPOWERING THEM TO OBTAIN LEGAL
REPRESENTATION AND SEEK JUSTICE.
THROUGH ASSISTANCE NEGOTIATED
THROUGH THE RETURN TO WORK OR
RECOVERY OF LOST WAGES.
ALL GET THE REST OF MY TIME TO
OF THE TESTIMONY HERE TONIGHT
AND ALLOW THEM TODAY AND ALLOW
THEM TO INTRODUCE THEMSELVES
THANK YOU [inaudible]
PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON NOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS KRISTEN I'M SICK I'M WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP TO AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE SPELL.
THIS BILL WOULD.
YOU KNOW HELP STRENGTHEN THE
EXISTING EMPLOYMENT PROTECTIONS
FOR SURVIVORS OF BY ALLOWING
THEM TO EXERCISE THEIR RIGHTS TO
BRING A PRIVATE CIVIL ACTION AS
YOU HEARD FROM THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS OPENING.
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE OR SEXUAL
ASSAULT SURVIVORS OFTEN FEAR AND
PHASE.
RETALIATION DISCRIMINATION AND
TERMINATION AS A RESULT OF THE
VIOLENCE THEY HAVE EXPERIENCED
CALIFORNIA LAW HAS TAKEN A
NUMBER OF STEPS TO JUSTICE --
BUT THE IMPACT OF THESE JOB
LOSSES CAN BE DEVASTATING FOR
SURVIVORS LEADING TO
HOMELESSNESS POVERTY AND
ECONOMIC STRESS.
AND THE CURRENT PROCESS FOR
RELIEF IS CONFUSING AND
BURDENSOME AND THIS BILL
PROVIDES AN IMPORTANT OPTION FOR
SURVIVORS TO BE ABLE.
TO RECEIVE THE RELIEF FOR THE
PROTECTIONS THAT THEY'RE
ENTITLED TO SO WE URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY.
HI MY NAME IS KATIE WHICH AND
I'M AN ATTORNEY WITH LEGAL AID
AT WORK WE ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF
LOW WAGE WORKERS THEM.
THAT'S CRITICS PLAINTIFF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CAN BE
DEVASTATING FOR YOUR FAMILY IS
PHYSICALLY MENTALLY AND ALSO
ECONOMICALLY OFTEN PEOPLE FIND
THEMSELVES IN A SITUATION WHERE
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN YEARS THEY
HAVE TO SUPPORT THEMSELVES AND
THEIR FAMILY ON ONE INCOME.
AT THE SAME TIME THAT THEY NEED
TO TAKE TIME OFF FROM WORK FOR
THEIR HEALTH OR TO SEEK A
PROTECTIVE ORDER.
AND OFTENTIMES THEY ARE
TERMINATED OR RETALIATED AGAINST
WHEN THIS HAPPENS AND WHILE IT'S
A LEGAL UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW
GENERALLY THERE ISN'T MUCH THAT
THEY CAN DO THEY CAN FILE WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF LABOR
STANDARDS ENFORCEMENT
RETALIATION UNIT.
BUT IT CAN BE SLOW THERE MIGHT
BE SIX MONTHS WHERE NOTHING
HAPPENS AT ALL DURING WHICH THEY
DON'T HAVE A JOB.
LOOKING AT THE STATS IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN ONLY TWO
PEOPLE FILE TO SAY THAT THEY HAD
EXPERIENCED RETALIATION FOR
TAKING TIME OFF FOR SAFETY
PLANNING.
AND ONLY EIGHT FILE TO SAY THAT
THEY HAD EXPERIENCED RETALIATION
FOR SEEKING SAFETY
ACCOMMODATIONS AND BASED ON THE
STATISTICS WE KNOW IT'S NOT
BECAUSE IT ISN'T HAPPENING.
IT'S BECAUSE THE PROCESS CAN BE
SLOW AND CONFUSING.
PEOPLE WHO EXPERIENCE
DISCRIMINATION AT WORK BECAUSE
OF RACE OR SEX OR RELIGION --
THEY HAVE THE RIGHT TO GET AN
ATTORNEY AND ARE ABLE TO SEEK
JUSTICE IN THE COURTS AND WE
THINK THAT SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SHOULD HAVE THE SAME
PROTECTIONS THAT WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
JERRY DOYLE AND I HAVE A
CONFERENCE OF CALIFORNIA BAR
ASSOCIATIONS WITH THE SPONSOR OF
THE BILL -- MANY PROVISIONS OF
THE LABOR CODE PROVIDE FOURS
SPECIFICALLY FOR PRIVATE RIGHT
OF ACTION AND IT'S OBVIOUSLY
NECESSARY. TO DO THAT THESE ARE
TWO PROVISIONS OF THE LABOR CODE
THAT REALLY NEED TO HAVE THE
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION.
OPTION BECAUSE THEYARE MORE
CONFUSING THEY CAN BE MORE
HORRIFIC THE TO THE VICTIMS THAN
OTHERS THEY'RE NOT NEARLY AS
STRAIGHTFORWARD AS SOME OF THE
OTHERS.
AND IT'S ONE OF THOSE CASES
WHERE.
YOU REALLY SHOULD BE ABLE TO
HAVE THE KIND OF OPTION WHERE
YOU CAN HAVE AN ATTORNEY.
GUIDE YOU THROUGH THE PROCESS
AND ENSURE THAT YOUR RIGHTS ARE
PROTECTED.
SO WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE TO SUPPORT.
VERY GOOD YES HARD WITH THE
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
JESSICA CENTER WITH LEGAL RIGHTS
ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANYWAY IN OPPOSITION.
AT THE EVERYONE REMAINS SEATED
IF YOU WANT THEIR SPACE IF YOU
CHOOSE TO THIS COUPLE CHAIRS
HERE.
JUST SAID TO SHARE THE
MICROPHONES.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MORE CURTIS
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE THANK YOU SO
MUCH CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY WE APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY HERE
TODAY OBVIOUSLY WE ARE VERY
SYMPATHETIC TO VICTIMS THAT
SUFFER THESE TYPE OF HARM.
HOWEVER OUR CONCERN IS MORE
ABOUT THE LEGAL PROCESS AND WHAT
KIND OF LIABILITY EXPOSURE THIS
WILL HAVE FOR EMPLOYERS AND JUST
TO CLARIFY.
UNDER LABOR CODE SECTION TWO
THIRTY AND THE AMENDMENTS IN
THIS BILL AND ALLOWS FOR AN
EMPLOYEE TO ALSO FILE A CIVIL
ACTION.
THIS MEANS THAT THE EMPLOYEE CAN
FILE WITH THE LABOR COMMISSIONER
AS WELL AS FILE CIVIL ACTION SO
POTENTIALLY PENALIZING THE
EMPLOYER TWICE FOR THE SAME
ALLEGED VIOLATION IT'S NOT AN
ALTERNATIVE TO A CIVIL ACTION.
LIKE IT IS UNDER PAGO PAGO
ALLOWS FOR ALL TURN IT OF REMEDY
IF YOU DON'T FILE WITH THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER.
ADDITIONALLY AND IT DOES NOT
EXEMPT RECOVERY UNDER PAGA SO
REALLY THERE ARE THREE AVENUES
FOR RELIEF PAGA.
THE NEW PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION
THAT THIS WOULD CREATE IN THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER AM.
THE ON THE PROPONENTS OF THE
BILL ARE ACTUALLY CORRECTED THE
REMEDIES FOR INDIVIDUALS THAT
SUFFER DISCRIMINATION AT WORK
BECAUSE OF GENDER RACE AND ALL
THE OTHER PROTECTED CATEGORIES.%
DO YOU HAVE A RIGHT CIVIL ACTION
HOWEVER THEY STILL HAVE TO FILE
AN ADMINISTRATIVE REMEDY WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FAIR
EMPLOYMENT HOUSING SO THERE IS
AN ADMINISTRATIVE REMEDY
REQUIREMENT THAT THIS WOULD SKIP
IN THE LABOR CODE -- INITIALLY
THE DEAL IS THE WE HAVE ALWAYS
BEEN UNDER THE IMPRESSION THAT
THEY ARE CHAMPION FOR EMPLOYEES --
THEY WALK THE EMPLOYEE THROUGH
THE PROCESS LET THEM KNOW OF
THEIR RIGHTS AND THEY PROVIDE
THE ADVICE FOR THE EMPLOYEE
THEMSELVES ALTERNATELY TURN AND
OF THE CURRENTLY UNDER THE LIFE
THE EMPLOYEE DOES NOT WANT TO GO
DOWN THAT ROUTE.
THEY CANNOT AT THIS TIME FILE
PAGA ACTION AND SO THAT'S WHERE
CONCERN IS IS THAT THIS IS
UNNECESSARY AND DUPLICATIVE
ADDITIONALLY IN TWO THOUSAND
THREE WHEN -- SENATOR HANNAH
BETH JACKSON RAN WITH SENATE
BILL FOUR HUNDRED A PRIVATE
RIGHT OF ACTION WAS ORIGINALLY
INCLUDED IN THAT BILL HOWEVER
THAT BILL.
AMENDED OUT THE PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION BEFORE IT MADE IT TO THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK AND WAS SIGNED
IN THE ASSEMBLY IT AT THE
AMENDED OUT VERSION OF THAT BILL
THE REMOVED THE A PRIVATE RIGHT
ABOUT AND WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THIS VERSION OF THE
BILL AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR ARE
KRISPY KAYLEE ON BEHALF OF A
CALIFORNIA AMBULANCE ASSOCIATION
ALSO MY COLLEAGUES AT THE%
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL.
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION A JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY ON ME TO MANAGE THEIR
OPPOSITION IN ADDITION TO THE
COMMENTS THAT MISS CURTIS MADE.
I ALSO WANT TO ADD THAT TO FROM
OUR VIEW THIS AND WE'VE HARDLY
BEEN FANS OF THE PRIVATE
ATTORNEYS GENERAL ACT.
BUT THIS COMPLETELY UNDERMINES
PAGA.
THERE IS NO EXEMPTION SO AS MISS
CURTIS INDICATED THERE ARE NOW
THREE POTENTIAL AVENUES.
OF COURSE WITHOUT THIS WITH THE
NEW PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION
THERE'S NO NOTICE TO THE D. LSE
OR THE LABOR AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT ASSOCIATION THEY CAN
GO SIMPLY TO COURT.
AND THERE WILL BE NO SHARING OF
FIND.
THE LABOR AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY AT THAT ALL
GO ALONG WITH PAGA -- WE FEAR
THAT THIS WILL OPEN THE DOOR TO
CREATING ALL NEW PRIVATE RIGHT
OF ACTION. FOR OTHER LABOR CODE
VIOLATIONS THAT FOLKS DEEM
APPROPRIATE OR NEED IN NEED OF
THAT.
AND SO IF WE'RE GONNA DO THAT WE
SHOULD AT LEAST CUT OFF THE
AVENUE OF PAGO FOR GOING TO
CREATE A SEPARATE PRIDE OF RIGHT
OF ACTION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
I WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE THE QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
WE HAVE.
MOTIONS.
WE DECIDED.
YEAH -- ANY OTHER COMMENT OR
QUESTION.
BUT I WOULD JUST SAY THAT YOU
KNOW THIS IS A DO PASSAGE ISSUE
RECOMMENDATION AYE AYE.
THIS LABOR EMPLOYMENT I THINK IN
TERMS OF GOOD LABOR POLICIES
GOOD OUT THERE ARE SOME
QUESTIONS IN TERMS LEGAL PROCESS
WHICH I THINK ARE MORE SUITABLE
SUITABLE IN THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE TO ADDRESS.
AND SO I KNOW -- THAT THE AUTHOR
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
COMMITTEE STAFF WITH OPPOSITION --
AND AND CERTAINLY WITH JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE STOPPING CHAIR TO
ENSURE THAT SOME OF THE OF THE
LEGAL CLARITY IS THERE AND THAT
SOME OF THE QUESTIONS THAT ARE
BEING POSE.
BUT THE OPPOSITION ARE PROPERLY
ADDRESSED IN THE APPROPRIATE
COMMITTEE -- AND SO WITH THAT --
WHICH THAT CLOSES IN AMERICA
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR A. B.
FOURTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT PROVIDES
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SURVIVORS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CHOOSE WHEN AND
HOW.
THEIR COMPLAINT OF AN EMPLOYER
MISCONDUCT IS HEARD THE ABILITY
TO GARNER DAMAGES FOR THE HARM
THAT THEY HAVE BEEN COST.
AND THE RIGHT TO REPRESENTATION
BY AN ATTORNEY WHO IS
PARTICULARLY EQUIPPED TO DEFEND
THE SURVIVORS BEST INTEREST I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
THANKS WE DO HAVE A MOTION KALRA
PLEASE.
THE PAST TWO JUDICIARY KALRA
FIVE KALRA AYE FLORA CREEL HI
CREEL AYE DEEP.
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ SIDE JONES
SAWYER.
THREE OF US.
OKAY SO THAT BILLS OUT TO
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE NEXT.
THANK YOU.
SENATE MEMBER AND SALAS.
LINE ITEM OF ONE EIGHTY FIVE HOW
AND AND ONCE AGAIN FOR
EVERYONE'S BENEFIT -- AS WE HEAR
THIS BILL JUST LIKE EVERY OTHER
BILL -- THERE WILL BE SIX
MINUTES.
OF A PER SIDE AND I KNOW THAT
BOTH FOLKS THAT WERE FOR AND
AGAINST THIS CARE MANY CAME TO
THE INFORMATION HEARING WERE
ALLOWED.
MORE GENEROUS COMMENTARY WHEN WE
GET THE PUBLIC COMMENT AGAIN
JUST LIKE THE OTHER BILLS --
NAME AFFILIATION AND YOUR
POSITION -- BUT WITH THAT LET US --
BEGIN WITH -- BUT WITH A SUMMARY
GONZALEZ PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS MONTH MARKS ONE
YEAR SINCE THE CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT UNANIMOUSLY ISSUED
THE LANDMARK.
DYNAMICS RULING AGAINST A
NEGLIGENT COMPANY THAT WAS
MISSED CLASS FINE IT'S DRIVERS
IS INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS JUST
TO SAVE A BUCK.
THIS DECISION REPRESENTS WHEN
THE MOST IMPORTANT ADVANCES IN
WORKERS RIGHT IN RECENT HISTORY.
THE ISSUE OF WORKER BEES
CLASSIFICATION IS NOT NEW AND
IT'S NOT EXCLUSIVELY A PRODUCT
OF THE MODERN DAY GIG ECONOMY.
COMPANIES HAVE EXPLOITED WORKERS
FOR DECADES BY USING UNLAWFUL
CONTRACTING PRACTICES IN
INDUSTRIES LIKE CONSTRUCTION
JANITORIAL SERVICE TRUCKING.
DELIVERY AND NAIL SALONS.
THE DYNAMICS RULING WITH THE
MORAL PROCLAMATION BY
CALIFORNIA'S HIGHEST COURT WITH
A MESSAGE THAT RING LOUD AND
CLEAR.
ENOUGH IS ENOUGH GOVERNMENT
CANNOT SIMPLY STAND BY WHILE
COMPANIES DEPRIVE MILLIONS OF
WORKERS OF THE LABOR LAW
PROTECTIONS THEIR RIGHTFULLY
ENTITLED.
TO OUR STATE LEGISLATURE IS A
NATIONAL LEADER IN ESTABLISHING
THE COUNTRY STRONG AS WORKPLACE
PROTECTIONS.
HIVE MINIMUM WAGE AND OVERTIME
PAID SICK DAYS PAID FAMILY LEAVE
THE RIGHT TO ORGANIZE WORKPLACE
PROTECTIONS AGAINST
DISCRIMINATION AND RETALIATION.
BUT IF COMPANIES CONVEY THEIR
OBLIGATION IS EMPLOYERS WITHOUT
CONSEQUENCE THEN THESE LAWS
BECOME WORTHLESS.
COMPANIES THAT USE MISS
CLASSIFICATION TO GAME THE
SYSTEM ALSO PASS ON ALL OF THEIR
TAX OBLIGATION BOTH HALVES THAT
ARE TRADITIONALLY PAID BY
EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEES GO TO
THE WORKER.
THESE COMPANIES CALL THE WORKERS
SMALL BUSINESSES YEAH CONTINUE
TO SET WORKERS RATES DIRECT HOW
THE WORKER MUST DO THEIR JOB AND
IMPOSE DISCIPLINE EVEN WHILE THE
WORKER IS DOING THE MAIN WORK OF
THE BUSINESS.
CALIFORNIA CAN'T AFFORD TO LOSE
WITH THE LABOR COMMISSIONER ARE.
HIS OFFICE ESTIMATES IS SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS IN ANNUAL TAX
REVENUE BECAUSE COMPANIES FORCE
WORKERS INTO LIVING WITH
SUBSTANDARD WAGES AND WORKING
CONDITIONS AND DON'T EXPLAIN
THEIR TAX LIABILITIES.
THE STATE CANNOT ALLOW FREE
WRITING BUSINESSES TO CONTINUE
PASS OFF THEIR OWN BUSINESS COST
ON TO TAXPAYERS AND RESPONSIBLE
BUSINESSES.
AB FIVE CODIFIES AN ABC TEST AS
PRESCRIBED IN DYNAMAX RULING.
TEST OUR STANDARDS FOR TRULY
INDEPENDENT -- ENTITY.
AB FIVE PROVIDES A UNIFORM
DEFINITION FOR THE STATE'S WAGE
ORDERS AND LABOR CODE WHERE
ANOTHER DEFINITION OF EMPLOYEE
IS NOT PROVIDED I'VE HAD THE
PLEASURE SPEAKING TO WORKERS
FROM A VARIETY OF FIELDS.
UP AND DOWN THE STATE FROM
FREELANCE JOURNALIST A TRUCK
DRIVERS TO HEAR SALAS AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THESE
CONVERSATIONS.
SOME WORK HAS BEEN -- CLEARLY
DEFINED IN THIS BILL ALREADY AND
SOME WORK HAS BEEN.
EXEMPTED WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE
TO HAVE THOSE DISCUSSIONS WERE
WILLING TO CONTINUE MAKE CHANGES
AS WE FIND THAT MORE CLARITY IS
NEEDED FOR DIFFERENT INDUSTRIES.
I'M COMMITTED A STRIKING A
BALANCE SO WE CAN EXTEND
CRITICAL EMPLOYMENT PROTECTIONS
TO MORE WORKERS WILL SEPARATE
OUT GROUPS THAT GENERALLY
FUNCTION AS SMALL BUSINESSES.
I'M ALL FOR AN ECONOMY THAT
ENCOURAGES INNOVATION BUT WE
NEED TO BE CLEAR THERE'S NOTHING
INNOVATIVE ABOUT UNDER PAIN
SOMEONE FOR THEIR LABOR ARE
BASED ENTIRE BUSINESS MODEL ON
MISS CLASSIFYING WORKERS.
A TRULY STRONG ECONOMY MESS
INCLUDE ACCOUNTABILITY FOR ALL
EMPLOYERS TO CONTRIBUTE THEIR
FAIR SHARE AND TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE PEOPLE
WHO MAKE THEIR BUSINESS POSSIBLE
AND SUCCESSFUL.
INSTEAD OF USING UNLAWFUL
PRACTICES TO CUT COSTS IN AND
YOUR MIND FAIR COMPETITION.
WE'RE OFFERING AN ECONOMY WORK
INCOME INEQUALITY IS GROWING AND
WORKERS TOO OFTEN LACK THE
BARGAINING POWER TO IMPROVE
THEIR CONDITIONS.
THIS IS OUR OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE
IT CLEAR.
EVERY WORKING CALIFORNIANS EVERY
SINGLE WORKING CALIFORNIAN
DESERVES BASIC PROTECTIONS THAT
ALLOW THEM TO SUPPORT THEIR
FAMILY PEOPLE SHOULD NOT HAVE TO
RELY ON THE EMERGENCY ROOM WHEN
THEY GET INJURED ON THE JOB.
AND SHOULD NOT BE STARTING GO
FUND ME PAGE IS TO FINANCE THEIR
MEDICAL BILLS.
TODAY WE ARE DETERMINE THE
FUTURE CALIFORNIA WORKERS WE CAN
EITHER CHOOSE TO BE COMPLICIT IN
THE EXPLOITATION OF WORKERS OR
WE CAN CHOOSE TO REBUILD THE
WORKING AND MIDDLE CLASS IN THE
STATE.
I HAVE A HOST OF FOLKS WITH ME
TODAY ADD TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
THE COMBINED FOR SIX MINUTES.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS CAITLIN
VEGA FOR THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION WE ARE PROUD TO BE CO
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL.
AS WE HAVE SAID MANY TIMES WE
BELIEVE THAT THE DYNAMAX RULING
OFFERS AS THE POTENTIAL TO BRING
MILLIONS OF WORKERS INTO THE
MIDDLE CLASS AND OUT OF POVERTY.
IT ESTABLISHES THAT EVERY WORKER
THAT DOES THE REGULAR WORK OF
THE BUSINESS SHOULD BE ENTITLED
TO THE MINIMUM WAGE -- AND
THAT'S AN ESSENTIAL PROTECTION.
I WANT TO BE CLEAR THOUGH AB
FIVE DOES NOT MAKE A. B. C. TEST
THE LAW OF THE LAND THAT'S
ALREADY THE CASE THE CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT.
ESTABLISHED THAT TEST IN THEIR
UNANIMOUS DECISION THIS BILL IS
SIMPLY ABOUT CLARIFYING THE LAW.
SAYING WHO IT APPLIES TO SAYING --
WHERE IT NEED NOT APPLY?
AND THAT'S WHY THIS BILL IS SO
IMPORTANT THIS WILL HELP US
IMPLEMENT THE TEST THIS WILL
HELP US HAVE ONE CLEAR
DEFINITION FOR WORKERS AND
EMPLOYERS.
ON AND WE APPRECIATE THE ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE HAVE HAD
WITH THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY --
WE HAVE AGREED TO A COUPLE OF
EXEMPTIONS ON END THE GOAL OF
THOSE THAT HAVE GONE THAT ARE IN
PRINT NOW IS REALLY TO SHOW THAT
THERE SHOULD BE A HIGH BAR.
IF YOU ARE SAYING YOU SHOULD NOT
HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE DOING THE WORK
YOU SHOULD HAVE TO MEET A HIGH
STANDARD THOSE SHOULD BE WORKERS
WHO ARE BEING EXPLOITED WHO ARE
MAKING A DECENT WAGE.
WHO HAVE SOME POWER OVER THEIR
LIVES IN OVER THEIR JOB TIMES
BUT WE APPRECIATE THE ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS -- WE WILL
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT THESE
PROFESSIONAL CATEGORIES AND
FIGURE OUT WHAT THE RIGHT KINDS
OF EXEMPTIONS ARE AS WELL AS TO
ADDRESS.
LEGITIMATE BUSINESS TO BUSINESS
CONTRACTING WHICH IS A NORMAL
PART OF A HOW BUSINESSES WORK
AND WITH THAT I AM I WILL TURN
IT OVER TO CARMEL FOSTER WE'RE
VERY.
PLEASED THAT SHE'S BEEN ABLE TO
JOIN US TODAY.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY
ABOUT MY EXPERIENCE AS A
DOMESTIC WORKER GEEK WORKER AND
A MEMBER OF THE NATIONAL
DOMESTIC WORKERS ALLIANCE.
WHICH IS THE NATION'S LEADING
VOICE FOR DIGNITY AND FAIRNESS
FOR THE MILLIONS OF DOMESTIC
WORKERS IN THE UNITED STATES
INCLUDING CALIFORNIA.
MY NAME IS COME OUT ORCE THAT
I'VE BEEN WORKING IN THE
DOMESTIC WORKER INDUSTRY FOR
SEVERAL YEARS AS A HOUSE CLEANER
AND AM CURRENTLY I PERSONAL CARE
GIVER FOR THE ELDERLY.
AND PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES.
IN SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA LIFE
BOAT IN THE UNITED STATES AND
ABROAD.
INSERT AFRICA I WAS A MEMBER OF
THE AFRICAN NATIONAL CONGRESS
WAY WE WORKED AGGRESSIVELY TO
WIN POLICY REFORMS FOR DOMESTIC
WORKERS.
IN CALIFORNIA THEY ARE OVER
THREE HUNDRED POUNDS AND MOSTLY
IMMIGRANTS WOMEN AND MEN.
OF COLOR WILL WORK AS HOUSE
CLEANERS NANNIES AND IN HOME
CARE PROVIDERS IN PRIVATE HOMES.
NEARLY TWO MILLION HOUSEHOLDS IN
CALIFORNIA RELY ON DOMESTIC
WORKERS.
IN LIGHT OF A HE'S THREE OFF
EXCLUSION FROM BASICALLY.
PROTECTIONS DOMESTIC WORKERS
HAVE.
EDUCATOR FOR OVER A DECADE TO
AFFIRM THE DIGNITY.
OF THEIR PROFESSIONAL.
AND TO AND SECURE BASIC LABOR
PROTECTIONS MOST RECENTLY
DOMESTIC WORKERS WERE EXTENDED.
THE PERMANENT RIGHTS TO OVERTIME
PAY THROUGH SB ONE A ONE FIVE
THE TWO THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN
DOMESTIC WORKERS BILL OF RIGHTS.
DESPITE THE GAINS WE'VE MADE.
WE ARE STILL INDEED EXTREMELY
VULNERABLE TO EXPLOITATION AND
ABUSE.
I WORK IS STILL CONSIDERED
INFERIOR EVEN WHILE I WORK IS
MOVING ONLINE AND NOW ON THE
INDUSTRIES THAT ARE PART OF THE
GIG ECONOMY.
S. DOMESTIC WORKERS WE ARE
FORCED TO ACCEPT.
THESE KINDS OF JOBS.
AND MORE.
ARE MORE PRODUCT PLATFORM SUCH
AS HANDY [inaudible]
WHICH CONNECT. TO PROFESSIONAL
HOUSE CLEANERS.
AND MOVING INTO THE DOMESTIC
WORKER INDUSTRY.
IT HAS PROVEN TO BE THE BEST AND
WORST DEVELOPMENT.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN I
DECIDED TO SIGN UP WITH HANDY
AND WAS HOPEFUL.
THAT IT WAS GOING TO BE A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY FOR ME. TO MAKE A
LIVING WAGE.
IT WAS NOT LONG BEFORE I HAD
MANY CHALLENGES.
SOON I REALIZED I DIDN'T HAVE
BASIC WORKPLACE AND LABOR
PROTECTIONS.
SUCH AS THE RIGHT TO MINIMUM
WAGE OVERTIME MEAL AND REST
BREAKS AND TRAVEL TIME
COMPENSATION.
LIKE OTHER DOMESTIC WORKERS.
WHO DON'T TO WORK THROUGH ONLINE
PLATFORM COMPANIES INCLUDING
THAT RIGHT?
THERE TO WERE GAINED ON THE
DOMESTIC WORKERS BILL OF RIGHTS.
THERE WAS NO TRANSPARENCY ABOUT
HOW MY PAY WAS ACTUALLY
CALCULATOR AND ACCOUNTABILITY IN
THE COMPANY'S RATING POLICIES
WHICH ARE DIRECTLY TIED TO HOW
HANDY.
WORKERS WAGES ARE DETERMINED.
FOR EXAMPLE IF I DID NOT HAVE
ENOUGH TIME TO DO THE WORK
REQUESTED ENOUGH HOURS I WAS
PAID.
FOR THIS RESULTED IN CUSTOMERS
RATING ME POORLY.
WHICH AFFECTED MY HOURLY RATE
AND ABILITY TO ON CONSISTENT
RAGE.
WHEN I DID GET A NEGATIVE
CUSTOMER REVIEW HANDY WOULD NOT
DISCLOSE THE ACTUAL PROBLEM OR
CLIENT WHO MADE THE COMPLAINT?
SO IT COULD BE RESOLVED WHICH
AFFECTED MY ABILITY TO GET MORE
WORK BECAUSE THEY CONTROL WHAT
JOBS ARE AVAILABLE TO HANDY
WORKERS.
BASED ON CUSTOMER RATINGS
HOWEVER WORKERS AREN'T ABLE TO
DISPUTE THE RATINGS ON THE WAGES
WE AS A RESULT I DIDN'T GET FAYE
AND LOVABLE WAGES BECAUSE MY
RATES DID NOT INCREASE.
SOON I STARTED GETTING MORE FEES
IMPOSED DENNIS MY RATINGS DROP
MY PAY RATE DROPPED.
EVEN LOWER HANDED FEES ARBITRARY
AND PUNITIVE AGAINST THE WORKERS
FOR EXAMPLE DAVIS TIMES MY FEES
WERE MORE THAN WHAT I WAS GOING
TO OUR OWN.
AND WHEN THIS HAPPENED I HAD TO
WORK ON A PLOT PLATFORM. FOR
FREE IN ORDER TO PAY.
THE FEES I'VE BEEN TOLD THIS IS
A FORM OF WAGE THEIR THINK THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR PERSONAL
TESTIMONY -- WE HAVE A LOT ALL
THE TIME IF IF FOLKS WANT TO
STATE THEIR POSITION -- PLEASE
DO SO.
AND THEN -- ACTUALLY ONE BEFORE
WE GET TO THAT WE HAVE AN
UNUSUAL SITUATION HERE AND I'LL
HE'S NOT SURE PROVISIONS WE HAVE
ACTUALLY ENORMOUS NUMBER OF
SUPPORT IF AMENDED.
SO I'M GONNA ASK THOSE THAT THAT.
JUST FOR SUPPORT RIGHT NOW.
AFTER WE DO SUPPORT ALLOW
SUPPORT IF AMENDED TO ALSO HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK MORE
FULLY AND THEN MORE ALLOW
OPPOSITION TO DO THE SAME.
JUST BECAUSE I THINK THERE'S A
LOT OF NEW WANTS TO THIS I WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE GETTING.
ALL THE FEEDBACK TO THE TO THE
MEMBERS SO FOR RIGHT NOW THIS IS
JUST.
FOR PURELY SUPPORT NOT SUPPORT
OF AMENDED PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME AFFILIATION STARTING WITH
FOLKS AT THE TABLE PLEASE I'M.
MY NAME IS DAVID KINNEY WITH THE
GREATER CALIFORNIA LIVVIE
ASSOCIATION.
REPRESENT THE FIVE THOUSAND
SEDAN IN THE MISSING OPERATORS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OR IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
RESEARCHER MEMBERS AS ARE THE
OTHER BEHALF OF THE FOUR HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND MEN AND WOMEN
STILL A SKILLED BUILDING TRADES
COUNCIL -- IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
RESCUE IVY Là WITH THE NATIONAL
DOMESTIC WORKERS ON BEHALF OF
THE THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOMESTIC WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
A MISTER ROOM MEMBERS JOHN
NORWOOD ON BEHALF THE
INDEPENDENT INSURANCE AGENTS
ASSOCIATION THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH
UNDERWRITERS THE FOUR HUNDRED
AND TWENTY THOUSAND LICENSED
INSURANCE AGENTS AND BROKERS IN.
CALIFORNIA WE SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
STERN MEMBERS BOB ACT ON BEHALF
OF TWO MEDICAL SPECIALTIES
RADIOLOGY PATHOLOGY IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL I THINK YOU.
JESSICA CENTER ON BEHALF OF
EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD AS YOU ARE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PLAN MILLERS
ASSOCIATION AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MIKE MONEY GOING
TO BE OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION ELECTRICAL WORKERS A
CALIFORNIA STATE BY PRINCE
COUNCIL AND THE WESTERN STATES
COUNCIL OF SHEET METAL WORKERS
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MIKE WESTWOOD DISTRICT COUNCIL
SIXTEEN PAINTERS AND ALLIED
TRADES IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
CATHERINE PORTER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTHY NELSON LONG
COLLABORATIVE IN VERY STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SHERMAN MEMBERS WAS IN HERE
LABOR STATE COUNCIL IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON LEAGUE BYNUM YOU
W. ASK ME LOOK AT THEIR AT
THIRTEEN FULL SUPPORT THANK YOU.
TIM CRAVENS INTERNATIONAL UNION
OF OPERATING ENGINEERS AND FULL
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN BRANDON WITH
ROCK SONGS SO SEE ATION OF
SUPPORTING THE BALLOT THANK SOME
AMERICAN DOLLARS FOR WORKING
WITH ANTHRAX OUR LANGUAGE.
THANK YOU.
MARJORIE FINE WITH SHAKLEE
CORPORATION SUPPORTING THE
DIRECT SELLER LANGUAGE IN THE
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MICHELLE -- BAY
WIH MERRY KANE AND REPRESENTING
FORTY SEVEN THOUSAND INDEPENDENT
CONSULTANTS IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
UNDER A REPAIR ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
TAYLOR JACKSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THE ONLY BE DRAWN WITH MAKE YOU
CAPTAIN ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
LIFE AND HEALTH INSURANCE
COMPANIES AS WELL AS NAY BUT
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
SAM APPELLATE BLUE GREEN
ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
AMY DURBIN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT
I THINK THE AUTHOR AND SPONSORS
FOR THEIR WORK WITH US THANK YOU.
AND WE MUST DO MORE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP FOR
WORKING FAMILIES EBAY'S WORKING
PARTNERSHIPS BECAUSE LANE
WAREHOUSE WORKERS RESOURCE
CENTER -- CORD AND CPI IN SAN
DIEGO IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS UNITE HERE THE
MACHINISTS THE AMALGAMATED
TRANSIT UNION UTILITY WORKERS
AND THE IMPLEMENTATION AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU EDWARD ESCOBAR FOUNDER
OF THE LINES FOR INDEPENDENT
WORKERS HASHTAG DRIVERS TONIGHT
NATIONAL AND INTERNATIONAL
MOVEMENT ON BEHALF OF OVER LIFT
DRIVERS AND ALL GET WORKERS.
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. TO MAD
REYES IN THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
OF AMERICAN COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
IT'S NOT YOUR HERNANDEZ AND WE
HAVE THE COMMUNICATION WORKERS
OF AMERICA DISTRICT NINE AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JANET WHO TAKE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
INTERPRETERS AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
CBS ON MONTH IN ALSO UNDER HOW
FOR CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
INTERPRETERS VERY MUCH IN FULL
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI DAVID GONZALEZ I'M HALF OF
AMERICA'S VISION GROUPS AND
SUPPORT AND I THINK THE AUTHOR
IN THE SUPPORTERS FOR THEIR WORK
ON THIS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON JOANNE VETTING
COURT REPRESENTING THE
SECURITIES INDUSTRY AND
FINANCIAL MARKETS ASSOCIATION.
LIKE THIS I THINK THE AUTHOR THE
SPONSORS AND YOU'RE ON YOUR
STAFF -- TO FOR YOUR WILLINGNESS --
TO ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS THANK
YOU. THREE TWENTY SAYS HE ARE
YOU USE THE VARIOUS WANT THANK
THE AUTHOR AND FOR ALL OTHER
MEMBERS STATEWIDE WE ARE STRONG
SUPPORT THANKS.
WHEN I START THIS ME NUMBER A
LOT I SEE BONTA E. SO YOU'RE NOT
ANY THAT I CAN SACRAMENTO YES
THEY KEEP IT UP WE HAD AT THE
LAKE YES YES CLASSES? ONE OF
SEVEN THE NUMBERS CATALINA CHEN.
US H<c.cyan>EMBER OF THE LOW CUT</c>
LACE ACA.
IF A IF A E. U..
N. KNOWS SOMETHING ABOUT SUPPORT
THAT IS TIMELY BASIS.
CHRISSY NUMBERS SACRAMENTO SEIU
US W. W. IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
FOR PREVIOUS ASSETS SACRAMENTO
CENTRAL ABRE COUNCIL A FELL CHAU
ON BEHALF OF HUNDRED THREE
THOUSAND MEMBERS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
RENEE BAYARDO SO YOU CALIFORNIA
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KATIE WHICH IT FREE LEGAL AID AT
WORK AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JAZZY GIRL UCW WESTERN STATES
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS CHERYL BARTLETT
I'M FROM SAN JOSE CALIFORNIA
WORK FOR THIRTY FIVE YEARS WITH
PRIMERICA INSURANCE COMPANY
PRIMARILY PART TIMERS AND WE
NEED THE FLEXIBILITY THEY USED
TO SEND HIM TO EITHER.
BUY HOMES OR START THEIR
FAMILIES.
THANK YOU WE SUPPORT THE BILL AS
AMENDED THANK YOU.
JOSH PANE FROM SAN JOSE
CALIFORNIA PRIMERICA FINANCIAL
SERVICES AND SUPPORT THE BILL
WITH AMENDMENTS THANK YOU.
GARY MARTIN PRIMERICA FINANCIAL
SERVICES THIRTY FIVE YEARS.
SUPPORT THE BILL AS AMENDED
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
BREAK LIABILITY WITH APEX GROUP
ON BEHALF OF FINANCIAL SERVICES
INSTITUTE FOR IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
OKAY -- IT SO I'M GONNA ASK OF A
COUPLE FOLKS CAN CLEAR THE TABLE
SO IF THERE'S ANYONE FROM
SUPPORT THIS IS SUPPORT IF
AMENDED.
SUPPORT IF AMENDED.
MISTER CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY AND I'LL BE BRIEF --
BECAUSE WE DO APPRECIATETHAT
THERE WAS ALREADY AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON THIS IN
THE COMMITTEE SO WE DON'T NEED
TO DIVE INTO THE HISTORY AND
DYNAMICS BUT IT WAS A
SIGNIFICANT CHANGE IN THE LAW --
THAT HAD BEEN IN PLACE FOR OVER
THIRTY YEARS IN IN ONE DAY
BASICALLY THE LAW CHANGED -- AND
IMPACTS APPROXIMATELY FROM OUR
ESTIMATES OVER TWO MILLION --
INDIVIDUALS IN CALIFORNIA WHO
PERFORM WORKS AS AN INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTOR AND WE APPRECIATE THE
CLARIFICATION THAT HAS ALREADY
BEEN MADE IN THE BILL WE DO
THINK IT'S A GREAT STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION TO PROVIDE
CLARITY AND TO RECOGNIZE.
THAT THERE ARE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PERFORM WORK AS INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS AND SHOULD MAINTAIN
THAT STATUS -- WE'RE CERTAINLY
NOT INTERESTED IN A PROTECTING --
THOSE EMPLOYERS WHO OF ABUSE THE
SITUATION EITHER UNDER THE
DYNAMICS RULING OR THE BRILLO
DECISION BUT WE'VE HAD
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE SPONSORS OF THIS BILL ON
FINDING COMMON GROUND WHERE WE
CAN -- PROVIDE FURTHER CLARITY --
FOR PROFESSIONALS -- PERFORMING
WORK AS INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS
BUSINESSES AND SUBCONTRACTING
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING
FOR THE CONVERSATIONS ON THAT
ISSUE SO THANK YOU FOR THE TIME.
THANK YOU SUPPORT IF AMENDED
ANYONE ELSE FRED JONES ON BEHALF
OF THE PROFESSIONAL BEAUTY
FEDERATION CALIFORNIA HAVE A
GOOD CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
AUTHORS OFFICE AS WELL AS THE
SPONSORS AND WE ARE OPTIMISTIC
OKAY THANK YOU.
SO IF WE CAN HAVE ANYONE ELSE --
THE LINE UP FOR SUPPORT OF
AMENDED AGAIN NAME AFFILIATION
POSITION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR
STACEY VALLEY ON BEHALF OF ROVER
DOT COM WE'RE TO SUPPORT AMENDED
POSITION AS WELL WE CONNECT --
PET OWNERS WITH DOG SITTERS AND
WALKERS VIA AT PLATFORM IN
CALIFORNIA THANK THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS SHERRY RANKIN.
AND I AM AND UBER PARTNER
[inaudible]
I'M SORRY [inaudible]
SORRY.
I ASK YOU. TO PLEASE IF.
I'M IN SUPPORT OF AMENDED.
IF IT WASN'T FOR OVER.
I WOULD BE SLEEPING IN MY CAR.
PLEASE DON'T TAKE THAT AWAY FROM
US WE WANT OUR FLEXIBILITY WE
WANT TO BE ABLE.
TO PROVIDE OUR OWN SCHEDULE
BECAUSE SOME OF US HAVE TWO JOBS.
SO WE NEED THAT FLEXIBILITY TO
DETERMINE.
IF WE CAN WORK IF WE CAN'T WORK
SO PLEASE DON'T TAKE THAT AWAY
FROM US THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
UP BREAK LEAD BUILT AGAIN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA YACHT
BROKERS ASSOCIATION WERE IN THE
SAME BOAT.
AS A INSURANCE BROKERS AND WE
HOPE THAT WE CAN CREATE A
FAILING TRANSITION OR LOOKING
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
OTHER SIDE NICE MOVE I SEE YOU
TO THEIR HELLO I'M JACK FROST.
PRESIDENT OF SMALL BIZ
CALIFORNIA.
I REPRESENT THE BEST INTEREST OF
OVER TEN MILLION SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS AND THEIR EMPLOYEES.
WILL BE AFFECTED BY THIS BILL.
A SUPPORT -- IF AMENDED THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
WOULD BE PROUD CALIFORNIA NEWS
PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION SUPPORT
OF AMENDED THANK YOU.
KERRY COOPER REPRESENTING A AND
THEN HEALTHCARE FROM SAN DIEGO
THE LARGEST HEALTHCARE STAFFING
COMPANY IN THE COUNTRY.
AND WE APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENT
EXEMPTED POSITIONS NOW WE'RE
ASKING FOR A NURSE PRACTITIONERS
AND PHYSICIAN ASSISTANTS BECAUSE
THEY ARE UNDER THE SAME LOCUM
TENENS PROCESS THAT THE
POSITIONS ARE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON KERR BLACK AND WE
HAVE THE WESTERN STATES TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION -- SUPPORT IF
AMENDED TO FIVE PROVIDE A
REGIONAL PATHWAY FOR UNDER
OPERATOR TRUCK DRIVERS TO
MAINTAIN THEIR INDEPENDENCE
THANK YOU.
CHARLIE RAY CALIFORNIA
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRIAL
MATERIALS ASSOCIATION SUPPORT OF
A MAN.
I THANK YOU.
HEY MISTER CHAIR -- MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE WE'RE ACTUALLY
HERE IN SUPPORT MY NAME IS BRIAN
NELSON WITH THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES THINK THIS
AMAZING BILL -- JUST RAN UP HERE
A LITTLE LATE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU DIDN'T SAY THE HOUSE AND
WHAT ABOUT YOUR OTHER ARM.
THIS KID JUST KIDDING.
THE AUTHOR IS VERY GENTLE AND
PEACEFUL -- OKAY SO I'M -- AND
SO I I APPRECIATE MY THE THE IT
WAS A DOLLARS ON THAT'S AS WE
HAD AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF
SUPPORT IT AMENDED.
AND SO NOW OF HE COULD HEAR FROM
THE OPPOSITION.
DOES ANYONE IN OPPOSITION THAT
WOULD LIKE TO COME FORWARD AND
EXPRESS THEIR CONCERNS THOUGHTS.
AND PLEASE TAKE A SEAT AGAIN
I'LL BE UP TO SIX MINUTES AND
THEN WE WILL ALLOW OPPORTUNITY.
FOR THE PUBLIC TO ALSO STATE
OPPOSITION.
I CHAIR MAT ROOMING WITH COPPER
TRUCKING ASSOCIATION HERE IN THE
POSE LESS AMENDED POSITION.
A SMALL BUSINESS AND EVENT
TRACKERS ARE THE BACKBONE OF THE
TRUCKING INDUSTRY. 90% OF
CALIFORNIA MEDICARE PERMIT
HOLDERS.
I HAVE ONLY OPERATE FIVE OF YOUR
TRUCK 70% OF THOSE ONLY OPERATE
ONE SINGLE TRACK.
IT IT IS THESE SMALL PROBABLY
MINORITY ENTREPRENEURS.
WHO WERE IN DANGER OF LOSING
THEIR LIVELIHOODS DUE TO THE
DYNAMIC DYNAMAX DECISION?
THE AVERAGE AND BEEN A TRUCKER
HAS APPROXIMATELY TWENTY YEARS
OF DRIVING EXPERIENCE.
DUE TO LABOR SHORTAGES CURRENTLY
NUMBERING OF AROUND.
TWENTY TEN THOUSAND A DRIVERS IN
CALIFORNIA ALONE INDEPENDENT
TRUCKERS WOULD HAVE NO PROBLEM
FINDING A JOB AS A CAN DRIVER IF
THEY THOUGHT THAT CHOICE
[inaudible]
IN FACT.
THE DRIVER THE COUNT 474% OF OUR
WORKFORCE RIGHT NOW.
BUT THESE INDIVIDUALS THE CHOSEN
REMAIN INDEPENDENT.
THE FIRE WAGES.
GREATER FREEDOM TO THE SCHEDULE
AND THE ABILITY TO BUILD
SOMETHING FOR THEMSELVES.
MANY HAVE INVESTED HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS IN THE
BUSINESSES TO COMPLY WITH CARP.
REGULATIONS AND INVESTMENT THAT
WOULD BE LOST UNDER DYNAMAX.
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR
AND OUR AND OUR LABOR
COUNTERPARTS FOR MEETING WITH
THE INDUSTRY AND CONTINUING TO
HAVE A WE BELIEVES PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS.
I AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING AS WE GO.
THANK YOU.
MISTER TURN NUMBERS CORPS IN
JENSEN WHAT TECH THAT -- I'LL BE
SHORT AND SWEET TODAY BECAUSE
YOU GUYS HAVE HEARD FROM HIM
BEFORE -- TECHNICIAN IS THEN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
GIVEN THE MOST RECENT AMENDMENTS
DOWN ADDRESS AND DON'T YET
CONTEMPLATE TECH MATS MEMBER
COMPANIES CONCERNS RELATED TO ON
THE
HAVE ON THE CALIFORNIA
ECONOMY AND THE AVAILABILITY OF
FLEXIBLE WORK OPPORTUNITIES. TO
DATE THERE HAVE BEEN NUMEROUS
DISCUSSIONS BETWEEN TECH MATT
MEMBER COMPANIES AND LABOR AND
WE APPRECIATE THE COLLABORATIVE
NATURE OF AND MANY WORKERS ONLY
AS AS WELL AS READ OTHER SMALL
IS.
AT THAT WOULD OTHERWISE HAVE
BEEN ECONOMICALLY THREATENED WE
BELIEVE CALIFORNIA IS UNIQUELY
POSITIONED TO DEVELOP A SOLUTION
AS BOTH PRO INNOVATION AND PRO
WORKER AND THAT CAN BE A MODEL
FOR THE NATION.
AND WE ARE COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING THE HARD WORK THAT
HAS BEEN TO THAT'S DONE THAT'S
FAR AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR AND ALL
STAKEHOLDERS AND BALD IN THIS
PROCESS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OF ANY OTHER ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
A NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION.
MY NAME'S DEBBIE FERRARI I
REPRESENT OWNER OPERATORS AND
SMALL AND MEDIUM BUSINESS I
OPPOSE AB FIVE IN LESS AMENDED.
BECAUSE IT IS IMPROPER TO HELP
SOME WHILE HURTING OTHERS AB
FIVE FORCES LEGITIMATE OWNER
OPERATORS TO LOSE THEIR TRUCK
BECAUSE OF THE B. PRONG THE
EMPLOYER BY LAW IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE TRUCK.
HE MUST MAINTAIN IT TAKE CARE
THE EXPENSES THE INSURANCE ON
THE LIABILITY THEREFORE AB FIVE
TRIES TO FORCE LEGITIMATE OWNER
OPERATORS TO GET RID OF THEIR
TRUCK.
BE TRUCKS BECAUSE TRUCKERS ALL
WE WAS WORK FOR OTHER TRUCKERS
THOUSANDS IN YOUR DISTRICT DOWN
OTHERS WITH OWN TRUCK AND PERMIT
WOULD WOULD FACE SEVERE
FINANCIAL AND EMOTIONAL LOSS.
OKAY THANK YOU EVERYONE ELSE
JUST NAME AND TITLE WE STILL
HAVE SOME TIME UNDER THE SIX
MINUTES SO -- I KNOW THAT MISS
PRIORITIES REPRESENTING A NUMBER
OF FOLKS I APPRECIATE HER A MORE
THOROUGH -- FEEDBACK EVERYONE
ELSE A NAME TITLE AND POSITION
PLEASE.
OSCAR FRANCO OWNER OPERATOR
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR OUT AYE
OPPOSED AB FIVE UNLESS AMENDED
THANK YOU -- MY NAME IS TOMMY
CARTER.
I OWN TLC TRUCKING LLC.
I'M OF TO CARRY PERMIT CARRIER --
REGISTER TO HAVE A BUSINESS
LICENSE -- RECOGNIZED BY THE DMV
AND THE C. H. P. D. O. T..
AND CALIFORNIA AS BEING PER
MINUTE AND ABLE -- TO RUN MY OWN
TRUCK AND I'D LIKE TO LEAVE IT
THAT WAY -- OPPOSED -- TO AB
FIVE THANK YOU.
I AM GONNA SEND ERA I OPPOSE AB
FIVE AS IT IS WRITTEN NOW. FOR A
CALIFORNIA OWNER UPPER TRUCKERS.
AS OF THE DEVASTATING.
FOR THE OWNER OPERATOR
CHARACTERS THANK YOU.
MY INSTRUCTOR I OPPOSE.
EIGHTY FIVE I'VE BEEN DOING THIS
FOR THIRTY YEARS AND I DON'T
THINK I'M EMPLOYABLE.
A THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS SIX MILES SANDOVAL
AND I'VE BEEN SOUTH HOLLER FOR
ALLEGRA TRUCKING FOR OVER SIX
YEARS.
AND I'M OPPOSED TO A. B. FIVE
THANK YOU -- GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS AT LEVEL RUN HANNAH.
AND I AM AN INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTOR ARE YOU POLLS -- AB
FIVE IT WOULD HURT MY FAMILY
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS ALICIA GONZALEZ ON
THE LEFT DRIVER.
AND I BY A MY FLEXIBILITY ABOVE
ALL ELSE I OPPOSE THE BILL
UNLESS IT'S AMENDED. TO PROTECT
OUR VALUES AND FLEXIBILITY THANK
YOU.
ALUMINUM REMEDIES -- FLORES --
YES THEY ARE KIND OF GOING
THROUGH A LOT LATE THIS LATE
HOUR ESSAY -- SINGLE.
JUDGE GIOVANNA MUCHO MAS THEN
THAT'LL CLONE.
CONFRONT THIS TIME IN THE END
THERE COMO.
EMPREGADO I WOULD AFFECT US ON
THEM THANK YOU.
CLASSES.
MY NAME'S ERIC WASHBURN I'M IN A
MEETING A CONTRACTOR I'VE BEEN
DOING THIS FOR THIRTEEN WILL.
FOURTEEN YEARS AND I'VE DONE
VERY WELL FOR MY FAMILY.
pI DEPEND ON MYSELF AN OPEN ON
ANYBODY IT'S ALREADY.
LIKE WORK FOR ANYBODY I WANT.
THANK YOU.
ALL I MEAN NUMBER STYLE PROJECT
AYE YES THIS WIKI AND GOING
THROUGH THE LATE YEAH I HAVE A
SINGLE.
FOCUS THERE -- DOMINICAL MAKE
PERFECT ON THE ON THING WOMEN'S
PROPIAS BETTER MISSILES --
YOU'RE WELCOME WHICH ALLOWS THE
NETTLE KAMAL WENT OUT THIS THING
THAT BEEN THE END TO GET COME ON
GET COMO AND BILLY IDOL SO YES
AMERICANS ABOUT A MONTH AND THEN --
IDEAS -- THE WEATHER MEANT TO ME
FOR ME AND I CS CLASSES.
HI MY NAME IS ARIANNA GOMEZ I'M
A LIFT DRIVER AS WELL AS THE
STUDENT I OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
TO PROTECT MY FLEXIBILITY.
THANK YOU.
HI AND CAN ROBERTS -- DRIVER FOR
LEFT AND I OPPOSE AB FIVE THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS LAURA TO ALLOW AND
SEE PM MORE CARRIER PERMIT
HOLDERS IT'S HARD TO BE A
EMPLOYEE IF YOU OWN YOUR OWN
TRUCK.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ANNA
AND I AM A TRUCKER INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTOR I AM OPPOSED OF AB
FIVE YOU CANNOT BE SOMEONE
ELSE'S EMPLOYEE IN ON YOUR OWN
TRUCK IDEAL.
SUBSTANDARD WAGES DOES NOT APPLY
TO ME BY LAW AN EMPLOYER'S
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE TRUCK AND
NOT JUST IS NOT THE CASE WITH ME.
I ASKED FOR AN EXCEPTION FOR
TRUCKER MOTOR CARRIER PERMIT
HOLDERS WE ARE CATEGORY THAT IS
DESERVING THANK YOU THANK YOU.
STEPHEN WELSH AND I OPPOSE AB
FIVE IN THIS BE PRONG IS AMENDED
TO RECOGNIZE PERMITTED
CALIFORNIA MOTOR CARRIERS AS
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS WE DO
NOT WANT TO BE FORCED TO BECOME
EMPLOYEES AND HAVE OUR FREEDOM
TAKEN AWAY TO CHOOSE WHERE WHEN.
AND WHO YOU WORK FOR AS WELL AS
HOW MUCH WE MAKE THANKS THANK
YOU.
I'M CHITRA SHARMA INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTOR AND I OPPOSE THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS SERVICING AND A
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS AND I
PUT THIS VIDEO THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S TOM VANCE AND I OPPOSE
THE BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS A KURDISH BRADLEY AND
I'M A DRIVER FOR LEFT AND UBER
AND I OPPOSE THE BILL NEXT
AMENDED.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS COULD TAKE HIS THE
METERS AMOUNT OPERATED FOR
THIRTY FIVE YEARS AND OPPOSE THE
BILL LISTEN DEMAND [inaudible]
THANK YOU -- MY NAME IS SCOTT
DAMMIT DAMMIT TRUCKING THE
REDWOOD CITY I'M OPPOSED AB AB
FIVE UNLESS IT'S AMENDED THANK
YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MATT GRAY ON
BEHALF OF CAL SMALL BIZ IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS -- TO I'M -- FROM
VIETNAM I OPPOSE THE A. B. FIVE
AND I BELIEVE THAT I COME HERE
BECAUSE OF THE ONE WORLD FREEDOM.
IT IS AFRAID I'M HERE.
I GOT TO CHOOSE WHAT I WANT TO
DO SO I GOT TO REALLY I LIKE IT
I LIKE TO BE IN A PEND
CONTRACTOR. FOR WHOEVER I WANT
TO LOOK FOR THANK YOU AYE
OPPOSED.
TO EIGHTY FIVE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
VIC.
NAME IS BIG TAYLOR OWN HAITI'S
PERFORMANCE.
HAVE A MOTOR CARRIER PERMIT.
AND I OPPOSE AB FIVE UNLESS
PRONG BE IS.
AMENDED THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS THE HOTEL THE MAI
DEFENDED CONTRACTORS -- I PLAY
THE BASS.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME ADD THESE ON ME AND I
AM -- IN THE BEGUN TO CONTACT
THEM SO -- AYE OPPOSED -- TO AB
FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS THE ON FILE I MODE SO --
OWNER OPERATOR I SUPPOSE TO AB
[inaudible]
FIVE THANK YOU.
NAME IS MATT LOW I OPPOSE AB
FIVE UNLESS THE PEOPLE AS
AMENDED THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS THERE ARE STILL A
GREAT TRUCK DRIVERS WHO OWN
THEIR OWN TRUCKS HAVE THEIR OWN
OPERATING THIRTY RUN THEIR OWN
LOGOS.
AND COMPLY WITH STATE AND
FEDERAL REGULATIONS TO MAINTAIN
THEIR INDEPENDENCE I OPPOSE AB
FIVE THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON SIR MY NAME ME
GET THE LEAP SAYING I'M ALL NOT
A BETA AND ABOUT FLORA FRANK C.
LIKE GREAT.
FROM TWENTY TWO YEARS AND I POSE
THIS THIS BETTER TAKE MY MY FOOD
AND MY INDEPENDENT URGING ALL
BLOCKING ABILITY.
SO I AFFORD THIS STRONGLY AND I
WANT TO REMAIN THE SAME AS I AM
BUT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OKAY -- THANK YOU
EVERYONE -- BUT THAT'S TAKEN THE
TIME TO BE A PUBLIC COMMENT AS
WE GET BACK. TO THE COMMITTEE.
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
IN ORDER MOTION [inaudible]
OKAY ANY.
COMMENT ON IT.
THANK YOU YES THE CHECKS --
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY WOMAN FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL UP TO
COMMITTEE -- I WOULD LIKE TO
SHARE -- VERY RECENT STORY FROM
A CONSTITUENT OF MINE HIS NAME
IS ROBERT HE DRIVES FOR LEFT.
HE WAS ALSO A CONTRACTED WORKER
WITH FED EX OR THE UNIFORM DROVE
THE TRUCK DID NOT HAVE THE
BENEFITS THE NOT GET PAID
OVERTIME.
THIS IS ALL.
A VERY INTERESTING CONVERSATION
THE RECENTLY HAPPENED HAPPENS
BECAUSE I NEEDED A RIDE TO THE
AIRPORT TO COME TO WORK.
AND SO CAN THE CONSTITUENT LIVES
IN MY SAME NEIGHBORHOOD I ASKED
HIM HEY HOW DO YOU LIKE DRIVING
FOR LIFT.
SAYS WELL I STARTED DRIVING FOR
LIFT BECAUSE I HAD THIS OTHER
JOB WHERE I WAS AND HIRE FULL
TIME HE WAS DRIVING AROUND OUR
DISTRICT WHICH IS MOSTLY HILLS.
AND BECAUSE OF THAT HE WASN'T
ABLE TO MAKE -- HIS DELIVERIES
ON TIME.
AND SO HE WAS GETTING DOT BY HIS
CONTRACTED EMPLOYER.
AND HE WOULD STAY EXTRA TO MAKE
HIS DELIVERIES WITHOUT GETTING
PAID OVERTIME AND I THOUGHT WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN TO HIM.
IF SOMETHING HAPPEN TO HIM ON
THE JOB WHO WOULD BE RESPONSIBLE
FOR HIS WORKERS COMPENSATION.
NO ANSWER TO THAT.
HE SAID HE FELT JILTED HE WASN'T
TAKEN SERIOUSLY AS AN INDIVIDUAL
HUMAN BEING.
AND SO HE STARTED WORKING FOR
LEFT AND HE LIKED THE
FLEXIBILITY OF THE HOURS HE
LIKED THAT HE WAS ABLE TO MAKE
HIS OWN SCHEDULE.
UNTIL HE HAD AN INCIDENT IN
WHICH HE GOT A OF YOU KNOW WENT
TO GO PICK SOMEBODY UP A WOMAN
AT A BAR THE COPS WERE THERE
THERE HAVE BEEN A FIGHT.
THINGS HAPPEN THAT BARS -- THE
WOMAN UNFORTUNATELY HAVE HAD TOO
MUCH TO DRINK GOT IN THE CAR HE
FELT AS HUMAN BEING RESPONSIBLE
FOR HER.
HOW DO YOU TAKE CARE OF SOMEONE
WHO'S INEBRIATED IN THAT STATE?
TOOK HER TO HER DESTINATION.
MUCH IS VERY ANGRY AND ASSAULTED
HIM.
STARTED HITTING HIM.
YOU KNOW WHAT TO DO OTHER THAN
TO MAKE SURE THAT SHE GOT TO HER
PLACE SAFE -- I DON'T THINK THAT
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN THE
SITUATION FOR HER HAD BEEN
SOMEONE ELSE WITH LESS.
MORALS -- LIFT APPARENTLY HAS --
AN EMERGENCY NUMBER THAT YOU
CALL AS A DRIVER AND HE CALLED
IT TO FILE.
WHAT HAD HAPPENED TO HIM?
AND NO ONE PICKED UP.
THERE WASN'T ANYBODY ON THE
OTHER END.
AND THE ONLY THING THAT HE COULD
DO WAS GIVE HER A LOW RATING.
AND THEN WRITE A COMMENT.
THAT SOMETHING HAD HAPPENED IN
THIS PARTICULAR RIDE.
HE DID GET A CALL BACK UNTIL THE
FOLLOWING DAY HOURS LATER.
IN WHICH HE SHARED THAT -- THE
PERSON ON THE OTHER END OF THE
LINE SAID WELL ARE YOU OKAY.
HE SAID YOUNG FINE BUT THAT'S
NOT.
WHY I'M CALLING OUR WAY CALLED?
AND THAT HE FELT INCREDIBLY
ALONE.
WHAT IF SOMETHING WOULD HAPPEN?
WHAT IF IT WOULD HAVE GONE A
DIFFERENT DIRECTION?
WHAT WERE HIS RIGHTS AS A WORKER?
AND SO I TOLD THEM -- WE'RE
DOING THIS SMALL LITTLE THING
CALLED AB -- FIVE AND HE SAID I
WANT TO KNOW MORE.
BECAUSE THIS IS NOT A JOB THAT I
THOUGHT THAT I WOULD HAVE.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT I'M
ABLE TO PAY MY RENT TO PUT FOOD
ON THE TABLE BUT I ALSO WANT TO
FEEL SAFE.
AND I THINK THAT THERE IS YES
THERE'S A LOT OF FLEXIBILITY IN
SCHEDULES OR IS IT SOMETHING
VERY IMPORTANT TO BE SAID ABOUT.
BEING ABLE TO MAKE YOUR OWN
SCHEDULE.
DEPENDING ON WHAT IT IS THAT YOU
NEED TO DO IN YOUR LIFE.
BUT WE DON'T HAVE THIS PROBLEM
FIVE YEARS AGO SO WE ARE IN A
NEW AGE A NEW ECONOMY.
IN WHICH WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
RIGHT NOW TO DEFINE WHAT THE
RIGHTS OF WORKERS ARE FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
HOPEFULLY SET A TONE FOR THE
NATION BECAUSE SURE.
WE LOVE INNOVATION WE WANT TO
USE TECHNOLOGY WE WANT TO USE
THESE APPS THAT MAKE OUR LIVES
EASIER.
BUT IT SHOULDN'T BE AT THE COST
AND WELL BEING OF WORKERS WHO
DESERVE TO HAVE A LIVING WAGE TO
HAVE BENEFITS TO HAVE A RIGHT TO
JOIN A UNION IF THAT'S WHAT THEY
SO CHOOSE TO DO.
BUT ALSO SHOULDN'T FEEL
DISCRIMINATED IF THEY ARE
WORKING IN THE SAME PLACE WHERE
THEY KNOW THAT OTHER WORKERS ARE
FULLY EMPLOYED WITH BENEFITS
WHILE THEY THEMSELVES DON'T HAVE
THOSE THINGS IT CREATES A
DIVISION.
AND THAT'S NOT WHAT WE'RE ABOUT
SO I WANTED TO SHARE THAT
TESTIMONY ON HIS BEHALF BECAUSE
IT COMES DIRECTLY FROM MY
DISTRICT.
AND IT SHOWED ME THE REAL
IMPLICATIONS OF WHAT IT TRULY
MEANS AND WHAT HE IS TRYING TO
DO AND LIVE HIS LIFE.
SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THAT IS A QUESTION OF
FOR THE AUTHOR AND YOUR YOUR
WITNESS -- COULD CERTAINLY
ANSWER I IN TERMS OF FLEXIBILITY --
I THINK THAT THERE IS OFTENTIMES
MENTIONED THAT BUT THIS BILL
FLEXIBILITY IS LOST OR STATUS
CHANGES BOX BUT HE CAN YOU
ANSWER A TO THAT.
FLEXIBILITY IS A 100% AND THE
CONTROL OF THE EMPLOYER -- AND
SO WHETHER AN EMPLOYER CHOOSES
TO ALLOW WORKERS FLEXIBILITY --
AS LIFTING OVER CURRENTLY DO ARE
ON ON THEIR PLATFORMS WOULD BE
THE SAME IF THEY WERE EMPLOYEES
THE WORKERS THEMSELVES IT WOULD
BE UP TO UBER OR LEFT -- TO TO
DECIDE IF THEY GAVE WORKERS THAT
FLEXIBILITY OR NOT -- THE
DIFFERENCE WOULD BE OF COURSE
THOSE WORKERS COULD COME
TOGETHER -- AND AND I HAVE A
COLLECTIVE VOICE.
WITH THEIR EMPLOYER ABOUT THAT
DESIRE FOR FLEXIBILITY SOMETHING
THAT RIGHT NOW IS IS.
ALTHOUGH HAPPENS.
AND OFFICIALLY IT IS REALLY
BARRED BY FEDERAL LAW.
OF AND SO I THINK THAT IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT AYE AYE A
EVERYBODY THAT SAYS THEY WANT
FLEXIBILITY WE UNDERSTAND THAT
THAT IS ABSOLUTELY.
IN THE HANDS OF OF LIFT AND UBER
AND SO I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND THAT
THIS BILL DOESN'T TAKE AWAY
FLEXIBILITY.
THERE IS NOTHING IN THE LABOR
CODE OR AN EMPLOYEE EMPLOYER
RELATIONSHIPS -- THAT DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT AN EMPLOYER IS
FLEXIBLE IN THIS BILL DOES NOT
CHANGE THAT THIS PLEASE.
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION
MISTER CHAIR I JUST WANTED TO
ADD ON BEHALF OF MY OF ONE OF
THE WITNESSES THAT WAS SITTING
UP HERE EARLIER AND DID NOT GET
A CHANCE TO TESTIFY -- HE SPOKE
ABOUT HIS OWN LIMOUSINE SERVICE
COMPANY AND SAID THEY HAVE THE
EMPLOYMENT MODEL THEIR EMPLOYEES
ARE ALLOWED TO DECLINE JOBS
THAT'S PART OF THE WAY THEY RUN
THAT BUSINESS IT IS AN ON DEMAND
BUSINESS.
AND SO YOU HAVE TO HAVE THAT
KIND OF FLEXIBILITY TO BE ABLE
TO HAVE DRIVERS AVAILABLE TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE DRIVERS WILLING TO
KIND OF GO WITH THE SUPPLY AND
DEMAND OF THE WORK AND SO
THERE'S NO REASON AN EMPLOYER.
CAN'T OFFER AS MUCH FLEXIBILITY
AS THEY WANT AND IN FACT MANY
MANY EMPLOYERS CHOOSE TO DO THAT
WHILE STILL PROVIDING THAT
SAFETY THAT FOR THEIR WORK AND I
DIDN'T HINDER HIS ABILITY TO BE
FLEXIBLE IN TERMS OF OPENING
LIMOUSINE SERVICE.
AND QUITE FRANKLY -- TO LET
LET'S POINT OUT THAT -- THERE IS
FLEXIBILITY NOW BECAUSE OF THE
SUPPLY AND DEMAND ISSUE ON THE
FLEXIBILITY ONLY EXISTS BECAUSE
PEOPLE WANT A RIDE THAT'S THE
SAME THING THAT WOULD HAPPEN IF
THEY WERE AN EMPLOYEE EMPLOYER.
PEOPLE WOULD BE TO RIDE AND IF
THAT WAS AVAILABLE THAT THEY
PLOY E. COULD WORK -- IF NOBODY
WANTED TO RIDE WITH IN THIS
PLATFORM THERE IS NO FLEXIBILITY
BECAUSE YOU REALLY CAN'T WORK IF
NOBODY NEEDS A RIDE LIKE WISE
THAT WOULD CONTINUE TO HAPPEN.
THANK YOU UP I HAVE SOME
COMMENTS I WANT TO GIVE LIFE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AN OPPORTUNITY
IF THEY DO HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
OKAY WELL I JUST WANTED TO THANK
THE AUTHOR BUT I ALSO WANT.
TO THANK EVERYONE THAT WAS HERE
BOTH SUPPORT SUPPORT WITH THE
MAN OPPOSITION.
THERE'S BEEN A LOT.
UNDERSTANDABLY CONVERSATION
MEETINGS AND THERE WILL CONTINUE
TO BE.
ON THIS ISSUE -- AS INDICATED BY
THE AUTHOR AS WELL AS IN -- THE
STAFF ANALYSIS UP THIS BILL IS
CAUGHT UP BY EXISTING LAW BASED
UPON THE SUPREME COURT DECISION.
IF NOTHING IS DONE THAT IS THE
LAW AND IT STANDS.
AND SO I UNDERSTAND WHY THERE'S
GREAT INTEREST FROM EMPLOYERS
FROM FOLKS WILL WORK IS IN A
CONTACT AS FOR BUT WORKERS -- IN
THIS BILL BECAUSE OF WHAT IT.
DOES OR DOESN'T DO.
BUT JUST TO MAKE IT CLEAR IF
NOTHING HAPPENS THE STATE OF THE
LAW.
AS AS A RULED UPON AND ACTUALLY
SUBSTANTIATED IN SUBSEQUENT
LITIGATION AND RULINGS FROM
COURSE THAT ARE ALREADY USING
DYNAMAX AS PRESIDENT.
THAT ABC TEST IS LAW IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I MENTION THAT BECAUSE THE THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS BILL IS NOT
JUST DEALING WITH THIS
CLASSIFICATION IS ALSO TOOK TO
ALLOW THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
STATE. TO TAKE A POSITION AS TO
HOW THE COURT RULING SHOULD BE
APPLIED IN A WAY THAT MAKES
pAND SO IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT OF
THE DIALOGUE CONTINUE.
FROM ALL INTERESTED PARTIES I
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS OF I
KNOW THAT THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
WORK HAS BEEN DONE WITH
DIFFERENT INDUSTRIES --
CERTAINLY MY OFFICE AND I I
REALLY WANT TO THANK THE AUTHORS
OFFICE WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE
LABOR COMMITTEE -- AS WELL TO
ENSURE THAT AS THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD -- THAT THIS FIRST GO
AROUND INCLUDES AMENDMENTS THAT
EXEMPTS CERTAIN INDUSTRIES BASED
UPON A LOT OF MEETINGS A LOT OF
CONVERSATION.
A LOT OF DIALOGUE -- AND THAT
THE THESE MEETINGS AND
CONVERSATIONS AREN'T GONNA STOP
GOING FORWARD -- THAT BEING SAID
IT IS THE POSITION OF OF OF OF
THE THE UNDERLYING POSITION.
OF CERTAINLY.
MYSELF AS LABOR CHAIR AND I
BELIEVE AS THE AUTHOR IS THAT
THE DYNAMIC RULING WAS A CORRECT
RULING.
IN TERMS OF THE UNDERLYING
MESSAGE THAT IT WAS SENDING.
AFTER YEARS AND YEARS AND YEARS
AND DECADES OF MISS
CLASSIFICATION.
THAT BEING SAID THERE ARE STILL
MORE AMENDMENTS TO COM MORE
CONVERSATION TO COME AND SO I'M
REALLY REALLY GRATEFUL TO
EVERYONE THAT'S BEEN ENGAGED IN
THIS.
THAT'S GOOD BECAUSE IT'S GONNA
REQUIRE FAR MORE DIALOGUE GOING
FORWARD WE HEARD IT FROM
INDUSTRIES I HAVE CONTINUED
CONCERNS BUT ALL THE EXPRESS
APPRECIATION FOR THE MANY MANY
HOURS THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN
SPENT -- BOTH WORKING OUTSIDE
THE BUILDING WITH WITH DIFFERENT
STAKEHOLDERS WITH LABOR WHAT
HAVE YOU.
BUT I THINK EVEN MORE
SIGNIFICANTLY WITH OUR AUTHOR
WITH A SUMMARY GONZALEZ WITH --
OUR COMMITTEE AND I WANT TO
REALLY THANK A MEGAN THAT LANE
OUR CHIEF CONSULTANT WHO HAS
SPENT MANY MANY HOURS NOT JUST
WRITING ANALYSIS BUT IN MEETINGS.
GETTING INFORMATION OUT TO
INTERESTED STAKEHOLDERS WORKING
WITH LABOR WORKING WITH
EMPLOYERS WORKED WITH THE
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE. TO MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYONE HAS THE
PROPER INFORMATION SO THAT THESE
CONVERSATIONS CAN CONTINUE.
AND SO I'M VERY ENCOURAGE OF
WHERE WE ARE IN A RELATIVELY
EARLY STAGE OF THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS THIS IS THE FIRST
COMMITTEE HEARING -- IN THIS
PROCESS AND SO WE KNOW THIS IS
AN EXTRAORDINARILY COMPLICATED
ISSUE ESPECIALLY AS IT APPLIES
TO THE TRUCKING INDUSTRY THE
TRUCKING INDUSTRY IS NOT ONE
THING.
IT'S VERY COMPLICATED WE'RE
REALIZING THAT WERE LEARNING
THAT AND SO I ENCOURAGE EVERYONE
TO CONTINUE TO ENGAGE -- TO SEE
IF THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY -- OF
FOR A MORE AMENDMENTS THAT MEET
THE NEEDS OF EVERYONE BUT I WILL
SAY THIS.
IF THE BILL DOES REACH THE
GOVERNOR'S THAT'S THE STOCK IN A
SATISFY EVERYONE'S NEEDS --
THAT'S FOR CERTAIN BECAUSE NOT
EVERYONE AGREES WITH UNDERLYING
DECISION OF DYNAMICS AND SO
THAT'S WHERE YOU'RE COMING FROM
I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
EXPECTATIONS ARE SET.
FAIRLY AND THAT PEOPLE.
HAVE THAT UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
CASE IN ITSELF DOES PROTECT
WORKERS THAT'S BEEN A LONG TIME
GOAL OF THIS LEGISLATURE -- AND
SO WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
MOVE IN THAT DIRECTION BUT I
THINK THAT WE ALWAYS HAVE TO
HAVE OUR DOOR OPEN.
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT ALL
FLEXIBILITY IS ALLOWED WITH ALL
THE INDUSTRIES THAT ARE AFFECTED.
AND SO I KNOW THAT'S WHAT HOW
HARD THAT THAT THE THE AUTHORS
OF WORKING ON IN THAT DIRECTION --
AND WILL CONTINUE AS A
LEGISLATURE TO SUPPORT THE
AUTHOR AND MAKING SURE THAT THAT --
COMMUNICATION CONTINUES AND SO
WITH THAT I DO WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR THIS IS IT AN
EXTRAORDINARY CHALLENGING
UNDERTAKING NO ONE HAD TO BRING
THIS BILL OR DEAL WITH THIS.
THE FACT THAT WE DO HAVE AN
AUTHOR THAT ALREADY HAS SHOWN
FLEXIBILITY BY ALLOWING THE HAVE
BY HAVING AMENDMENTS IN THIS
COMMITTEE.
AND THAT THERE'S GOING TO BE
CONTINUE TO WORK GOING FORWARD I
THINK INDICATES THE DEGREE TO
WHICH OUR AUTHOR IS WILLING TO
WORK.
WITH OPPOSITION WITH THE SUPPORT
WITH THE MEN'S AND WITH
EVERYBODY ELSE OUT THERE -- BUT
THEY HAVE A BROKEN ARM OR NOT
THAT SHOWS UP TO THE TO TESTIFY
OR TO SHOW SUPPORT.
SO THANK YOU A SUMMER GONZALEZ
AND YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU --
AND THANK YOU FOR THAT ROB OF I
THINK YOU DID A REALLY GOOD JOB
AND AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
ESPECIALLY. FOR THE FOLKS WHO
TESTIFIED TODAY I WANT TO THANK
ALL OF THEM WHO CAME FORWARD.
AND THERE ARE SOME THINGS SO I I
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
BE HONEST WITH PEOPLE AND
SOMETIMES I THINK -- AND
ORGANIZATIONS.
MAYBE THERE'S GET SOMETHING LOST
IN THE TRANSLATION WHEN WHEN
WHEN ORGANIZATIONS ARE TELLING
THE WORKERS -- WHAT THEY'RE
SEEKING OR WHAT THEY SHOULD BE
THINKING OR WHAT COULD HAPPEN
AND I KEPT HEARING A FEW THINGS
TODAY AND I JUST WANT TO BE
REALLY CLEAR BECAUSE I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW THIS --
NOBODY IS TAKING PART BE OUT SO
PART B. IS ESSENTIAL TO THE
DYNAMICS DECISION AND IT IS IT
IS.
THAT THE MIDDLE PART OF A TEST
SO -- SO IT TO BELIEVE AT LEAST
IN THIS BILL.
THE ONE I'M CARING AND PART B.
WILL NOT BE TAKEN OUT SO I I
JUST WANT TO SAY THAT BECAUSE
THAT'S NOT EVEN IN NEGOTIATED
STANDPOINT WHAT WE'VE DONE ON
EXEMPTIONS IS THIS.
WE'VE TAKEN WORKERS WHO FIRST OF
ALL HISTORICALLY HISTORICALLY
HAD CERTAIN ASPECTS THAT MADE
THEM IN A DIFFERENT WAY TO ORDER%
IN THE LABOR CODE.
THINGS LIKE THE BILL EIGHTY TO
SOUTH NEGOTIATE RIGHT THERE
SETTING THEIR OWN RATES THEY
HAVE THEIR OWN STRUCTURE -- THEY
THEY ARE WORKERS FIND FAR THAT
SATISFY OUR TEST FOR FOR
SALARIED EXEMPTS.
WORKERS IN OTHER WORDS IT THEIR
THEIR SALARY IS IS AT LEAST
TWICE THE MINIMUM WAGE ME WE'RE
NOT WORRIED IF AS MUCH ABOUT
OVER TIME.
AND AND REST PERIODS AND BREAK
PERIODS THEY HAVE ALL THE SHARE
THESE FEATURES -- THEY HAVE THE
ABILITY TO NEGOTIATE FOR
THEMSELVES THEIR RATES ARE NOT
FAT I THINK THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT -- WHEN RATES ARE SET
BY A MASTER CONTRACTOR THAT
MEANS YOU'RE WORKING FOR
SOMEBODY -- FOR THE MOST PART IN
AND ALL ALL JUST AND I'M STE I'M
SORRY I I REALLY WANT TO TALK TO
ALL THE WORKERS BECAUSE I DON'T
THINK THIS IS UNDERSTOOD. FOR
EXAMPLE WE COULD LOOK AT
COSMETOLOGY AND THAT'S AN ISSUE
THAT WE'RE GOING.
TO WORK ON IN THE NEXT FEW WEEKS
WITH -- HAIR STYLISTS IN AND
NAIL SALON OWNERS AND THERE IS A
DIFFERENCE AND WE ALL KNOW THIS
IF YOU GO TO YOUR YOUR YOUR HAIR
STYLIST IN YOURTHEIR BOOKING
YOUR APPOINTMENT THE RENTING A
CHAIR.
THEY'RE SETTING THE RATES
THERE'S NOT RATES ON THE ON ON
THE WALL THAT TELL YOU HOW MUCH
THEY'RE CHARGING THAT MEANS ARE
WORKING FOR THEMSELVES VERY
SMALL BUSINESS THEY'RE
NEGOTIATING WITH YOU.
IF I'M WORKING FOR A COMPANY
WHERE EVERY HAIR CUT IS SEVEN
DOLLARS AND THAT'S ALREADY BEEN
SOUTH DECIDED AND THERE'S
SOMEBODY ELSE DECIDING WHEN I AM
I'M GOING TO SCHEDULE YOU AND
HOW OFTEN I'M THERE.
THAT'S THAT'S NOT AN INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTOR THAT DOESN'T FOUNDER
FEEL LIKE A SMALL BUSINESS AND I
I WANT PEOPLE TO REALLY THINK
THROUGH WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
HERE WE'RE TRYING TO ENSURE.
THAT PEOPLE WHO ARE INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS UNDERSTAND IN KNOLL
NOT JUST THAT THEY HAVE
FLEXIBILITY BUT THEY HAVE
CONTROL OVER -- THEIR WORKPLACE
AND HOW MUCH.
FRANKLY THEY MAKE IDEAL
FLEXIBILITY AND AND LIVE DRIVERS
AND I NOW LIVE DOES A GOOD JOB
OF OF WITH SOME DRIVERS OF
BRINGING THEM HERE -- YOU KNOW I
ALSO HAD A STORY AND I'M START
TAKING TOO MUCH TIME BUT THIS IS
FOR ME SUCH AN EMOTIONAL ISSUE.
I WAS IN THAT THE CHAIRS I
DISTRICT ON FRIDAY.
AND AND I I TOOK AN UBER.
OF A DRIVER WHO ALSO DROVE FOR
LEFT IN AS I DO EVERY TIME I ASK
ABOUT ABOUT THEIR SITUATION AND
AND HOW THEY WORK -- AND HE WAS
A SINGLE DAD HE HAD FOUR KIDS
AND HE SAID THAT HE STARTED
DRIVING.
AT TO SUPPLEMENT A PART TIME JOB
IN AT FIRST WHEN IT FIRST CAME
OF THIS WAS FIVE SIX YEARS AGO
HE WAS ACTUALLY MAKING REALLY
GOOD MONEY HE SAID -- IN THE SAN
JOSE AREA YOU KNOW IF YOU WORKED
IF YOU WORK AS A DRIVER FOR
SIXTY HOURS A WEEK WHICH IS A
LOT OF WORK -- THAT HE COULD OF
MAKEUP CLOSE TO TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS A WEEK AND HE COULD
ACTUALLY YOU KNOW GET BY IN AN
BILL TAKE CARE OF HIS FOUR KIDS --
HE SAID OVER THE TIME PERIOD
WHAT HE SAW IS THAT ABILITY TO
MAKE THAT MONEY WENT DOWN AND
DOWN AND DOWN.
AS THESE TWO COMPANIES BATTLED
AND THAT HE IS NOW -- BRINGING
HOME ABOUT A THOUSAND DOLLARS A
WEEK WORKING SIXTY HOURS A WEEK
AND SAN JOSE WHICH IS HIGH A
COST LIVING.
BEFORE TAXES AND THEN HE HAS TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO PAY HIS TAXES
HE HAS NO HEALTH INSURANCE IT IS
CHILDREN ARE NOT INSURED -- HE
HE HAS NO SAFETY NET IF HE GETS
HURT ON THE JOB HE DOESN'T HAVE
WORKERS COMPENSATION HE HAS NO
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE IT IF
SOMEHOW HE HE LOSES THAT JOB.
AND HE EXPLAINED TO ME THAT THE
FEAR THE FEAR OF OF UBER OR LIFT
OR ANY TECH COMPANY AFTER BASED
COMPANY OF OF RETALIATING
AGAINST HIS ABILITY TO EARN
MONEY THROUGH THAT PLATFORM
WITHOUT EXPLANATION.
THEY CAN DROP A DRIVER WITHOUT
EXPLANATION IN WHICH CASE HE IS
STILL A FATHER OF FOUR KIDS.
LIVING IN SAN JOSE WITHOUT
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE AND
WITHOUT HIS ABILITY TO EVEN MAKE
A CAR PAYMENT.
SO I THINK WE HAVE TO UNDERSTAND
THAT -- YOU KNOW IT WE SAW A LOT
OF CELEBRATIONS ON FRIDAY
BECAUSE IT THE DAY THIS MAN TOLD
METHE STORY.
THE DAY THE MAN TOLD ME THE
STORY WAS THE SAME DATE WE SAW
LIVE CELEBRATE BECOMING.
AT A COMPANY VALUED AT TWENTY
BILLION DOLLARS BILLION WITH A
B..
THAT HIGH THAT'S A INNOVATION
THAT'S GREAT BUT IF YOU'RE A
TWENTY FOUR BILLION DOLLAR
COMPANY IN YOU GET ON TELEVISION
AND SAY IF YOU HAVE TO PAY YOUR
WORKERS MINIMUM WAGE AND PROVIDE
WORKERS COMPENSATION.
AND IN OVERTIME AND IN PAID SICK
LEAVE AND PAID FAMILY LEAVE IF
YOU HAVE TO DO THESE THINGS THAT
EVERY OTHER COMPANY IN
CALIFORNIA IS EXPECTED TO DO.
THAT YOU CANNOT SURVIVE IN THE
MARKETPLACE I WOULD VENTURE TO
SAY THIS IS NOT HOW CAPITALISM
IS SUPPOSED TO WORK.
THAT IS THEN EITHER FAKE VALUE
OF A COMPANY AND MEANS A LOT OF
PEOPLE GET RIPPED OFF WITH STOCK
OR THEY HAVE A REALLY BAD
BUSINESS MODEL THAT THEY CAN'T
EVEN PLAY THEIR WORKERS BUT
SOMEHOW THEY CAN PAY.
THEIR STOCKHOLDERS -- WHO WHO
BASICALLY ARE INVESTING IN A
COMPANY THAT THEY SAY THEY SAY
THEY CREATED THE VALUE IS TWENTY
EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS I AT
COMPANY?
THE SAME WEEK THAT WORKERS HAD
TO GO ON STRIKE BECAUSE THEIR
PER MILEAGE FEE WAS BEING CUT.
AN INVESTOR WAS CELEBRATING HIS
THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLAR
INVESTMENT THAT BECAME A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
ONE DAY.
SOMETHING IS WRONG WITH THE WAY
WE HAVE ALLOWED THESE COMPANIES
TO OPERATE.
AND THE PEOPLE WHO PAY ARE YOU
IN ME THE PEOPLE THAT PAY ARE
GOOD COMPANIES LIKE OUR REMOTE
SERVICES THAT PAY EITHER DRIVERS
CORRECTLY AS EMPLOYEES.
US AS TAXPAYERS LAST YEAR WE WE
SUPPLEMENTED EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT FOR INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS THAT MEANS THAT
FATHER FOR IS GOING TO GET A TAX
CREDIT.
PAID BY TAXPAYERS [inaudible]
WELL LET'S.
YOU KNOW CELEBRATES THEIR THEIR
HUGE GAINS A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
GETTING RICH AND IT'S NOT THE
WORKERS IN ITS APLIKASI OF THE
TAXPAYERS IT'S TIME TO LEVEL THE
PLAYING FIELD.
IT'S TIME TO BE HONEST WITH
WORKERS IT'S TIME TO BE HONEST
I'M WITH COMPANIES AND LET US
WORK ON THE SAME.
IDEAS TOGETHER IN UNDERSTAND
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE SO
I THANK YOU FOR LETTING.
ME SAY THAT I KNOW THAT WAS OFF
SCRIPT BUT OKAY.
THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY APPS
FOR NINE THANK YOU YOU HAVE A
MOTION TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
UNLESS AMERICA REAL SECOND BY
SUMMER EVERY BUS.
HAS ACCURATE CALL THE ROLL.
THE PAST TWO APPROPRIATIONS
KALRA AYE KALRA AYE FLORA.
LARA NOT VOTING CARILLO.
CARILLO I DEEP.
GONZALEZ HI AND SALAS I JONES
SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER A THREE OF US.
THREE OF US I A BILLS OUT BUT
THAT DOES UP THANK YOU.
AND SO WE WE HAVE A WE HAVE A
SENSITIVE.
WITNESSES WERE GONNA ASK IF WE
GOT AYE GREGORY IT'S IT IS A
BILL WITH NO OPPOSITION.
AND I BELIEVE THE SUBSEQUENT
AUTHOR HAS SOMETIMES LIMITATIONS
OF WE CAN [inaudible]
YEAH.
OKAY SO AB -- TWELVE TWENTY
THREE SEPTEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY.
THERE IS A AND I RECOMMEND
STATION DO PASSED TO INSURANCE
ANIMAL WHENEVER YOU'RE READY TO
BEGIN GREAT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN THE BILL -- UNDER
CURRENT LAW LIVING ORGAN DONORS
ARE ALLOWED UP TO THIRTY DAYS OF
PAID LEAVE AFTER SURGERY YOU'RE
FULLY RECOVER.
AB TWO TWELVE TWENTY THREE WOULD
ALLOW EMPLOYEES TO TAKE AN
ADDITIONAL UNPAID LEAVE OF UP TO
THIRTY BUSINESS DAYS FOR THE
PURPOSE OF ORGAN DONATION ONCE
ALL AVAILABLE.
SIX LEAVE HAS BEEN EXHAUSTED.
I HAVE WITH ME TODAY -- MY
WITNESSES -- MELANIE CON
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
FOR THE AMERICAN KIDNEY FUND AND
DARIUS BROWN A LIVING DONOR
KIDNEY RECIPIENT THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
CHAIRMAN KALRA CHAIRMAN VICE
CHAIRMAN FLOOR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY AND AB
TWELVE TWENTY THREE TODAY A BILL
THAT WOULD PROHIBIT INSURANCE
DISCRIMINATION.
BASED ON A PERSON'S STATUS AS A
LIVING ORGAN DONOR AND THAT
WOULD ENSURE ACCESS TO JOB
PROTECTED LEAVE FOR ORGAN
DONATION.
MY NAME IS MELANIE CON I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF STATE AFFAIRS FOR
THE AMERICAN CAN BE FUN WERE
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION BASED IN
ROCKVILLE MARYLAND THAT FOR
NEARLY FIFTY YEARS HAS HELP
PEOPLE FIGHT KIDNEY DISEASE.
KIDNEY TRANSPLANT ACTS AS A
LITERAL LIFELINE FOR PATIENTS
SUFFERING FROM KIDNEY FAILURE.
OFFERING THE CHANCE FOR A LONGER
AND HEALTHIER LIFE.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY THE SEVERE
SHORTAGE OF AVAILABLE ORGANS
FROM DECEASED DONORS IN THE
UNITED STATES MEANS THAT MORE
THAN NINETEEN THOUSAND
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS MUST WAIT
FOR SOMEONE TO DIE.
IN ORDER TO GET A KIDNEY UNLESS
THEY CAN FIND A LIVING ORGAN
DONOR.
UNFORTUNATELY STUDIES HAVE SHOWN
THAT PEOPLE WHO DONATE ORGANS
EXPERIENCE DISCRIMINATION BY
INSURANCE COMPANIES SOLELY BASED
ON THEIR STATUS AS AN ORGAN
DONOR.
SO FOR EXAMPLE IN AND I. H.
STUDY DEMONSTRATED THAT A HIGH
PROPORTION OF KIDNEY DONORS HAD
DIFFICULTY CHANGING OR
INITIATING INSURANCE.
PARTICULARLY LIFE INSURANCE THAT
STUDY CONCLUDED AND I'M QUOTING
DIRECTLY FROM THE STUDY NOW
THESE PRACTICES BY INSURERS
CREATE UNNECESSARY BURDENS AND
STRESS FOR THE CHEAP THOSE
CHOOSING TO DONATE.
AND COULD NEGATIVELY IMPACT THE
LIKELIHOOD OF LIVE KIDNEY
DONATION AMONG THOSE CONSIDERING
TOWARD DONATION.
FURTHER EXTENSIVE RESEARCH FROM
JOHNS HOPKINS HAS DEMONSTRATED
THAT PEOPLE WHO DONATE A KIDNEY
ARE JUST AS LIKELY TO LIVE JUST
AS LONG AND LEAD JUSTICE HEALTHY
HEALTHY LIVES AS PEOPLE WHO HAVE
BOTH OF THEIR ORGANS.
WE BELIEVE THAT PROHIBITING
INSURANCE DISCRIMINATION AGAINST
ORGAN DONORS.
AND GUARANTEEING JOB SECURITY
WHEN THEY TAKE TIME OFF TO
RECOVER FROM ORGAN DONATION
SURGERY ARE NOT ONLY SENSIBLE
PROTECTIONS BURKE FRANKLY JUST
GOOD POLICY.
AND FOR ALL OF THESE REASONS WE
INCUR THE PASSAGE OF THIS
LEGISLATION THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK WITH
YOU ALL TODAY THANK YOU. TO THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY ON AB.
TWELVE TWENTY THREE THE BILL THE
PROTECTED LIVING ORGAN DONORS
FROM INSURANCE DISCRIMINATION
AND ALLOW THEM TO TAKE
ADDITIONAL TIME OFF FROM WORK TO
RECOVER FROM DONATION SURGERY.
MY NAME IS DARIUS BROWN.
AND AS A CALIFORNIA RESIDENT IN
RECENT RECIPIENT OF A KIDNEY
FROM A LIVING DONOR I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS LEGISLATION.
MY JOURNEY WITH KIDNEY DISEASE
STARTED WHEN I WAS A SEVEN YEAR
OLD.
WHEN I WAS DIAGNOSED WITH THE
MARIJUANA FRIDAYS?
THAT DIAGNOSIS EVENTUALLY
DEVELOPED INTO FOCAL SEGMENTAL
AMEREN OF FRIDAY'S BY THE TIME I
WAS IN MY EARLY THIRTIES WHICH
REQUIRED ME TO GO ON DIALYSIS.
I DI LIES THAT NIGHT FOR ABOUT
EIGHT HOURS IN EIGHT FOR EIGHT
YEARS.
WHICH ALLOWED ME TO CONTINUE
WORKING FORTY HOURS A WEEK AT MY
JOB AS A SERVICE TECHNICIAN
I CONSIDER MYSELF LUCKY BECAUSE
I CONTINUE WORKING WHILE ON
DIALYSIS BUT IT WAS A DAILY
CHALLENGE.
DIALYSIS TREATMENTS ALONE IS IT.
IS A PHYSICALLY EXHAUSTING IN
FULL TIME COMMITMENT AND MANY
PEOPLE WITH KIDNEY DISEASE ARE
UNABLE TO CONTINUE WORKING.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN MY WIFE AND
I HOSTED A SMALL NEW YEAR'S EVE
DINNER AT OUR HOME AND A FAMILY
FRIEND OF OURS CONFIDED TO MY
WIFE THAT SHE WANTED TO HELP ME.
FIGHT WITH KIDNEY DISEASE HE
OFFERED TO GET TESTED. TO SEE IF
SHE WAS A DONOR MATCH AND SHE
WAS ON NOVEMBER SECOND TWENTY
EIGHTEEN I RECEIVED MY KIDNEY
TRANSPLANT.
AND MY LIFE HAS BEEN CHANGED FOR
THE BETTER.
I NO LONGER HAVE TO DIE ALLIES
WHICH MEANS I HAVE THE GIFT OF
TIME IN FACT I'M STILL GETTING
USED TO HAVING THAT TIME BACK.
WHICH IS A GOOD THING TO DO IT.
I HAVE MORE TIME TO DO THINGS
WITH MY FAMILY AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO TRAVELING MORE NO
LONGER BEING ON DIALYSIS ALSO
MEANS FEWER DIETARY ESTRICTIONS.
AND WHILE I MANY THIS MAY SEEM
TRIVIAL. ONE OF THE BEST THINGS
I EVER DID AFTER MY SURGERY WAS.
I WAS ABLE.
TO EAT A BOWL OF CEREAL WITH
REAL MILK WHICH IS SOMETHING I
WASN'T ABLE TO DO BEFORE.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT I TAKEN
YOU KNOW MANY TAKE FOR GRANTED.
THE FRIEND WHO DONATED THE
KIDNEY TO ME GAVE ME A CHANCE
FOR A BETTER LIFE SHE AND OTHER
LIVING DONORS.
ARE GENEROUS PEOPLE WHO
SELFLESSLY CHOOSE TO HELP
SOMEONE IN NEED.
AB TWELVE TWENTY THREE WOULD
PROVIDE COMMONSENSE PROTECTIONS
FOR THEM AND HOPEFULLY ENCOURAGE
OTHERS TO ALSO BECOME LIVING
DONORS THE CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY
SHOULD PASS THIS BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER I'M
SO HAPPY TO HEAR.
I'M SO HAPPY TO HEAR A STORY IN
PLEASE THANK THANK YOUR YOUR
FRIEND AS WELL.
I WILL.
THEY WOULD ALSO SUPPORT.
MR TURN MEMBERS MEDICINE DAHLIA
BEHALF DONATE LIFE CALIFORNIA
AND SUPPORT.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS NEARLY PETRONE
WITH MAKE YOU CAPTAIN ASSOCIATES
ON BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA LIFE AND HEALTH
INSURANCE COMPANIES -- WE
APPRECIATE THE ARE AUTHORS WORK
ON THIS MEASURE IN WITH THE
COMMITMENT OF AMENDMENTS WILL BE
THE SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
CAN L<c.cyan>G ON BEHALF THE</c>
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT WELL WE WILL BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE WE DO HAVE A
MOTION FOR THE COMMON.
ANY CLOSING THOUGHTS SUMMER
AGUIAR-CURRY -- I RESPECTFULLY
US RIVAL BUT I I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THIS IS IMPORTANT.
AND FOR SOMEBODY TO DONATE TO
SOMEBODY AND AS WE'VE SEEN HERE
TECH.
WHO'S THE THINK THAT A A BOWL OF
CEREAL READ THAT IMPORTANT. TO
BE ABLE TO GET A CAR AND GO
VISIT WITH HIS FAMILY PLACES
THAT HE GETS TO HAVE A NEW LIFE
THERE'S SO MANY OTHER PEOPLE
THAT DESERVE THE SAME QUALITY OF
LIFE AND SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY.
AND I'M HONORED TO HAVE MISTER
BROWN HERE WITH THIS AS WELL
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER ABOUT
THIS WONDERFUL BILL -- DOES HAVE --
A TO PASS TO INSURANCE COMMITTEE
RECOMMENDATION.
WITH THE THE MOTION FROM SUMMER
CREEL SECOND BY VICE CHAIR FLORA
[inaudible]
THE POLITICAL.
THE PAST TWO INSURANCE COMMITTEE
KALRA AYE KALRA AYE FLORA AYE
FLORA AYE.
CARILLO I SEE.
GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ I AM JONES
SAWYER FIVE JONES SAWYER AYE
THREE OF US.
THREE OF US I SOME BILLS OUT
THANK YOU RIGHT THANK YOU.
CERVANTES THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE I REALLY APPRECIATED.
SB.
SIX TWENTY EIGHT ALL RIGHT A. B.
SIX TWENTY EIGHT DOES HAVE A
RECOMMENDATION TO PASSAGE ASSURE
A SUMMER BONTA PLEASE MY CAN
RESULT.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES THIS IS A BILL
THAT ADDS SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
TO A OTHER SET OF CATEGORIES
THAT ALREADY RECEIVE PROTECTION --
FOR PROTECTED LEAVE AND WE THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT NOW MORE THAN
EVER TO STEP UP AND AND PROTECT
OUR SURVIVORS OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT JUST TO BE CLEAR DOES
NOT CREATE ADDITIONAL PAID TIME
OFF IT JUST SAYS THAT SEXUAL
HARASSMENT SURVIVORS IMMEDIATE
FAMILY MEMBERS.
CAN CLAIM PAID TIME OFF ALREADY
OFFERED TO THEM BY THEIR
EMPLOYERS OR TAKE ON PAGE ARE
PROTECTED TIME.
OTHER ALSO IMPORTANT -- EMPLOYER
SAFEGUARD THE VERIFICATIONS IN
THE BELL.
SHAPED YOUR CONSIDERATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON A. B. SIX TWENTY EIGHT I HAVE
WITH ME CATHERINE WHAT YET AN
ATTORNEY AT LEGAL AID AT WORK A
SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND KRISTA.
NINES SICK THE AT THE PUBLIC
POLICY AT THE PUBLIC POLICY
COORDINATOR AT CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIP TO AND DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE ANOTHER SUPPORTER OF
THE BILL MAILED IT.
GOOD AFTERNOON QUEST ITEMS LIKE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP
TEN DOMESTIC VIOLENCE -- HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BELL OF US THOSE
STATEWIDE ORGANIZATION WE WORK
WITH ORGANIZATION SERVING THE
SURVIVORS ALL ACROSS THE STATE.
AND HERE EVERY DAY ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF THAT THEIR ABILITY
TO MAINTAIN THEIR EMPLOYMENT.
AND ALSO OF THE IMPORTANCE OF
SUPPORT PEOPLE AND THEIR LIVES
IN PARTICULAR IN THE ABILITY FOR
FAMILY MEMBERS TO ACCOMPANY THEM
TO COURT HEARING THIS TO MEDICAL
APPOINTMENTS TO MEET WITH THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY OR WHATEVER
THE CASE MAY BE -- AND BY
EXTENDING THE PROTECTIONS THAT
ALREADY EXIST FOR SURVIVORS TO
BE ABLE TO TAKE TIME OFF WITHOUT --
IF YOU'RE OF TERMINATION OR
RETALIATION AND TO THE FAMILY
MEMBERS OF THOSE SURVIVORS WERE
ABLE TO MAKE SURE THAT SURVIVORS
HAVE BETTER OUTCOMES ARE BETTER
APRIL TO HEAL FROM THE TRAUMA SO.
WE'RE PLEASED TO SUPPORT THE
BILL REALLY APPRECIATE THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI -- I'M CATHERINE WHICH IT
FROM LEGAL AID AT WORK AND WE'RE
AN ORGANIZATION THAT ADVOCATES
ON BEHALF OF LOW WAGE WORKERS.
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW SURVIVORS
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SEXUAL
ASSAULT SEX HARASSMENT AND
STALKING TO SEEK THE HELP THAT
THEY NEED WHEN THEY NEED IT
WITHOUT RISKING LOSING THEIR
JOBS -- AT LEGALLY TO WORK WE
HAVE A HELP LINE WHERE PEOPLE
WHO EXPERIENCE SEX HARASSMENT AT
WORK CALL US IN AND TELL US
WHAT'S GOING ON AND SEEK HELP --
IN JUST THE OTHER DAY WE HEARD
FROM SOMEONE WHO WORKED IN A
SMALL CHAIN RESTAURANT.
WHERE SHE WAS BEING HARASSED BY
HER COWORKER SHE FOUND THE
COURAGE SHE REPORTED IT TO HER
EMPLOYER AND THE EMPLOYER TOLD
THE COWORKER OKAY YOU KNOW STOP
DOING THAT?
BUT THE NEXT DAY SHE WAS STILL
REQUIRED TO COME INTO WORK AND
BE IN THAT SAME SMALL SPACE WITH
THE PERSON WHO HAD BEEN
HARASSING HER.
THIS BILL WOULD HAVE GIVEN HER
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE TIME OFF
WORK TO SEEK THE THERAPY THAT
SHE NEEDED TO BE ABLE TO RECOVER
AND TO CONTINUE WORK -- THIS IS
AN IMPORTANT BILL FOR SURVIVORS
AND WE STRONGLY URGE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT.
VERY GOOD -- SHE HIGH WITH THE
CALIFORNIANS LIMIT LAWYERS'
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
.
GOOD AFTERNOON MORE CURTIS HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TESTIFIED TODAY I DO WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF
FOR THE TIME THAT THEY HAVE
TAKEN THE WITH US SO FAR -- OVER
THE LAST TWO YEARS ON THIS BILL --
THE AUTHOR THIS -- INTRODUCED
THIS BILL LAST YEAR AS WELL --
AND OBVIOUSLY WALL CAL CHAMBER
AND ALL THE BUSINESS COMMUNITIES
ARE ALL THE BUSINESS ENTITIES
THAT HAVE SIGNED ON IN
OPPOSITION THIS BILL.
ARE FULLY IN SUPPORT OF
ELIMINATING HARASSMENT IN THE
WORKPLACE WE HAVE A LOT OF
CONCERNS WITH THIS BILL.
GIVEN FIRST OF ALL THAT IT
CREATES AN INCONSISTENT
DEFINITION OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT
IN THE WORKPLACE -- THE
AMENDMENTS TO THIS BILL ARE
AMENDING THE SAME LABOR CODE
PROVISION THAT DISCUSSES HER
SEXUAL HARASSMENT OR SEXUAL
ASSAULT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND
STALKING HOWEVER.
SEXUAL HARASSMENT OCCURS OFTEN
TIME IN THE WORKPLACE -- AND IT
IS NOT SOMETHING THAT IS
DETERMINED BY THE POLICE IT'S
NOT SOMETHING THAT IS DETERMINED.
BY THE CRIMINAL DEPARTMENT IT IS
DETERMINED BY AN INVESTIGATION
DONE BY THE EMPLOYER IT'S
DETERMINED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
FAIR EMPLOYMENT HOUSING OR TO
TERMS AND QUIRK WHETHER SEXUAL
HARASSMENT RISES TO THE LEVEL OF
UNLAWFUL BEHAVIOR.
BECAUSE WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT
THERE ARE A LOT OF BEHAVIOR THAT
CAN BE INAPPROPRIATE ANY SORT OF
HARASSMENT IS OBVIOUSLY --
SHOULD NOT BE TOLERATED HOWEVER
IT'S NOT ALWAYS UNLAWFUL AND
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS IT SIMPLY
PULLS PARTS OF EXAMPLES OF WHAT
COULD RISE TO THE LEVEL SEXUAL
HARASSMENT.
BUT DOES NOT REQUIRE THAT THEY
ACTUALLY WRITES THE SEVERE OR
PERVASIVE STANDARD EXAMPLE
SHOWING SOMEONE A CARTOON OR
LEERING IS INAPPROPRIATE
BEHAVIOR BUT THAT DOESN'T
ACTUALLY MEAN THAT IT'S UNLAWFUL
BEHAVIOR THAT RISES TO THE LEVEL
OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT IT CAN.
BUT DOESN'T NECESSARILY MEAN
THAT IT DOES THIS BILL WOULD
ALLOW HIM AN INDIVIDUAL TO TAKE
LEAVE FROM WORK FOR SOMETHING AS
SIMPLE AS BEING CáC CALLED ON
THEIR WAY TO WORK GOING INTO THE
EMPLOYER SAYING.
I'M GOING TO TAKE NEXT WEEK OFF
BECAUSE I FEEL LIKE I NEED AN
EXTENDED AMOUNT OF TIME OF LEAVE
BECAUSE THERE IS NO REQUIREMENT
THAT THERE BE ANY VERIFICATION
BY ANYONE AS LONG AS YOU ARE
GIVING PRIOR NOTIFICATION TO
YOUR EMPLOYER.
YOU GET PRIOR NOTIFICATION
YOU'RE ALLOWED TO TAKE AN
UNLIMITED AMOUNT OF TIME OFF
ADDITIONALLY ALLOWS FOR FAMILY
MEMBERS TO TAKE AN UNLIMITED
AMOUNT OF TIME OFF AS WELL.
AND THE FAMILY MEMBERS MAY TAKE
THIS LEAVE FOR THE SAME REASON
AS YOU ALLEGE THAT YOU WERE
SEXUALLY HARASSED WITHOUT ANY
SORT OF VERIFICATION.
THE DEFINITION OF FAMILY MEMBERS
EXTREMELY BROAD AND GIVEN THE
WAY THAT THE BILL AS CURRENTLY
WRITTEN IT BY EXAMPLE WOULD
ALLOW ME TO TELL MY BROTHER WHO
MIGHT LIVE IN SAN DIEGO.
THAT IKE'S THE I SUFFERED SEXUAL
HARASSMENT I WANT YOU TO TAKE
TIME OFF WORK AS WELL AND ALLOW
HIM TO TAKE AN UNLIMITED AMOUNT
OF THE FOR SOMETHING AS MINOR.
AS A CAT CALL AND THEN FOR I
UNDERSTAND THAT THAT'S NOT THE
INTENT OF THE AUTHOR HOWEVER
THAT'S THE WAY THAT THE BILL'S
CURRENT DRAFTED AND THAT'S OUR
CONCERN SEXUAL HARASSMENT IS
JUST SO DIFFERENT AGAIN IT'S
REGULATED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
FAIR EMPLOYMENT HOUSING.
THIS NOW PLACES IT INTO THE
LABOR CODE AND WE HAVE A LOT OF
CONCERNS WITH THAT ISSUE
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE FACT THAT
THERE IS AN ADMINISTRATIVE
REMEDY WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FAIR EMPLOYMENT HOUSING.
WHO HELPED TO WEED OUT CLAIMS
THAT ARE FRIVOLOUS AND THERE
WOULD BE NO SUCH DEPARTMENT
DOING THAT AS FAR AS
ADMINISTRATIVE REMEDY?
AND OUR CONCERNS ARE JUST THE
OVERALL ABUSE BECAUSE THERE'S NO
WAY TO VERIFY OR ALLOW ANYONE TO
TELL THEM THAT THEY CAN'T TAKE
IT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
BECAUSE WE TOOK THE GAVEL MR
HERE WELL I TOOK ABOUT -- I ALSO
WANT TO THINK A ASSEMBLYMEMBER
ON TENNIS STAFFORD DISCUSSIONS
ON THIS BILL AS WELL AS LAST
YEAR'S IN JUST A FOLLOW UP WITH
MISS CURTIS'S COMMENTS WE HAVE
SUGGESTED SOME POTENTIAL.
AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THE CONCERNS REYES FOR EXAMPLE
RATHER THAN THE BROAD DEFINITION
OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT CONTAINED
IN THE TWO PROVISIONS OF THIS
BILL AND AND PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
TO TWO THIRTY AND TWO THIRTY
POINT.
ONE IS FOR EXAMPLE TO UTILIZE
THE HARASSMENT DEFINITION OUT OF
FEE ON THE GOVERNMENT CODE.
IN.
ONE TWO NINE FOUR ZERO I ALSO --
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE LANGUAGE
ABOUT PROVIDING CERTIFICATION TO
THE EMPLOYER. FOR THE FOR ACTS
RELATED TO SEXUAL HARASSMENT AS
WELL.
ANOTHER ITEM IS IS THAT IN.
SUB DIVISION E..
THREE IT TALKS ABOUT THE
EMPLOYER MAINTAINING
CONFIDENTIALITY OF EMPLOYEES
REQUESTING LEAVE.
OUR CONCERN THERE IS IS THAT
WE'RE FACED WITH THE SITUATION
UNDER FEE HOT.
THAT WERE THERE ARE HARASSMENT
CLAIMS THAT WE HAVE TO CONDUCT
AN INVESTIGATION.
INTERVIEW EMPLOYEES DO OUR DUE
DILIGENCE THERE'S A TENSION
THERE BETWEEN.
THE PROVISIONS HERE OF
MAINTAINING CONFIDENTIALITY AND
FIAT DEMANDING INVESTIGATION.
ALSO WITH THESE ADDITIONAL
PROVISIONS OF THE LABOR CODE
WERE CONCERNED THAT INSTEAD OF
BEING THE CURRENT STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS OF SIX MONTHS
CURRENTLY UNDER FREE HOT.
THAT IT COULD TURN INTO THREE TO
FOUR YEARS NOW THAT THESE WOULD
BE ADDED TO THE LABOR CODE.
AND IN ADDITION OF COURSE AS WE
ALWAYS LIKE TO POINT OUT ARE
CONCERNED WITH.
ANY ADDITIONAL -- CLAIMS UNDER
THE LABOR CODE SUBJECT EMPLOYERS
TO ACTIONS UNDER THE PRIVATE
ATTORNEYS GENERAL ACT SO WITH
THAT WE REMAIN OPPOSED BUT WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHORED A STAFF.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS NICOLE RICE
CALIFORNIA MANY FACTORS IN
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION I DON'T
KNOW IF THERE'S ANY MORE MINUTES
LEFT IN THAT. SIX MINUTE LIMIT
AB FORTY FIVE SECONDS OKAY SO I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO POINT OUT
THAT FOR THE MANUFACTURERS ARE
CONCERNED ARE THOSE THAT HAVE
BEEN EXPRESSED BY THE OPPOSITION
THIS FAR.
BUT MAINLY FOR US THAT THE NO
LIMIT ON THE DURATION OR THE
FREQUENCY OF THE LEAVE IS
GREATLY CONCERNING FOR INDUSTRY
BECAUSE WHEN WE HAVE PEOPLE GONE
OUT ON LEAVE WE ACTUALLY HAVE TO
SHUT DOWN PROCESS SEES.
SO NOT KNOWING WHEN PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO COME OUT AND HELP.
GOING TO COME BACK AND HOW MANY
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO BE OUT HOW
LONG THEY'RE GOING TO BE OUT.
IS VERY CONCERNING FOR US SO WE
HOPE TO BE ABLE TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION WITH THE AUTHOR
HOWEVER INDUSTRY -- CONCERNS
ADDRESSED BUT FOR NOW WE REMAIN
OPPOSED ALONG AS I SAID BEFORE
WITH THE OTHER ARGUMENTS THAT
HAVE BEEN RAISED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON KATIE HANSON WITH
THE CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION PROPOSED TO THE BILL
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHEN MEMBERS
MATTHEW ALLEN WITH WESTERN
GROWERS ARE ALSO OPPOSED THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON BROWN LITTLE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU ALSO IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
JOSH DUGGAR REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES AND COLLEAGUES AT THE
JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY OPPOSED.
THANK YOU.
OKAY A BACK TO COMMITTEE -- IS
ANY FURTHER COMMENT.
I'LL JUST I'LL JUST SAY THAT THE
THAT I THINK THAT.
SOME OF THE CONCERNS A WARRANT I
KNOW THAT IT'S BEEN MENTIONED
THE STAFF NOW SO THERE IS A NEED
FOR GREATER CLARITY.
AGAIN BEING THE LABOR EMPLOYMENT
COMMITTEE IS THIS A WORTHY
ENDEAVOR YES.
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE I THINK IS
AN APPROPRIATE PLACE WHERE WE
NEED TO REALLY FIND TO SOME OF
THESE DEFINITIONS AND
CERTIFICATION PROCESS AYE THAT'S
OF THE AUTHOR -- HAS COMMITTED
TO DOING -- IN TERMS OF THE
DOING THAT FOR THEIR WORK AND SO
I'M I'M CONFIDENT THAT HE'LL BE
ABLE TO DO THAT AND WORK WITH
OPPOSITION.
AS WELL AS WITH THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE STAFF -- TO ENSURE
THAT HAPPENS I'LL JUST MAKE ONE
COMMENT THOUGH.
YOU KNOW THIS IS FOR UNPAID TIME
OFF -- FOR VICTIMS OF THOSE ARE
SUPPORTING VICTIMS AND I THINK.
WE WE I THINK WE HAVE A
RECOGNITION BUT WE CERTAINLY
HAVE NOT DONE ENOUGH.
OVER MANY DECADES.
THAT WERE FINALLY STARTING TO
RECOGNIZE WE DO MORE TO PROTECT
VICTIMS [inaudible]
AND THE SUGGESTION THAT FOLKS
ARE GOING.
TO YOU KNOW THAT THEIR THEIR
THOUGHTS COLLIDED FORGET CAT
CALL TO TAKE TIME OFF I'VE NOT
HEARD.
OF THIS IS A DISRESPECT TO THE
WORKER.
AT THAT THOSE THE WORKERS THAT
EUROPE HIRING AND THAT'S WHAT
YOU THINK OF THEM THAT I I I I I
JUST DON'T BUY IT.
I I THINK THAT FOLKS ARE GOING
TO CERTAINLY PERSONALLY TO HAVE
TO KEEP AN EYE ON HOW SOMETHING
LIKE THIS LIKE ANYTHING ELSE IS
USED IF IT'S ABUSED THEN WE
CERTAINLY.
HAVE TO TAKE SUCH GOOD ACTION TO
ENSURE THERE IS AN ABUSE BUT I
HOPE AND BELIEVE THAT SUBSEQUENT.
AMENDMENTS WILL HELP TO FINE
TUNE IT HELP CLARIFY I DO
BELIEVE THAT EMPLOYERS NEED MORE
CLARIFICATION -- AS WITH THE
LEGISLATURE IN SO I LOOK FORWARD
TO THOSE AMENDMENTS GOING
FORWARD.
I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE THIS --
BONTA THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR COMMENTS
YOU KNOW WHAT WE ARE COMMITTED
TO MAKING SURE DOES AN ADEQUATE
VERIFICATION PROCESS WE WE'VE --
WE HAVE. ONE IN THE BILL NOW AND
IF THE IF THERE ARE AREAS WHERE
WE CAN FROM IT UP INCLUDING
CLEAR FIGHT WERE HAPPY TO WE
ALSO HAVE.
A REFERENCE -- TO THE FMLA
AROUND THAT THAT THE TIME
RESTRICTIONS AND AND IT IT IS SO
IT'S NOT DOESN'T CLEARLY STATED
ON ITS FACE IN THE BILL BUT IT
REFERS THE FMLA WHICH HAS A
TWELVE WEEK.
LIMIT ON ON HOW MUCH PAID LEAVE
CAN BE TAKEN SO TO SAY THE
SUGGEST THAT IT'S UNLIMITED IT'S
JUST NOT ACCURATE AND IF WE NEED
TO BE CLEAR ABOUT THAT IN THE
FUTURE AS BE ABOUT THE BILL
GOIN FORWARD -- WE WE CAN DO
THAT.
I ALSO THINK THE PUT THIS IN A
PARADE OF HORRIBLE IS ABOUT HOW
ALL OF THE WORKERS ARE GONNA
ABUSE THIS IS JUST NOT WARRANTED.
WE TO WE LIKE EVIDENCE BASED TO
DATA BASED ARGUMENTS IN IN THIS.
BUILDING AND WE HAVE HAD ALREADY
HAVE THIS BILL OF THIS LAW FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS AS IT RELATES TO
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND SEXUAL
ASSAULT AND STALKING AND I
HAVEN'T HEARD ANY EXAMPLES OF OF
THAT TYPE OF ABUSE IT'S IT'S
IT'S AN ONES.
IT YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S BEEN
IMAGINED TO AS AN AS AN ARGUMENT
AS A FOIL FOR THIS BILL BUT IT'S
NOT ACTUALLY ACTUALLY HAPPENING.
SO -- AS ALWAYS WERE WILLING TO
WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION TO TRY
TO ADDRESS ISSUES PROVIDE MORE
CLARITY FROM THINGS UP.
WITH A FOR DOING THAT THE FUTURE
FOR ABLE TO GET OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT TODAY.
THANK YOU ARE THE MOTION TO DO
PASSENGER SHERRY BYE SUMMARY
CARILLO SECONDED BY SUMMER JONES
SAWYER A MADAM SECTOR PLEASE
TAKE WILL.
DO PASSED TO JUDICIARY KALRA AYE
KALRA AYE FLORA.
FLORA NOT VOTING CARILLO.
CREEL I DEEP GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER I THREE OF US.
THREE OF US I OKAY THE BILLS OUT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES THINK STAFF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GONZALEZ WOULD
LIKE TO PRESENT A SUMMARY
MENTIONS BILL.
I ACTUALLY -- ACTUALLY SOME OF
HIS LOST ME PAUSE ON THAT FOR
ONE MOMENT ALLOW SOMEONE IS
THERE IN 2%.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT.
ALL UP IN THE HOME.
BUT THANK YOU FOR YOUR THANK YOU
FOR PAYS OR SOMETHING IS THERE
AND I KNOW YOU WERE HERE EARLIER
WE HAD THIS IDEA CURRY WHO.
SIGNED IT UP TO YOU BUT SHE HAD
A SENSE OF WITNESS SO THANK YOU
NO NO PROBLEM THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AB SIX FORTY EIGHT WOULD
EXPAND CONSUMER PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS AROUND WELLNESS
PROGRAMS BY DOING THE FOLLOWING
ONE ESTABLISHING CLEAR
REQUIREMENTS ON FARE COLLECTION
AND USE OF PERSONAL INFORMATION.
TO PROHIBITING AN INTENTIONAL
DISCRIMINATION AND WELLNESS
PROGRAMS. THREE REQUIRING
TRANSPARENCY AND WELLNESS
PROGRAMS INCLUDING DATA USAGE
GENERALLY RIGHTS UNDER STATE AND
FEDERAL LAW AND FOR GRANTING
WELLNESS PROGRAM ENROLLEES.
THE RIGHT TO REVIEW AND CORRECT
THE COMPLETENESS AND ACCURACY OF
RECORDS ABOUT THEM.
WELLNESS PROGRAMS ARE PROMOTED
AS A WAY TO SUPPORT HEALTHY
BEHAVIORS AND IMPROVE HEALTH
OUTCOMES FOR PATIENTS FOR
PARTICIPANTS HOWEVER MANY COME
WITH UNSPOKEN TRADE OFFS THEY
REQUIRE PARTICIPANTS TO GIVE UP
THEIR PERSONAL DATA.
INCLUDING SENSITIVE PERSONAL
HEALTH INFORMATION IN EXCHANGE
FOR UNSUPPORTED PROMISES OF
WELLNESS AND IN SOME CASES. TO
WIN REWARDS THIS UNSPOKEN TRADE
OFF THREATENS ENROLLEES PRIVACY
AND CREATES THE POTENTIAL FOR
DISCRIMINATION MANY WELLNESS
PROGRAMS WILL REQUIRE
PARTICIPANTS TO WEAR A MOBILE
DEVICE SUCH AS A FITBIT -- WITH
ME IN SUPPORT I'M GONNA CUT THIS
SHORT BECAUSE I THINK THIS DOES
ENJOY A SUPPORT SO I'M GONNA CUT
THIS SHORT THE END AND
INTRODUCED A THANK YOU.
DANA MENDELSSOHN A DINO
MENDELSON FROM CONSUMER REPORTS
AS WELL AS TAYLOR JACKSON FROM
THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION WHO IF SHE IS STILL
HERE AND SHE IS.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN KALRA
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS TINA MENDELSSOHN I AM A
SENIOR POLICY COUNSEL FOR
CONSUMER PART.
PRAGUE BONSOR THIS BILL.
HOW CARE COMPLICATED AND SORE ON
THE PROGRAM?
BECAUSE OF A VARIETY OF TYPES
AND ALL OF THE OPERATORS OF ON
THE PROGRAM THE APPLICATION
PRIVACY LAWS THIS BODY AND
INCONSISTENT.
RENDERING THEM INADEQUATE.
WE ARE PROUD TO SPONSOR A BILL
WHICH WOULD CREATE A BASELINE OF
TRUST IN FAIRNESS FOR ALL OF THE
PROGRAM BASED ON TWO PILLARS.
COMMONSENSE PRIVACY PROTECTIONS
AND FULL TRANSPARENCY.
CONSUMERS HAVE REASON TO BE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE COLLECTION
AND USE OF DATA IMAN THIS
PROGRAM THE PROGRAM THAT
PERSONAL QUESTION SO DID MEDICAL
HISTORY REPORTER STRESS
INCLUDING PROBLEMS AT WORK.
OR SEPARATION DIVORCE PLAN TO
BECOME PREGNANT BODY MASS INDEX
AND EATING AND EXERCISE HABITS.
THIS INFORMATION IS VERY
PERSONAL WITH REAL WORLD IMPACT
FOR PROGRAM PART THAT HAVE
NOTHING TO DO WITH IMPROVING
THEIR ONE THIS.
IN ADDITION MORE WEARABLE
DEVICES THERE'S PRIVATE PART OF
ON THE PROGRAM THE DATA
COLLECTED BY WEARABLE BLUNTED
PROGRAM TURNING IT INTO A TYPE
OF SURVEILLANCE.
THAT UNDULY INVASIVE AND GOES
BEYOND THE ORIGINAL PURPOSE FOR
WITH THE DATA WAS INTENDED. TO
PROMOTE INDIVIDUAL HEALTH.
BECAUSE THE CURRENT ABSOLUTE
PULLED THE PRIVACY LAWS THE DATA
COLLECTED BY ONE'S PROGRAM CAN
BE USED FOR PURPOSES UNRELATED
TO PROMOTING EMPLOYEE BOND THAT.
SUCH A SECONDARY USE AND SALE.
CONSUMERS WHEN ROLLING ON THE
PROGRAM DO SO TO IMPROVE THEIR
HEALTH NOT SO THEY CAN GET
TARGETED MARKETING.
HOW THEIR ABILITY TO GET
AFFORDABLE INSURANCE ALTERED OR
MAKE PERSONAL INFORMATION ABOUT
THEMSELVES NO TO THEIR EMPLOYERS?
POTENTIAL EMPLOYERS FOR LENDERS
THAT ACT OF BAD FAITH.
RIGHT NOW CALIFORNIANS WHO
CONSIDER ENROLLING IN OF ALL THE
PROGRAM OR WHO ARE ENROLLED IN A
WHILE THE PROGRAM.
OFTEN HAVE LITTLE WAY TO KNOW
THE EXTENT TWITTER DATA WILL BE
COLLECTED AND SHARED A VISION
NOT BEAR THE BURDEN TO OF
ENSURING THAT THEIR DATA IS NOT
MISUSED.
UNDER A BASIC FORTY EIGHT MOTHER
PROGRAM CAN STILL BE OFFERED AND
CONSUMER COUNTRY TO PARTICIPATE
IF THEY WANT. TO HAVE THEIR
PRIVACY PROTECTED WITHOUT
UNINTENTIONALLY OR INVOLUNTARILY
ENTERING INTO UNFAIR DEALS. FOR
THIS REASON CONSUMER REPORTS
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS TAYLOR
JACKSON OF THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION NURSES ARE PROUD TO
SUPPORT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MISSOURIANS BILL WHICH PROVIDES
IMPORTANT PROTECTIONS FOR
CALIFORNIA WORKERS.
SEE IN A REPRESENTS UNION
REGISTERED NURSES WHO ARE IN A
UNIQUE POSITION TO UNDERSTAND
THIS BILL AS WELL HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS IN WORKERS.
THE PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL ARE
JUST COMMON SENSE A WORKER
SHOULD NEVER BE REQUIRED TO
PARTICIPATE IN A WELLNESS
PROGRAM AS A CONDITION OF
EMPLOYMENT.
IT MAKES PERFECT SENSE THAT AB
SIX FORTY EIGHT WHAT OUTLINED
THAT PROTECTION AND ALSO ENSURE
WORKERS AREN'T RETALIATED
AGAINST IF THEY ELECT NOT TO
JOIN A WELLNESS PROGRAM.
NURSES KNOW THAT SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH LIMIT THE
SUCCESS OF WELLNESS PROGRAMS ARE
HEALTH IS DETERMINED IN PART BY
ACCESS TO SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES.
THE RESOURCES AND SUPPORTS
AVAILABLE IN OUR HOMES
NEIGHBORHOODS AND COMMUNITIES
THE QUALITY OF OUR SCHOOLING THE
SAFETY OF OUR WORKPLACES THE
CLEANLINESS OF OUR WATER FOOD IN
AIR.
AND THE NATURE OF OUR SOCIAL
INTERACTIONS AND RELATIONSHIPS.
THE CONDITIONS IN WHICH WE LIVE
EXPLAIN IN PART WHY WEALTHIER
AND WHITER COMMUNITIES ARE
HEALTHIER THAN BROWN BLACK AND
POOR COMMUNITIES.
IT IS UNLIKELY THAT A JANITOR
WHO WORKS NIGHTS IS GETTING
EIGHT HOURS OF SLEEP.
IT IS UNLIKELY THAT THE GIG
ECONOMY WORKER WHO HAS THREE
JOBS IS ABLE TO CONSISTENTLY
MAKE HEALTHY MEALS AT HOME.
IT IS UNLIKELY THAT A SURGICAL
NURSE IS ABLE TO GET OFF THEIR
FEET DURING A TWELVE HOUR SHIFT
AND RUST THEIR BACK.
REQUIRING WORKERS TO WHERE
FITBIT DOES NOT CHANGE ANY OF
THE REAL HEALTH ISSUES OUR
SOCIETY CAUSES.
AB SIX FORTY EIGHT PUTS
REASONABLE CONSTRAINTS IN THE
LAW TO PROTECT WORKERS AND
CONSUMERS WHILE STILL ALLOWING
WELLNESS PROGRAMS TO OPERATE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
OF AB SIX FORTY EIGHT THE NURSES
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
AFTERNOON CHEN FLOOR ON BEHALF
OF WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI AM JDS ON BEHALF OF HEALTH
ACCESS CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
VERY CLEAR SHE HARM TO HAVE A
CALIFORNIA PLUMMET LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JESSICA CENTER ON BEHALF OF
EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU [inaudible]
IN OPPOSITION [inaudible]
HELLO.
THERE IT IS AGAIN ON THE HAVE
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE -- WE ARE HERE AND
OPPOSITION OBVIOUSLY BECAUSE OUR
CONCERN IS IS THAT THIS A
DISINCENTIVE VICES EMPLOYERS WHO
WANT TO PROVIDE WELLNESS
PROGRAMS AND THE REASON BEING IS
THAT.
OBVIOUSLY WELLNESS PROGRAMS ARE
INTENDED SO BAD TO PROVIDE A
BENEFIT TO THE EMPLOYEE -- TO
PROVIDE MORE INCENTIVE FOR
EXERCISE FOR MOBILITY FOR ALL OF
THOSE REASONS HOWEVER.
THE DISINCENTIVE IS ATION FROM
THIS BILL COMES FROM THE FACT
THAT NOT ONLY IMPOSE A CIVIL
LIABILITY BUT ALSO CRIMINAL
LIABILITY FOR SOMETHING AS EASY
AS OR AS MINOR AS NOT PROVIDING.
THE CORRECT NOTIFICATION AN
EXPLANATION ABOUT THE WELLNESS
PLAN AND ADDITIONALLY IT
PROHIBITS EMPLOYERS FROM
RETALIATING OR TAKING ANY
ADVERSE EMPLOYMENT ACTION.
IN RESPONSE OR RELATED TO A
MATTER RELATED TO WELLNESS
PROGRAM AND FOR EXAMPLE LET'S
SAY THE INDIVIDUAL WAS HARASSING
SOMEONE THAT CAME IN TO PROVIDE
SOME SORT OF AN EDUCATION
REGARDING THE WELLNESS PROGRAM.
THE EMPLOYER WOULD HAVE NO
ABILITY TO TAKE ANY ADVERSE
EMPLOYMENT ACTION AGAINST THAT
EMPLOYEE BECAUSE IT'S RELATED TO
A MATTER REGARDING WELLNESS AND
THOSE CIVIL AND CRIMINAL
LIABILITY U. M. WOULD KICK IN.
ADDITIONALLY AT THE THE MANDATES
AND THREATS OF LIABILITY BOTH
CRIMINAL AND CIVIL WILL SIMPLY
ELIMINATE THE POTENTIAL FOR
ANYONE THIS PROGRAM BECAUSE BY
AN EMPLOYER TAKE THE RISK OF
EVEN PROVIDING WELLNESS PROGRAM
IF THAT'S THAT WHAT THEY'RE
FACING. ONE IS PROGRAM
INCENTIVIZE GOOD HEALTH AND
CONTRIBUTE TO A HEALTHY
WORKFORCE AT THIS TIME WHEN A
BEE STING CANCER ON THE RISE IN
HEALTHCARE COSTS ARE INCREASING
IN CALIFORNIA.
WE THINK THAT WE SHOULD BE
ENCOURAGING WELLNESS PROGRAMS
RATHER THAN DISINCENTIVE ISING
THEM IN THE WORK PLACE THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
THANK YOU.
BUT A NICKEL WITH US ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
HEALTH PLANS I THINK THE THE
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE CHAMBER
COVERED ALL THE SUBSTANTIVE
ISSUES -- WERE OPPOSED TO THE
BILL OUR CONCERN IS THAT WERE
LOADING THESE HELPFUL PROGRAMS
UP WITH.
ON A LEVEL OF RULES REGULATIONS
AND REQUIREMENTS THAT WOULD MAKE
THEM EFFECTIVE -- WE HAVE REACH
OUT TO THE AUTHORS OFFICE AND
YOU KNOW LOOK FORWARD SOME
MEETINGS.
WITH THE AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS
TO UNDERSTAND HOW CURRENT LAWS
AND SUFFICIENT IN THIS AREA.
AND TO LEARN ABOUT A REAL WORLD
EXAMPLES -- THAT WOULD YOU KNOW
BACK UP SOME HYPOTHETICALS I'VE
BEEN DISCUSSING THEIR TESTIMONY
SO AT THIS TIME WERE OPPOSED TO
THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
THE ONLY BE JOURNALISTIC YOU
CAPTAIN ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
LIFE AND HEALTH INSURANCE
COMPANIES ECHOING THE COMMENTS
MADE IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
OKAY.
BACK TO COMMITTEE.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION FROM THE
SUMMER GONZALEZ SECOND BY SUMMER
CARILLO ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
SUMMER IS VERY MUCH LIKE TO
CLOSE.
YEAH I'LL JUST BRIEFLY TOUCH ON
SOME OF THE COMMENTS THAT WERE
MADE IN THE OPPOSITION I'M HAPPY
TO WORK WITH THEM OBVIOUSLY
THERE'S A WORK IN PROGRESS --
I'M ASSUMING WHEN THE CRIMINAL
LIABILITY ISSUE WAS MENTIONED IT
WAS ABOUT THE MISDEMEANOR
POTENTIAL BUT I I DON'T WANT TO
MAKE ANY ASSUMPTIONS SO.
LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THEM UP WITH THAT I A I I DO
THAT THESE PRO I DO AGREE THAT
THESE PROGRAMS ARE WONDERFUL --
BUT IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT IT
SHOULD HAVE ANY LOOPHOLES TO BE
ABUSED SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE
THANK YOU KALRA.
AYE KALRA AYE FLORA.
FLORA NO CREEL.
REAL ID GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I AM JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER I THREE OF US.
THREE OF US THANK YOU THE BILL
IS OUT THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT AB ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR
MAIENSCHEIN.
AND WILL HAVE A SUMMER GONZALEZ
PRESENT ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN.
THAT COULD BE A QUESTION CAN ASK
THE PRESENTER.
YEAH THAT WON'T WORK EITHER
[inaudible] FOR ABOUT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
LETTING ME AS TESTIFY IN PLACE
OF MISTER MAIENSCHEIN WHO IS
USING ONE OF HIS THREE PAID SICK
DAYS TODAY.
I'M JUST YET WE DO HAVE SICK
DAYS YES -- NOT ENOUGH.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS AB ELEVEN
TWENTY FOUR IS AN IMPORTANT
MEASURE TO PROTET WORKERS
CALIFORNIA'S EPIDEMIC OF DEADLY
WILDFIRES CONTINUE TO WORSEN
WILDFIRE SMOKE CONSISTS OF
DIFFERENT GASES AND FINE
PARTICULATE.
PART [inaudible]
PARTICULATES.
PARTICLES.
THANK YOU -- SOME FROM BURNING
VEGETATION OTHER FROM BURNING
STRUCTURES AND OFTEN -- HAVE
BEEN BUILT WITH AS BEST AS LEAD
AND OTHER TOXINS.
I HEARD TO MOTIONS I DON'T WANNA
GO TOO FAR AB ELEVEN POINT WORLD
REQUIRE OSHA -- THE OCCUPATIONAL
SAFETY AND HEALTH STANDARDS
BOARD TO ADOPT EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS THAT REQUIRE
EMPLOYERS TO MAKE APPROPRIATE
EFFECTIVE RESPIRATORS AVAILABLE
TO OUTDOOR WORKERS ON ANY DAY
THOSE WORKERS COULD REASONABLY
BE EXPECTED BE EXPOSED TO
HARMFUL AT LEVELS OF WILD FIRE
SMOKE -- OF COURSE WE WOULD HAVE
PREFERRED PLAYERS SEND WORKERS
HOME.
PREFERABLY WITH PAY -- BUT UNDER.
THE EXTREME CONDITIONS AT LEAST
A RESPIRATOR IS WORN TED I
RESPECT LAST FOR MY VOTE THANK
YOU AND BEFORE WE BID.
HAVE MORE TESTIMONY WE HAVE A
MOTION AND BASED CHAIR FLORENCE
OR SECOND SECOND SECOND WAS
AMERICA THANK YOU PLEASE.
THEY GET YOUR KALRA MEMBERS
MITCH DYER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR THIS BILL TO BETTER
PROTECT OUTDOOR WORKERS FROM
EXPOSURE TO WILD FIRE SMOKE.
AS MOST OF US IN CALIFORNIA --
PAINFULLY AWARE THIS IS A HAZARD
THAT GETS WORSE EVERY YEAR --
AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT IF YOU
HAVE TO WORK OUTSIDE THESE
ENVIRONMENTS OF SOMETHING THAT
YOU'RE REALLY FAMILIAR WITH WE
SAW HAPPEN OVER AND OVER AGAIN
LAST YEAR
WHERE WORKERS WERE FORCED TO
WORK OUTSIDE WITH NOTHING NO
MASKS NO RESPIRATORS NO NOTHING
AND?
IT IT GOES A LOT BECAUSE PRETTY
FAR BEYOND JUST DAMAGING YOUR
THROAT MAKING A LITTLE BIT
HARDER TO BREATHE IT DOES
PERMANENT DAMAGE TO YOUR LONG
FUNCTION WE ALL INHALED A LOT OF
DIFFERENT CARCINOGENS SO ON
THERE'S A LOT OF PERMANENT
DAMAGE DONE AND THAT'S JUST FROM.
WALKING AROUND IF YOU HAVE TO
WORK IN THIS KIND OF AIR YOUR
SPENDING EIGHT HOURS EXERTING
YOURSELF ON THE DAMAGE IS FAR
WORSE.
AND SO WE DO HAVE EXISTING
REGULATIONS THAT ARE SUPPOSED TO
PROTECT WORKERS FROM THIS HAZARD
BUT THEY KIND OF SPANISH RANGE
FROM EITHER SO VAGUE THAT NO ONE
REALLY KNOWS WHAT TO DO WITH
THEM TOO SO CUMBERSOME THAT
EVERYONE JUST KIND OF IGNORES
THEM.
AND SO WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
IT IS PETITION THE STANDARDS
BOARD TO COME UP WITH NEW
EMERGENCY REGULATIONS THAT DO A
BETTER JOB OF PROTECTING WORKERS.
THAT PROCESS IS HAPPENING AND
IT'S GOING PRETTY WELL BUT WE
BELIEVE WE NEED A BILL TO KIND
OF GUIDE THE PROCESS IN A FEW
DIFFERENT WAYS ONE REASON IS
THAT WE WANT TO CLARIFY THE
THRESHOLD WHEN EMPLOYER ACTION
IS NECESSARY.
RIGHT NOW THE LAW SAYS THAT
BASICALLY EMPLOYERS ARE SUPPOSED
TO DO SOMETHING WHEN THERE'S A
HARMFUL EXPOSURE.
AND THERE'S A DEFINITION IN
THERE BUT IT KIND OF REQUIRES
EMPLOYERS TO BE BOTH DOCTORS AND
SCIENTISTS TO DETERMINE WHEN
SOMETHING IS HARMFUL AND SO WE
WANT TO MAKE IT A LITTLE BIT
MORE CLEAR BY TELLING THE
STANDARDS BOARD TO DO SOMETHING
RELATED TO THE AIR QUALITY INDEX.
IT'S MORE PUBLICLY AVAILABLE AND
MORE CLEAR WE ALSO WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE'S A VERY
TEMPERATE TEMPORARY VERY LIMITED
EXEMPTION FROM THE MEDICAL
EVALUATION AND FIT TESTING
REQUIREMENTS UNDER CURRENT LAW
THAT.
WOULD ESSENTIALLY REQUIRED
EMPLOYER BRING A DOCTOR OUT AND
DO AN EXAMINATION OF EVERY
SINGLE OUTDOOR WORKER BEFORE
THEY COULD WEAR AND IN NINETY
FIVE MASK AND THAT'S WE THINK
SOMETHING THAT'S PRETTY
UNREALISTIC FOR MOST EMPLOYERS
SO WE WANT TO COME UP WITH A
VERY LIMITED EXEMPTION TO THAT.
AND ALSO AN EFFECTIVE DATE SO
THAT WE HAVE SOMETHING STRONG
AND PLACE FOR THIS YEAR'S FIRE
SEASON I AND WE ARE JUST
[inaudible]
FOR THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS -- I'M IN COTTON FROM
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION AND I'M
ALSO SPEAKING TODAY ON BEHALF OF
WORK SAFE ANOTHER OF CO SPONSOR --
A VERY A VAST BODY OF STUDIES
HAS DETERMINED THAT EXPOSURE TO
WILDFIRE SMOKE COMPROMISE LUNG
FUNCTION.
EXACERBATE HEART PROBLEMS AND
CAUSED DIFFICULTY BREATHING.
AND FARMWORKERS LANDSCAPERS AND
OTHER OUTDOOR WORKERS URGENTLY
NEED PROTECTION.
A CLEAR PROTECTION -- THAT WOULD --
REQUIRE RESPIRATORS BE MADE
AVAILABLE -- WHEN THEY'RE ON
HEALTHY LEVELS OF WILDFIRE SMOKE?
THE AIR QUALITY INDEX IS A
READILY AVAILABLE -- WAITED
DETERMINE WHEN -- RESPIRATOR
SHOULD BE REQUIRED SHOULD -- BE
MADE AVAILABLE AND AND IT'S BEEN --
IT IS ACCEPTED BY THE CONSENSUS
OF HEALTH EXPERT WE URGE YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THIS GERMAN RECESS OR DO AS A
BEHALF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL ALSO
CO SPONSOR OF THIS BILL FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
VERY GOOD -- SHE HARM TO HAVE
THE CALIFORNIA PLUMMET LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
DOES IT IS TENDER ABOUT VEHICLE
RIGHTS ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT.
A DRY RIVER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MICHELLE F. ON BEHALF OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SHE DOES NOT HAVE THE TEAMSTERS
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KATIE WHICH IT FOR LEGAL AID AT
WORK IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY BRING ABOUT TWO COMMUNITY
IS THERE ANY -- FURTHER COMMENT.
QUESTIONS.
HOW DOES ALLOWS LATER DISCOVER
MORE ABOUT PARTICULAR MATTER
THAN EVER WOULD IMAGINE AND PM
TWO POINT -- FIVE TO PAY WHICH
IS -- NO TWO POINT FIVE
MICROMETRES EXTREMELY DANGEROUS
THAT'S THE PARTICULAR MATTER
THAT COMES FROM THESE FIRES.
WHEN WE HIVE HIGH LEVELS THE BAY
AREA WE TELL PEOPLE TO STAY IN
THEIR HOMES -- LITERALLY AND SO
I'M VERY GRATEFUL FOR THIS BILL
ON THE ISLE OF SPEECH CERTAIN
THANK YOU AUTHORS WELL
[inaudible]
CLOSE.
RESPECT LAST VERY VOTE.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHTS RESERVED WE HAVE A
BY SUMMER CARILLO.
OF WILL PLEASE.
DO PASSED TO APPROPRIATE KALRA.
AYE KALRA AYE FLORA AYE FLORA
AYE.
CARILLO ID GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ
I JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER I THREE OF US THREE
OF US HI RIGHT THE BILL IS OUT
[inaudible] TO MARK.
HAVE A HAPPY LIFE.
ALL RIGHT MISTER CHAIRMAN
ASSUMING WE'RE DOING AB
[inaudible]
FOUR OH THREE HI SIR.
READY WHEN YOU ARE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AB FOUR OH THREE INCREASES THE
STATURE LIMITATIONS FOR FILING A
WORK RETALIATION CLAIM FROM SIX
MONTHS TO THREE YEARS AND HAS
THE ABILITY TO SEEK ATTORNEY'S
FEES FOR PREVAILING EMPLOYEES.
WORKPLACE RETALIATION OCCURS
WHEN EMPLOYEES DISCHARGED
THREATENED WITH A DISCHARGED
EMOTE SUSPENDER SUBJECT
EMPLOYEES TO AN ADVERSE ACTION
INCLUDING THREATS OF DEPORTATION
FOR ACCESS TO EXERCISE THEIR
RIGHTS.
UNDER LABOR CODE TELL YOU SHE'S
NOT ONLY PERVASIVE BUT ALSO
GROWING PROBLEM TO THE CURRENT
POLITICAL CLIMATE SURROUNDING
IMMIGRATION.
IN BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN RETALIATION COMPLETE
REPORT TO LEGISLATURE THE LABOR
COMMISSION REPORT RECEIVING
NINETY FIVE COMPLAINTS.
ALLEGING VIOLATIONS THE LABOR
CODE INSIDE DOUBLING.
OF THE NUMBER RETALIATION PLANS
BASED UPON SEX RACE OR ETHNICITY
FROM THE PREVIOUS YEAR.
AND IT TOOK SPECIFIC NOTE OF AN
INSTANT ROLE WORKER TO BE A
DAILY FROM MEXICO INTO THE U. S.
WAS REPORTED BY FEDERAL CUSTOMS
AND BORDER PATROL BY HIS
EMPLOYER IN RETALIATION FOR HIS
FILING.
OF AN UNPAID WAGE CLAIM.
AS A RESULT THE REQUISITE TANDAS
TOURIST PIECE WAS CONFISCATED HE
WAS REMOVED FROM THE UNITED
STATES.
UPON LEARNING OF THE EMPLOYERS
ACT THE BORDER AGENT WHO
DETAINED THE WORKER WAS THE
PERSONAL ENCOURAGE THE WORKER TO
SEEK ASSISTANCE FROM THE STATE
RETALIATION.
IN RESPONSE ABOUT RETALIATION
COMPLAINT ONE AND THE CASE IS
ALSO REFERRED TO DEAL AS SEIZE
LEGAL UNIT FOR FURTHER
ENFORCEMENT.
NOW IMAGINE THE WORK WAS NOT
LUCKY ENOUGH TO ACROSS PASSED
WITH A BORDER AGENT MORE
INFORMED OF HIS RIGHTS.
THE MATCH OF THE WORK WAS
DETAINED DEPORTED IN UNABLE TO
OBTAIN HIS RIGHT TO BACK MAJORS.
AND IMAGINE THE WORK WAS UNABLE
TO MEET THE CURRENT. SIX MONTH
WINDOW IN ORDER FOLLOWS
RETALIATION CLAIM DUE TO THAT
UNLAWFUL DEPORT DEPORTATION.
THIS IS JUST ONE EXAMPLE OF MANY
OF WHY THE EXTENSION OF THE
CLAIMS TIMELINE IS NECESSARY.
REGARDING ATTORNEYS FEES TWO
YEARS AGO LEGISLATURE ADOPTED
THE GOVERNOR SIGNED SB NINETY
SIX INTO LAW WHICH PROVIDED THE
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR STANDARDS
ENFORCEMENT THE RIGHT TO RESUME
ALL ATTORNEYS FEES.
FROM THE EMPLOYER IF THE LABOR
COMMITTEE COMMISSIONER PREVAILS.
THIS BILL SIMPLY BUILT UPON SB
NINETY SIX BY PROVIDING THAT
SAME RIGHT TO PRIVATE INSURANCE
TO TAKE THESE RETALIATION CASES
OFTEN ON PRO PRO BONO STATUS.
ON BEHALF BEHALF WORKERS AND IT
ONLY IN TITLES.
OF IT ONLY INTO A TITLES FEES IF
THE WORKER PREVAILS.
OFTENTIMES THE BURDEN OF PAYING
ATTORNEYS FEES CAN BE A
DETERRENT FOR AGREE OF WORKERS
ESPECIALLY THOSE WERE LOW WAGE
EVEN IF THEY HAVE A STRONG CLAIM.
THIS IS NOT A BILL THAT IS
INTENDED TO INCREASE THE
NEGATION OF THE OPPOSITION
ARGUES RATHER IT PROVIDES
ADDITIONAL SENSIBLE AND
REASONABLE WAYS FOR WORKERS TO
PURSUE RECOURSE.
WHEN THEY HAVE BEEN UNFAIRLY
RETALIATED AGAINST FOR INVOKING
THEIR LEGAL RIGHTS UNDER STATE
LAW?
I HAVE WITH ME.
AMERICA YOUR USER HARA AND
CAITLIN VEGAS BECAUSE PART OF
THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR.
OKAY MISTER VICE CHAIR MEMBERS
MARICA YOSHIHARU ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT
LAWYERS ASSOCIATION.
OUR MEMBERS PROVIDE LEGAL
ASSISTANCE OF REPRESENTATION TO
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIA WORKERS
AND OUR MEMBERSHIP INCLUDES.
ATTORNEYS IN PRIVATE PRACTICE AS
WELL AS NONPROFIT LEGAL SERVICES
PROVIDERS AND I CAN TELL YOU
THAT OUR ATTORNEYS VERY OFTEN DO
NOT HEAR FROM WORKERS ABOUT
RETALIATION COMPLAINS UNTIL WELL
AFTER SIX MONTHS.
IF THE RETALIATION INVOLVES
TERMINATION THE WORKERS FIRED
THEN WORKERS MIGHT COME FORWARD
RIGHT AWAY BUT AS WE ALL KNOW
RETALIATION OFTEN IS MUCH MORE
SUBTLE THAT INCLUDES BEING NOT
BEING PASSED UP FOR PROMOTION
THERE WERE HOURS ARE CUT THIRD.
SHIFT IS CHANGED IN THOSE
SITUATIONS WORKERS OFTEN JUST
TRY TO WAIT THINGS OUT AND HOPE
THINGS GET BETTER.
AND BY THAT AND OFTENTIMES
THINGS DON'T GET BETTER AND AT
THAT POINT THEY WILL TRY TO
ENFORCE THEIR RIGHTS IN WITH THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER ONLY TO FIND
OUT THAT THEY MISS THEIR SIX
MONTH FILING DEADLINE.
SO WE THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
WORKERS ARE NOT DOT TO DOT
DENIED ACCESS TO JUSTICE BY
EXTENDING THAT FILING DEADLINE.
THIS BILL ALSO WILL ALLOW
WORKERS TO RECOVER THEIR
ATTORNEYS FEES IF THE
RETALIATION INVOLVES WHISTLE
BLOWING WHICH WE THINK IS VERY
IMPORTANT -- LABOR CODE SECTION
ELEVEN A TWO POINT FIVE IS THE
MAIN WHISTLEBLOWER STATUTE THAT
PROTECTS WORKERS FROM
RETALIATION IF THEY REPORT
VIOLATIONS OF LOCAL STATE OR
FEDERAL LAWS.
ON IN TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN THE
STATUE WAS AMENDED BY SB SIX SIX
SIX IN AB TWO SIXTY THREE TO
ALSO ENSURE THAT IMMIGRANT
WORKERS AND THEIR FAMILIES ARE
PROTECTED FROM A TALLY ASIAN.
ART TOURNEY'S USE LABOR CODE
SECTION ELEVEN OH TOO BUT POINT
FIVE TO PROTECT WORKERS WHO
REPORT SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND
ASSAULT IN THE WORKPLACE WE'VE
HAD WORKERS WE HAVE I'D
ATTORNEYS REPRESENT WILL SO
BLOWERS WHO -- THE PHARMACY TECH
WHO WHO WAS RIVER WHO WAS DONE.
SHE WAS TOLD TO DILATE -- TO
DILUTES SORRY TO THE LOO --
CHEMO MEDICATION AND WHEN SHE
REPORTED IT TO OSHA SHE WAS
FIRED JUST.
WEEKS LATER.
SO IN THIS SITUATION WHERE YOU
HAVE A WORKER WHO IS ABOUT TO
BLOW THE WHISTLE ON FRAUD ABUSE
MISCONDUCT IN THE WORKPLACE IT'S
ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT THE WORKERS
ABLE TO SECURE LEGAL COUNSEL.
AND WITHOUT ATTORNEYS HIS
PROVISION THAT MEANS THAT THE
WORKERS GOING TO HAVE TO PAY FOR
THEIR LEGAL REPRESENTATION
THROUGH A PORTION OF THE AWARD
THEY RECOVER AT THE END OF THE
CASE.
AND FOR A LOT OF WORKERS THAT
MAKES IT REALLY HARD TO FIND AN
ATTORNEY BECAUSE OF THE COST OF
LITIGATION IS GOING TO EXCEED
THAT CONTINGENCY FEE.
THAT THE ATTORNEY IS GOING TO BE
ABLE TO RECOVER FROM THE AWARD
THEY JUST CAN'T TAKE ON THOSE
CASES SO WE THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO ALIGN THIS WAS A BLUR STATUE
WITH ALL OTHER STATE AND FEDERAL
WHISTLEBLOWER STATUTES THAT HAVE
A AN ATTORNEY'S FEE PROVISION.
WE THINK THAT THAT WAS A BLOWER
LAWS ARE ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT TO
PROTECTING WORKERS WHO ARE
RISKING THEIR JOBS TO TO REPORT
WASTE FRAUD AND ABUSE AND FOR
THOSE REASONS WE STRONGLY URGE
YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS CAITLIN
VEGA FOR THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION -- WHEN AN EMPLOYER
ENGAGES IN RETALIATION THAT
MEANS THAT THE WORKER HAS
ALREADY BEEN THE VICTIM OF AN
UNDERLYING ACT THEY'VE HAD WAGES
STOLEN THEY'VE BEEN SEXUALLY
HARASSED?
THEY HAVEN'T BEEN PAID FAIRLY
ARE TREATED FAIRLY AND THEN WHEN
THEY REPORTED THEY GET
RETALIATED AGAINST.
THIS IS SO THAT MEANS THAT THIS
IS A REPEAT OFFENDER THIS IS AN
EMPLOYER WHO IS NOT ONLY
VIOLATING THE LAW BUT THEN
ACTING IN A WAY -- TO TO
INTIMIDATE WORKERS FOR TRYING TO
COME FORWARD AND SPEAK OUT.
A TO LIMIT THOSE KINDS OF CLAIMS
TO SIX MONTHS IS REALLY A WAY OF
INSULATING EMPLOYERS WHO ENGAGE
IN THIS KIND OF BEHAVIOR --
ALMOST ALL WORKERS TO REPORT
WORKPLACE VIOLATIONS DO FACE
RETALIATION AND SO ALLOWING THEM
THE TIME TO COME FORWARD AND
REPORT.
IS AN INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
CHANGE TO THE LOST SO WE'RE HERE
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
I TESTIFIED EARLIER THAT I WAS
RETALIATED.
BECAUSE I SPOKE OUT OF BOUNDS.
ABOUT GENDER PAY DISPARITIES.
I FILED AN EQUAL PAY CLAIM AND
RETALIATION CLAIM WITH THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER.
BUT IT WAS REJECTED BECAUSE THEY
SAID IT WAS MORE THAN SIX MONTHS
AFTER RETALIATION HAD BEGUN.
I FILED MY EQUAL PAY RETALIATION
CLAIMS.
BECAUSE I COULDN'T FIND A LAWYER.
THAT WOULD TAKE MY CASE.
WORKERS ABILITY TO FIND A LAWYER
SHOULD NOT DICTATE THE AMOUNT OF
TIME THAT SHE HAS TO SEEK
JUSTICE FOR BEING RETALIATE
RETALIATED AGAINST.
THANK YOU FOR GIVING ME THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
ABOUT MY SITUATION AND I URGE AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS SISTER
DEALS AND WE HAVE THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL ALSO [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANDREA RIVER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MUCH.
DOES A CUSTOMER OF AB RECORDS
ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
KATIE WHICH IT FOR LEGAL AID AT
WORK IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
YOU ONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEN ON ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON VICE CHAIR
MEMBERS THANK YOU AGAIN SO MUCH
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
TODAY MY NAME'S LAURA CURTIS
NAME HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
AND WE ARE IN OPPOSITION TO
EIGHTY FOUR OH THREE AT THE SAME
POSITION THAT WE HAD LAST YEAR
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE
AND HIS STAFF.
IN TALKING WITH US -- ABOUT THIS
BILL AND WORKING WITH US HOWEVER
OUR CONCERNS ARE NOT WITH THE
EXTENSION OF THE STATUTE
IMITATIONS -- WE ARE THAT PART
PROVISION WE ARE FINE WITH --
BECAUSE THAT PROVISION ALLOWS
FOR THE EMPLOYEE TO FILE
RETALIATION CLAIM THROUGH THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER AND THROUGH
THE DEPARTMENT OF LABOR
STANDARDS ENFORCEMENT -- WHICH
HOLD THE HAND OF THE EMPLOYEE
BUT WE WE ARE CONCERNED WITH IS
THE THE ADDITIONAL ATTORNEY FEE
RECOVERY AND OUR CONCERN WITH
THAT IS IS THAT.
EMPLOYEES ALREADY HAVE THE
OPTION TO GO THROUGH CIVIL COURT
THEY CAN FILE THIS CLAIM IN
CIVIL COURT AND SO IT WHEN THEY
FILE IT WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
LABOR STANDARDS ENFORCEMENT IT'S
OFTENTIMES BECAUSE THE EMPLOYEE
DOES NOT WANT THE MORE LITIGIOUS
PROCESS THEY DON'T WANT TO HAVE
TO GO.
THROUGH COR SO IF YOU ADD THE
ATTORNEY FEE RECOVERY PROVISION
TO THIS PROCESS WHERE THE
EMPLOYER ACTUALLY HAS NO RIGHT
TO HEARING THEY HAVE NO
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE EVIDENCE
THEY HAVE NO PER -- OPPORTUNITY
TO ENSURE THAT THEY CAN
REMEDIATE THOSE ATTORNEYS FEES
THAT COULD QUICKLY ADD UP.
AND THEN WE'RE CONCERNED THAT IT
WILL BECOME MORE LITIGIOUS IN
MORE OF A REASON FOR FRIVOLOUS
PLANES AND SO WHILE WE DO
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S INTENT
WITH THE BILL OUR CONCERN IS IS
THAT ADDING A ONE SIDED
ATTORNEY'S FEES PROVISION WILL
ACTUALLY MAKE THIS PROCESS THAT
HAS BEEN WORKING.
MORE LITIGIOUS WHEN THE EMPLOYEE
ALREADY HAS THE OPPORTUNITY FILE
IN CIVIL COURT AND FOR THOSE
REASONS WE ARE POST THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE.
WE HAVE A SIDEBAR.
YES WE WERE.
WE'RE ALWAYS IT ALWAYS
CONFERRING WE'RE ALWAYS
CONFERRING YEAH ABSOLUTELY.
YOU HAVE THE GAVEL NOW.
OKAY NO WE'RE DEFINITELY NOT
SUPPORT QUITE YET.
JUST ONE MORE AMENDMENT ONE MORE
MOMENT -- WE SHARE THE SAME
CONCERNS THAT MISS CURTIS
OUTLINE WHICH IS NO OBJECTION TO
THE STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS.
WHICH I THINK IS THE PRIMARY
FOCUS.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE WORKED
WITH THE LABOR COMMISSIONER AND
CENTER HERTZBERG ON SB THREE OH
SIX WHICH IS REFERENCE AT THE
TOP OF YOUR ANALYSIS ON PAGE.
THREE WHICH GAVE THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER INJUNCTIVE
AUTHORITY AND GREATER POWER TO
DEAL WITH RETALIATION CLAIMS AND
WE PREFER TO HAVE SOME TIME. TO
SEE HOW THAT PROCESS IS UTILIZED
AND HOW WELL IT IS WORKING
BEFORE WE AUTHORIZE THE ABILITY
TO SUE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
IN OPPOSITION.
IF ANY MILLION ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION A JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITY TO OPPOSITION
THANK YOU.
BRIAN LITTLE CALIFORNIA FARM
HERE FOR THE REASON STATE OF MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE CHAMBER IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH.
KATIE HANSON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION WERE HERE
IN OPPOSITION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MATTHEW OUT WITH WESTERN ROLLERS
ALSO OPPOSED.
HER ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
CNN THE QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
SEE AN NINE MISTER WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE SPIKE VAST FROM
ABOUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT IS
ACTIVE LEGAL.
MOTION IS THE PAST TWO JUDICIARY
KALRA.
AYE KALRA AYE FLORA.
FLORA NO CREO [inaudible]
CARILLO I GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE THREE OF US.
THREE OF US I MISTER CHAIR THAT
BILLS OUT IN HUSING AB SIX
TWENTY FIVE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR.
SB -- SIX TWENTY FIVE EXTENDS
THE EMPLOYEE RETENTION 10% BID
PREFERENCE TO ALL PUBLIC TRANSIT
CONTRACTS AWARDED BY THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
THE 10% BID PREFERENCES SCORING
CREDIT ON A STATE BID FOR A
TRANSIT OPERATOR THAT
VOLUNTARILY AGREES TO RETAIN THE
QUALIFIED EMPLOYEES.
OF THE PREVIOUS CONTRACTOR
CRIMINAL NINETY DAYS THE WAITERS
AND BENEFITS OF ANY RETAINED
EMPLOYER NOT REQUIRED TO BE THE
SAME AS ON THE PREVIOUS
CONTRACTOR.
UP UNDER CURRENT LAW IN TWO
THOUSAND THREE THAT SLOW.
LEGISLATION WAS SIGNED TO
PROVIDE A 10% BID PREFERENCE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
PUBLIC TRANSIT OF CONTRACTS A
BITTER THAT BONTA AGREED RETAIN
THE QUALIFIED EMPLOYEES THE
PREVIOUS CONTRACTOR.
THE PURPOSE OF THAT LAW WAS TO
ADDRESS THE HIGH RATE OF
TURNOVER OCCURRING IN THE
CONTRACT A SEGMENT OF PUBLIC
TRANSIT.
HOWEVER THAT LEGISLATION NOT
PROVIDED BIDDING PREFERENCE FOR
BIDDERS ON STATE CONTRACTS -- IN
PUBLIC TRANSIT AGREED TO RETAIN
EXISTING EMPLOYEES.
STATE TRANSIT WORKERS JOBS ARE
AT RISK DUE TO CONTRACTING OUT
FOR EXAMPLE STATE EMPLOYEES WERE
SUBTLE DRIVERS AT HEARST CASTLE.
LOST THEIR JOBS OR NEW
CONTRACTOR CAME IN HAD A BID
PREFERENCE BEEN IN PLACE A
PROSPECTIVE CONTRACTOR WOULD
HAVE AN INCENTIVE TO KEEP THE
DRIVERS IN THE DRIVERS WILL
LIKELY STILL BE WORKING.
TODAY WE MUST ACT TO PREVENT
UNNECESSARY AND COSTLY TRANSIT
WORKER LAYOFFS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR IBOOK WOULD BE TO TEST
BY SHANE GUSMAN WITH THE
TEAMSTERS.
SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
INLAND BOATMEN UNION AND THE
TEAMSTERS -- BOTH CO SPONSORS OF
THIS BILL -- MISTER KALRA SAID
IT ALL -- WE SUPPORT THE BILL
IT'S WORKED VERY WELL AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL IT HASN'T INCREASED
COST AND IT HELPED WORKERS
RETAIN THEIR JOBS -- DRIVE UP.
ROBERT ESTRADA AND REGIONAL
DIRECTOR OF THE INLAND OPENS
UNION OF THE PACIFIC WE ARE CO
SPONSORS AND I WOULD LIKE TO SAY.
THANK YOU TO TO CHAIRMAN KALRA
FOR CARRYING THIS BILL AND TO
THE COMMITTEE AT LARGE FOR
HOPEFULLY PASSING WITH A STRONG.
AYE VOTE -- SO THIS IS NOT
ACADEMIC TO US THIS IS NOT
MERELY HYPOTHETICAL -- EITHER
PASSED OR PROLOGUE WE HAVE HAD --
WE HAVE AN EXPERIENCE WHERE DO
CONTRACTORS OF COME IN.
AND WHERE IN FROM ONE DAY TO THE
NEXT THE JOB IS THE SAME THE
SERVICE IS THE SAME.
AND AND EVEN INTO TIMES THE
VESSELS REMAIN THE SAME THE ONLY
THING PERVERSELY THAT CHANGED
WAS THAT.
V. OBJECTIVELY MOST QUALIFIED
AND MOST EXPERIENCED CREW
MEMBERS WERE REMOVED FROM THE
EQUATION.
AND WE DON'T THINK THAT'S
REASONABLE FAIR OR JUST
ESPECIALLY IN A STATE LIKE
CALIFORNIA WHERE WERE EMPLOYMENT
AND AND WORKERS MATTER.
SO WHAT WE HAVE BEFORE US NOW
GOING FORWARD IS THERE ARE A
COUPLE OF ANGEL ISLAND -- STATE
FOR CONTRACTS THAT BETTER OUT
THERE ONE OF WHICH IS CURRENTLY
UNIONIZED ONE OF WHICH IS NOT --
WHETHER OR NOT.
OUR OUR UNION CONTRACTED COMPANY
PICKS UP AN ADDITIONAL.
CONTRACT THAT THEY DON'T HAVE OR
WHETHER OR NOT THE CURRENT
CONTRACT IS LOST TO A NON UNION
CONTRACTOR.
IN EITHER OF THOSE INSTANCES WE
DON'T BELIEVE THAT THE THAT THE
WORKERS SHOULD SUFFER WE WOULD
NOT WANT THE CURRENT WORKERS OF
RECORD TO SUFFERED SHE JUST TO
IN JUST TO ADD MORE WORK TO OUR
OWN UNION RANKS.
WE WOULD THINK THAT THE JOB ONE
OF ANY UNION AND ANY JUST
SOCIETY IS TO PROTECT THOSE
PEOPLE WERE WORKING.
AND AND TO GIVE A PREFERENCE
WILL BENEFIT TO ANYBODY WHO SAYS
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO COME IN
AND TRY TO HELP PROTECT THOSE
WORKERS SO WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE PLEASE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT.
SEE AND NOT ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
SEE AN NONE BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE.
NOTHING MISTER CHAIR WOULD LIKE
TO CLOSE AT THE ASPEN AYE VOTE.
EXECUTIVE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS THE PAST TWO
APPROPRIATIONS KALRA.
KALRA AYE FLORA BY FLORA AYE FOR
YOU.
REAL AYE.
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER I THREE OF US.
THREE OF US HI [inaudible]
BOB [inaudible]
DONNAN.
WELL HELLO ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU BYE SURE FLORA.
WE DO HAVE ONE BILL ON CALL.
AND SO WE CAN LET THE CALL ON AB
TWELVE TWENTY FOUR SOME NUMBER
GRAY.
B. TWELVE TWENTY FOUR ABSENT
MEMBERS FLORA.
FLORA NOT VOTING.
JONES SAWYER.
HI JONES.
JOHN JOHNSON [inaudible]
HI THREE OF US [inaudible]
THREE OF US.
OKAY SO THE BILL IS OUT.
MADAM SECRETARY FREAKING THOSE
OR NOT SHE'S ANYONE WHO IS OUT
ON RIGHT THERE ARE SOME YEAH SO
THAT'S GOING TO THOSE.
I AM RIGHT.
AB THREE SEVENTY EIGHT ABSENT
MEMBERS JONES SAWYER.
BY JONES SAWYER I THREE OF US
THREE OF US HI. ONE EIGHTY SIX
TWENTY ONE ABSENT MEMBERS FLORA.
SEVEN TWENTY ONE EXCUSE ME HI
SEVEN TWENTY ONE LARA HI.
JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE THREE OF US.
THREE OF US I AB SEVEN FIFTY
EIGHT FLORA.
FLORA I JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER I'D THREE OF US.
THREE OF US.
YEAH.
LOPEZ WROTE.
AB ELEVEN FIFTY EIGHT ABSENT
MEMBERS FLORA.
FLORA HI JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER I FOR YOU TO WANT.
TO G. OVER YOU.
LAST QUESTION.
AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT ABSENT
MEMBERS FLORA [inaudible]
FLORA NO.
JONES SAWYER -- JONES SAWYER HI.
SOME OF THE CONSENT CALENDAR AB
EIGHTEEN OH FOUR CARILLO.
JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER I THREE OF US.
THREE OF US HI.
MAYBE OKAY YEAH AND SO WHAT WILL
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR SUMMER DO
YOU HAVE.
THINK HE'S ON MY LEFT SO -- WILL
HOLD UP A FEW MINUTES RAN.
THE SEASONS WITH.
THAT WOULD BE REQUIRED.
YEAH OKAY WE DRAFT [inaudible]
REALLY.
I AGREE WITH THAT
.
WE ARE ADJOURNED